So, jetzt aber.
Fast hätte alles so gut funktioniert. Leute, hier ist die Freakshow.
Wir sind wieder da. Zu einem ungewöhnlichen Zeitpunkt. Wer jetzt live zuhört,
wundert sich, wundert sich. Draußen ist ja noch hell.
Genau. Kommen wir gleich zu. Aus technischen Gründen. Diese Sendung wird an
einem Freitagnachmittag ausgestrahlt.
Wenn man die Zeit zu einer MEZ heranzieht, bei mir ist es dann schon dunkel.
Ich bin nämlich hier aus der Ferne zugeschaltet zu den Herren und die Herren
sind Roddy. Hallo Roddy.
Hallo.
Und Ralf, wer soll das anderes sein?
Einen wunderschönen guten Mittag.
Genau, ich bin Tim und wir befinden uns trotzdem zusammen.
Aber ich bin nämlich gerade in einer anderen Zeitzone und deswegen war das ein
etwas größerer Aufwasch, hier das Ganze so zusammenzubekommen.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich bin jetzt vorsichtig optimistisch, dass das ganz gut
funktioniert. Jetzt bin ich nämlich mal remote.
Du kannst ja mal erzählen, wie das aus eurer Perspektive sich gerade darstellt.
Also akustisch erstmal hört man, finde ich, gar keinen Unterschied.
Also da muss man sagen, ist Zoom mittlerweile schon weit fortgeschritten dank Corona.
Und du hast, glaube ich, hattest du vorhin gesagt, auch diesen Musikermodus
aktiviert, dass da nichts an Kompression und Pseudo-Rauschreduzierung und sowas daherkommt.
Also die Audiospur hört sich jetzt schon ohne Lokalaufnahme sehr gut an hier.
Und ansonsten ist unser Setup eigentlich so wie sonst auch, also sprich rechts
haben wir deinen großen Curved Monitor und da läuft friedlich ein Ultraschall,
noch in der alten Version,
ich prangere es an und oben der Beamer und unten drunter halt der Gastbildschirm
und da bist jetzt halt du statt andere Leute als Gast, aber psychologisch würde ich sagen,
fühlt es sich eigentlich im Moment noch an wie eine ganz normale Freakshow, die wir hier machen.
Wenn es so etwas gibt.
Ja, also Latenz total gut. Wir hatten jetzt hier auch schon ein bisschen vorgeplänkelt und so.
Man hat jetzt auch nicht den Eindruck, ständig muss ich wieder irgendwie aufhören
zu sprechen, weil irgendjemand anders von draußen möchte irgendwie da mit rein.
Aber du hast auch, glaube ich, gutes Internet, hast du vorhin mal erläutert.
Ich habe hier exzellentes Internet. Der Speedtest sagt, ich habe hier ein Gigabit
down und ein halbes Gigabit up.
Das ist hier so, was man hier normal nennt.
Das kleine Besteck.
Ich kann immer dazu sagen, wo ich gerade bin. Ich bin gerade in... Genau so der Standard.
Man sieht ja immer irgendwie irgendwelche Techniker rumwurschteln,
wie sie irgendwie draußen irgendwelche Leitungen zusammenballern.
Aber hier ist halt irgendwie alles auf Glasfaser und hier nimmt man halt irgendwie
richtig am Internet teil, nicht so wie bei uns.
Wo bin ich? Ich bin in Malaysia, genauer bin ich gerade auf der Insel Penang.
Und ja, habe hier gutes Netz, gutes Essen, gutes Wetter und bin an sich auch
ganz zufrieden, muss ich sagen, mit der Gesamtsituation.
Ja, das Essen ist glaube ich mein Hauptneidfaktor in meiner ganzen Geschichte.
Ich könnte mich glaube ich auch echt den Rest meines Lebens einfach nur asiatisch ernähren.
Das wäre eine gute Sache und gar keine Einschränkung. Man muss allerdings sagen,
dass das Videobild von dir, das ist schon sehr klötzerig. Also dafür,
dass du jetzt da so eine Datenrate an den Start bringst, kannst du da eigentlich noch irgendwas tun?
Also das ist weit entfernt von irgendwie Hi-Res oder High Definition und Full HD oder sowas.
Also das ist okay, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es jetzt total stört,
aber wenn man schon mal Bandbreite hat, hätte ich gedacht, dass Zoom die vielleicht
auch durchreicht und da jetzt mal die Videoqualität noch ein bisschen hoch schraubt.
Jetzt wollen wir natürlich nicht her.
Auch gerade unklar, was da der Grund für sein kann.
Weil eigentlich ist es jetzt auch okay, aber es ist jetzt halt nicht super toll.
Du weißt doch, wie Tim aussieht.
Ich mache einfach mal ein Screenshot für unsere Gäste, damit die mal sehen,
wie das hier so alles wirkt.
Das ist bestimmt das Netz.
Ja, müssen wir jetzt nicht.
Wir wissen jetzt nicht genau, an welcher Stelle das den Tod stirbt.
Irgendwas ist ja immer.
Soviel zum Vorgeplänkel. Also ich bin ja auf Reisen. Ich hatte das ja angekündigt
und bewege mich hier so quer durch Südostasien und habe so meine ersten Etappen auch schon hinter mir.
Kann ich mal so vielleicht ein bisschen erzählen, falls es euch interessiert.
Ich war jetzt in Singapur.
Allerdings nur ein Wochenende. Mir trägt das nicht, weil es ist ja so ein bisschen
so Dubai nett, kann man sagen.
Da steht doch aber dieses, finde ich, doch sehr, sehr coole Gebäude auf diesen
vier Stelzen, was in so einem Halbrund irgendwie gebaut ist.
Ich gucke mal eben gerade. Das ist so einer dieser...
Du meinst das Ding oben mit diesem fetten Pool oben drauf?
Ja, genau.
Ja, das ist hier so ein bisschen das Wahrzeichen geworden.
Genau, das finde ich schon... Das finde ich sehr krass, genau.
Was aussieht wie so ein Schiff, was auf Stelzen irgendwie so läuft.
Also ich muss sagen, ich finde es so ein bisschen asymmetrisch.
Vergessen wieder, wie heißt denn das Ding überhaupt?
Irgendwie wird es bestimmt gleich raus. Ich schaue auch nochmal kurz.
Ja, kann man irgendwie machen. Mein Film ist es irgendwie nicht so richtig.
Ist halt so Hochhaus mit viel Hotel drin und mit unten so einer fetten,
völlig übertriebenen Shopping Mall, wie das ja hier sowieso üblich ist.
Also alles mal so ein bisschen zu übertreiben, speziell die Shopping-Malls.
Und das ist dann halt nochmal so eine richtig übertriebene Shopping-Mall,
wo übrigens auch Apple einen Apple-Store hat.
Ah, okay.
Und zwar haben sie den natürlich dann auch gleich,
nicht einfach nur so in die Shopping-Mall reingebaut, weil das wäre ja zu einfach.
Ja, sondern diese Shopping-Mall-Geschichte, wie heißt denn dieses Teil,
Marina Bay heißt das, genau, Marina Bay, also ihr könnt ja mal nach Marina Bay,
wie heißt das Ding nochmal, Marina Bay Sands, genau, Marina Bay Sands.
Das sind diese drei Hochhäuser, wo oben wie so eine Flunder da oben nochmal
so eine Etage draufgelegt wurde, wo dann die eine Seite so ein durchgehender
Pool ist und auf der anderen Seite ist das alles so ein bisschen so parkmäßig
und da können dann die Touris hochfahren.
Ich habe das nicht gemacht, mir war es das nicht wert. Und die Aussicht genießen.
Davor ist dann nochmal so ein künstlich angelegter Park auf so einer künstlich angelegten Insel.
Es ist alles ganz pompös und alles ganz groß und viel von allem immer so.
Also Singapur ist genauso wie Dubai so völlig übertrieben, weil die haben halt
einfach die Kohle und It shows.
Aber man muss auch sagen, es ist aber auch wirklich ein interessantes Experiment.
Also dieses Land hat sich innerhalb von 50, 60 Jahren, mal kann man mal sagen,
gut, sie haben ein, zwei geografische Vorteile gehabt,
aber die haben sie halt auch voll ausgenutzt und das Beste draus gemacht und
eigentlich einen ganz beachtlichen Stadtstaat dahin gelegt, nachdem sie ja eigentlich
so von Malaysia so ein bisschen beschissen wurden.
Die waren ja eigentlich erst Teil von Malaysia, aber dann hat Malaysia Singapur rausgeschmissen.
Das hat immer so ein bisschen was mit so Bevölkerungsanteilen,
chinesische versus muslimische Bevölkerung und so weiter zu tun.
Auf jeden Fall wollten sie die irgendwie nicht haben und dann war das einfach
nur so ein Fischerdorf, was aber ganz gut gelegen war.
Und daraus haben sie halt dann irgendwie diesen großen Hafen gebaut und haben
sich dann eben mehrere sehr gut funktionierende Standbeine gemacht.
Also einerseits ist halt dieser Hafen, das ist so das Zwischenlager.
Da müssen halt irgendwie alle Schiffe aus China, die nach Europa fahren, müssen da vorbei.
Deswegen sind sie da als Umschlagplatz ganz groß. Das ist auch die größte Tankstelle der Welt.
Also nirgendwo wird irgendwie so viel Sprit abgegeben wie dort,
den sie ja nicht selber liefern, sondern den sie sozusagen da nur verkaufen.
Und dann haben sie sich natürlich auch als Finanzplatz, als internationaler
Finanzplatz etabliert und sind halt so zwischen den amerikanischen und europäischen
Börsen da quasi Chef der jeweiligen Zeitzone und deswegen läuft es da ganz gut
und deswegen haben sie eine Menge Kohle und ja, dann brauchst du halt so eine riesige Stadt.
Aber ganz ehrlich, länger als ein Wochenende trägt das irgendwie nicht,
wenn man sich das so anschaut, es sei denn, man hat da irgendwelche Connections.
Deswegen bin ich auch gleich weitergefahren, dann erstmal nach Malaysia und
danach nach Bali. Das war wiederum ganz interessant.
Das ist also wirklich eine sehr nette Insel.
Alles voll mit so Instagram-Menschen.
Es ist eigentlich irgendein Fleck der Erde nicht voll mit Instagram-Menschen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich nicht, aber da war das so eine Hipster-Surfer-Parade vor dem Herrn.
Also es sind natürlich da viele westliche Touristen. Trotzdem ist es da ganz
angenehm, muss man sagen.
Also es ist schon wirklich eine nette Insel, alles sehr freundlich und da kann
man schon sehr nett Urlaub machen.
Genau, und jetzt bin ich aber erstmal wieder in Malaysia auf dem Zwischenstation
und werde mich dann demnächst Richtung Taiwan weiter bewegen,
um mir das mal anzuschauen. Da habe ich nämlich Interesse dran.
Gab es denn irgendwelche, das finde ich immer spannend, so kulturelle Erweckungserlebnisse,
wo du denkst so, ah, so macht ihr das hier, warum machen wir das nicht so? Ihr habt es raus.
Kulturelle Erweckungserlebnisse,
ja, so in den Ländern ein bisschen unterschiedlich also ich meine erstmal,
da hatten wir ja schon so Internet,
funktioniert halt einfach alles so, es ist hier irgendwie so bezahlen,
digital, ist einfach alles vollkommen normal, Netz ist schnell gibt überall
WLAN so in jedem Restaurant gibt es natürlich selbstverständlich überall,
WLAN, aber wenn du jetzt mal von so ein paar Street-Hawkers, also diesen,
Straßenrestaurants mal absiehst oder so,
brauchst du halt irgendwie kein Bargeld.
Und das ist halt alles irgendwie sehr angenehm. Also alles ist halt irgendwie
so ganz selbstverständlich digital organisiert.
Alles geht hier irgendwie online und das ist irgendwie so normal.
Man hat einfach zunehmendem Maße das Gefühl, dass man einfach in Deutschland
so richtig an der Zukunft nicht mehr so richtig teilnimmt.
Also die Zukunft findet statt, aber nicht gleichmäßig auf Deutschland verteilt.
Deutschland kriegt da nicht ganz so viel ab.
Um den berühmten Douglas-Adams-Spruch.
Achso, jetzt hatte ich das mit diesem Apple Store ja gar nicht erzählt.
Weißt du, wo dieser Apple Store ist? Der Apple Store ist im Wasser.
Im Wasser. Das heißt, du musst dann, genau, und zwar haben sie so eine Kugel
gebaut, muss mal Apple Store Singapur irgendwie.
Erstmal Schuhe ausziehen.
Das wäre ja mal was. Nee, also du kannst dann sozusagen unterirdisch von dieser
Shopping Mall unter dem Wasser durch und dann kommst du mit einer Rolltreppe
oben in dieser Glaskugel raus.
Oder du hast noch so einen Steg und kannst übers Wasser da so reinlaufen.
Dann bist du da irgendwie in
deinem Apple Store. Aber ansonsten ist es ein ganz normaler Apple Store.
Gibt wirklich kaum irgendwas langweiligeres, als sich Apple Stores anzuschauen.
Die sehen wirklich alle gleich aus. Alle funktionieren gleich.
Eigentlich bin ich da nur reingegangen, weil ich das zufällig entdeckt habe,
das da eingibt und sagt mir so, ah, der ist ja ganz hübsch, den gucke ich mir
mal von innen an, aber länger als 10 Minuten hat das auch nicht getragen.
Aber von außen ist er in der Tat ganz fancy.
Ja, das können sie ja auch, also so optisch, architektonisch,
da haben sie immer was drauf.
Wobei der ist auch gar nicht mal so groß, wie es aussieht. Ich dachte jetzt
zuerst, das sei so ein bisschen wie dieser S4 in Las Vegas, die neue, aber das ist sehr.
Sehr klein. Also es ist nicht so mega pompös, es ist halt nur wieder so, naja.
Genau, der Anschnitt der Kugel ist ziemlich vergleichbar zu der S4.
Über die müssen wir auch irgendwann nochmal reden, aber nicht heute.
Ja, ich hoffe auch noch, dass wir da nochmal technische Assistenz bekommen,
aber es gestaltet sich leider noch ein bisschen schwierig.
Machen wir nochmal, aber nicht heute.
Ja,
habe ich mir jetzt gerade nicht zurechtgelegt, eine gute Antwort auf deine Frage.
Das mache ich dann vielleicht nächste Sendung. Generell kann man feststellen,
es geht auch alles in freundlich.
Also man kann so als Gesellschaft auch einfach so freundlich miteinander umgehen.
Auch keine deutsche Stärke, zumindest in Berlin.
Nee, es ist einfach, weiß ich auch nicht.
Also derzeit zieht mich gerade relativ wenig zurück, muss ich sagen.
Es ist hier alles schon ganz okay so.
Na gut. Ich werde später noch ein paar Reiseupdates geben, aber ich bin auch fleißig.
Ich bin hier nicht nur am,
Urlaub machen oder so, sondern ich habe viel recherchiert. Ich poemiere auch
ganz viel. Kommen wir gleich noch zu.
Naja, eine Sache, die richtig geil ist, ist natürlich Verkehr in Bali.
Das ist natürlich für mich genau das Richtige.
Was für ein geiles Chaos.
Also in Bali machst du halt am besten alles mit einem Zweirad.
Also mit Mopeds. So kleinen 150er Mopeds, das ist so ein bisschen der Standard.
Autoverkehr geht halt irgendwie kaum irgendwas voran. Aber mit diesen Mopeds
fahren sie natürlich fast alle. Und das ist so ein geiles Chaos.
Ist das schon ein Elektronen-Thema oder ist das alles noch verbunden?
Nee, leider nicht. Da ist es mit der Zukunft noch nicht so. Es wurde dann tatsächlich
noch ein Foto von einer BMW CE 04, die irgendwo auf Bali steht, zugetragen.
Aber leider habe ich die selber nicht gesehen. Und einmal ist auch einer mit
dem Elektroteil an mir vorbeigefahren tatsächlich, aber alles andere ist knatter,
knatter, ratter, ratter.
Und was anderes habe ich natürlich jetzt auch nicht geliehen bekommen.
Aber du leistest dir sowas, weil anders da sich fortzubewegen ist vollkommen unsinnig.
Aber dann einfach in so einem Pulk von Mopeds die einfach alle gleichzeitig
links und rechts an den Autos vorbei durch jede Lücke sich durchschlängeln keine
Ampeln, einfach alles go.
Ich kann euch sagen das ist einfach, also ich habe mich so so glücklich gefühlt
in dem Moment, es war einfach das Beste überhaupt ein totales High habe ich
da irgendwie bekommen in diesem Verkehr,
nichts finde ich geiler als so voll chaotischer Verkehr, warum?
Weil das so, das ist nicht rule-based, wie bei uns.
Da ist es so, ja, Stratverkehrsordnung, Schilder, und so.
Und wir hatten ja die Diskussion schon, rote Ampeln und so sind ja eh,
zumindest bei Fahrradfahrern, nicht besonders populär.
Da ist dann schon so ein bisschen Anarchie. Aber es wird dann immer viel geschrien,
alle anderen müssten halt immer alle Regeln einhalten.
Und dann macht man noch mehr Regeln, noch mehr Regeln, noch mehr Regeln,
bis dann halt irgendwann gar nichts mehr funktioniert. und alles wird nur noch
irgendwie bestraft und so und in Bali ist halt einfach scheiß drauf.
Es gibt so ein paar Ampeln irgendwo wo so die Stadt ein bisschen sich mehr verdichtet
bei so großen Kreuzungen und da lustigerweise auch ähnlich wie in der Türkei
wenn du grün hast dann ist immer grün nur für eine Straßenseite und dann darfst
aber sowohl geradeaus als auch rechts und links fahren,
und dann eine längere Phase, aber es gibt nicht so dieses Problem,
Leute wollen rechts abbiegen, aber dann kommt auch der Gegenverkehr,
inzwischen muss auch in der Türkei so.
Wusste ich vorher auch nicht. Aber davon abgesehen von diesen paar Ampeln gibt
es halt einfach gar keine Ampeln, gar nichts.
Sondern wer irgendwie auf die Straße will, der muss halt irgendwo eine Lücke finden.
Und jede Lücke, die irgendwie da ist, wird mit einem Motorrad gefüllt.
Es ist halt einfach automatisch immer irgendwie alles gefüllt und alles schlängelt sich durch.
Und du schaust dir das an und es ist einfach wie so eine Lehrstunde in Thermodynamik.
Du hast einfach das Gefühl, es sind einfach nur so quellende Gase,
die sich automatisch miteinander vermischen und wieder verstreuen.
Alles regelt sich von alleine.
Das sind einfach nur noch so Temperaturschwankungen an Verkehrsdichte.
Und es ist einfach das Geilste überhaupt.
Der Chat schreibt, wer hupt, hat recht.
Da haben wir sehr viele Leute.
Aber das Interessante ist, auf Bali wird dann die Hupe aber auch tatsächlich
so benutzt, wie sie gedacht war.
Also du warnst mit der Hupe, dass du da jetzt irgendwie kommst und dass du da
bist oder was weiß ich, da kommt so eine enge, fährst um so eine Mauer,
so eine 90-Grad-Kurve, die man nicht einsehen kann, da wird halt kurz angehubt oder so.
Aber man hupt nicht die anderen an aus Bestrafungsaspekten.
In Deutschland wird ja eigentlich immer nur gehupt, um Leute zu... zu bestrafen.
Nicht um irgendwie den Verkehr sicherer zu machen, sondern es ist immer Rache.
Das ist richtig.
Naja, eine Meinungsäußerung ist es.
Ja, so eine Meinungsäußerung. So ein irgendwie, ich finde dich doof und deswegen hupe ich.
Weil ich war der Meinung, mir wurde irgendein Privileg genommen oder eingeschränkt oder so.
Und auf so eine Idee würde man in Bali gar nicht kommen. Dann macht man so, bip, bip, bip, bip, bip.
Und so, nee, ich komme jetzt hier gerade lang, pass auf, irgendwie.
Und keiner hat irgendwie Beef miteinander.
Also alle fahren wirklich wie die Berserker.
Aber alle machen das und deswegen ist es völlig okay und es fließt einfach und
man kann einfach stundenlang geradeaus fahren und muss nicht irgendwo stehen
bleiben und das ist toll.
Also ich kenne das aus Italien, in Florenz hatte ich den Effekt,
als ich da selber mit dem Auto gefahren bin.
Da hast du auch so vier, fünf spurige Straßen, wo es aber gar keine Spuren mehr
eingezeichnet sind, weil es sowieso überflüssig ist.
Und jeder drängelt sich so irgendwo durch, aber das Faszinierende ist,
es passen halt auch alle auf.
Also man hat auch irgendwie so ein bisschen das Gefühl, du bist ja jetzt auch
nicht alleine, sondern du bist ja jetzt auch schon Teil von so einem Mobilitätskollektiv,
wo es keiner darauf anlegt, dich jetzt in ein echtes Problem reinzubringen.
Und das kann man sich in Deutschland überhaupt nicht vorstellen.
Wenn ich da auf meiner Spur bin, dann ist das hier meine Spur und wenn da irgendjemand
anders kommt, dann soll er mir reinfahren und dann rennen, dann werden die Versicherungen
das schon unter sich ausmachen.
Aber ich meine, du fährst halt auch mehr motorisiertes Zweirad.
Ich bin Moped gefahren in Thailand und das fand ich schon anstrengend.
Also das war, glaube ich, ein Bruchteil, so hektisch wie das,
was du jetzt gerade beschreibst.
Aber dieses man muss erst mal irgendwie zwei Minuten warten,
bis man irgendwie reinkommt, zumindest wenn man so ein ängstlicher Typ ist wie
ich, da hätte ich mir schon so die eine oder andere Ampel durchaus mal gewünscht.
Ich mag halt diese Knatterbüchsen überhaupt nicht. Fahrradfahren jederzeit.
Ich hätte ja super Fahrrad fahren können, aber ich mag halt einfach Mopeds nicht.
Und dann muss man glaube ich erstmal reinwachsen auch in diese Art des Verkehrs.
Aber ja, es funktioniert nachweislich.
Mit der Angst ist meine, ich finde ja, das ist ja genau das Problem.
Unser regelüberfrachtetes Verkehrssystem
schafft einfach ganz automatisch ängstliche Verkehrsteilnehmer.
Weil alle immer davon ausgehen, dass alle sich an alle Regeln halten müssen.
Und wenn mal irgendeiner ein abweichendes Verhalten zeigt, dann hat keiner eine Erfahrung damit.
Und ich meine, ich bin wirklich wie ein Bekloppter da gefahren irgendwie und es ist völlig normal,
du bretterst da irgendwie mit 80 Stundenkilometern zwischen zwei Lassern irgendwie
durch und irgendwie fühlt es sich nie irgendwie nennenswert bedrohlich an und
dadurch, dass du halt auch nie das Gefühl hast,
jetzt wird dich gleich irgendeiner für irgendwas bestrafen, weil du irgendein
Privileg genommen hast,
wird man auch automatisch generöser. Also es ist so ein Gesamtgefühl und ich
mag dieses Chaos und diese Thermodynamik.
Und nächstes Mal schauen wir uns auch die Unfallstatistiken an, oder?
Einen Unfall habe ich gesehen, tatsächlich. Das waren aber Autos,
die sind irgendwie miteinander geknallt.
Moppets? Nix.
Gut.
So viel zu meinen Reise-Updates. So ganz allgemein.
So, was noch passiert?
Es hat sich ein Unfall in meinem Leben ereignet, gefühlt.
Ein Unfall in deinem Leben?
David Lynch ist tot. Das hätte nicht passieren dürfen.
Es hat sich aber abgezeichnet für die Ziegen, oder?
Es hat sich etwas abgezeichnet, in der Tat.
Am 15.01. Das ist auch schon zwei Wochen her, drei Wochen fast und ich weiß
nicht, wie es euch geht, man kommt jetzt ja in so ein Alter,
wo auch einfach Leute sterben,
zu dem man doch irgendwie einen Bezug hatte, so im Bereich Kunst, Gesellschaft,
Politik, was auch immer und ich habe bei mir da so ein Phasenmodell irgendwie
hinterlegt, so Achselzucken, naja, gut, war an der Zeit,
Versus, ach, schon schade, hätte man ja das eine oder andere noch irgendwie von erwarten können.
Und dann gibt es eine sehr, sehr kleine Kategorie von Leuten,
wo es einem dann doch irgendwie an die Nieren geht.
Also David Bowie war so ein Moment, Steve Jobs war so ein Moment.
Aber nichts davon hat mich so aus der Kurve geworfen wie jetzt David Lynch.
Er war jetzt irgendwie ja schon gar nicht mehr jung und das war jetzt alles
überhaupt nicht überraschend. Aber mir ist dann an dem Tag klar geworden oder
ich habe mir nochmal die Frage gestellt.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendeinen Künstler, Künstlerin da draußen,
die einen größeren Impact auf mein persönliches Leben hatten?
Und dann war die Antwort nein. So, es gibt also zwei ganz wichtige zentrale Pfeiler bei mir.
Das eine ist Depeche Mode und das andere war David Lynch.
So, und der ist jetzt nicht mehr da.
Und dann habe ich mich jetzt wirklich hingesetzt und dachte so,
jetzt müssen wir es mal ganz kitschig machen.
Und ich habe einen Nachruf geschrieben auf David Lynch, was er mir in meinem
persönlichen Leben bedeutet hat. Und das schmeiße ich jetzt mal einfach in die Shownotes rein.
Keine Sorge, das werde ich jetzt nicht draus zitieren. Aber es ist schon frappierend,
wie die sehr unterschiedlichen Filme, die er gemacht hat, in jeweils sehr unterschiedlichen
Lebenssituationen von mir,
sehr unterschiedliche Dinge getriggert haben, aber die dann alle irgendwie sehr wichtig wurden.
Zum Beispiel Dune von 84 ist der erste Erwachsenenfilm, den ich überhaupt im Kino gesehen habe.
Vorher halt immer nur irgendwie Bud Spencer und so ein Kram,
aber da war ich elf. Der Film ist ab 16.
Man könnte ihn auch ab 18 gut rausgeben lassen.
Und das war eine totale sensorische, inhaltliche Überforderung für mich.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn man dann in sehr jungen Jahren sehr verstörenden
Dingen ausgesetzt ist, dann macht das mit dem Gehirn vielleicht auch das eine
oder andere Positive, glaube ich.
Und so ging das dann so durch die verschiedenen Filme durch.
Und so die relevanten Stationen habe ich einfach mal ein bisschen runtergeschrieben.
Wer auch David Lynch hinterher trauert, dort gerne mal reingucken.
Ich finde, das war ein ganz, ganz großer. Er hat fantastische Filme gemacht,
die man auch immer und immer und immer wieder gucken kann.
Und ja, nur ist er weg.
Also dieses Gefühl kenne ich ganz gut.
Wenn du sagst, es ging dir an die Nieren, wie weit ging das?
Sagst du das jetzt so daher oder hast du so eine körperliche Reaktion?
Ich hatte körperliche Reaktionen, ich habe ein paar Tränchen verdrückt.
Und mich dann halt viele Stunden auch mit diesem Gefühl und meinen Erinnerungen
und meinem Kunstverständnis, also er hat auch sehr stark geformt,
wie ich Kunst überhaupt wahrnehme.
Also dieses Aufschließen von Independent,
von Camp, von irgendwie Underground, ich würde gar nicht sagen,
dass ich immer irgendwie jetzt Teil dieser Kunstszenen irgendwie besonders aktiv
war, weil es hat ein großes Verständnis und eine große Toleranz bei mir aufgeschlossen.
So, dass ich nicht sage, dass es alles abartig und verstört und pervers ist.
Ich denke so, ja, auch da gibt es Dinge zu finden, die irgendwie total spannend sind.
So, ohne David Lynch wäre ich mit Sicherheit nicht zu Christoph Schlingensief
gekommen, beispielsweise.
Das sind dann alles so Ketten, wo man erstmal so ein Grundlevel freigespielt,
bekommt und da war Lynch also ganz zentral für.
Auf was für Arten von Frauen ich stehe, hat er geprägt.
Wer damals als Teenager Blue Velvet weniger, aber Twin Peaks gesehen hat,
was da plötzlich für Frauen rumlaufen, das hatte so gar nichts mit dem zu tun,
was ich aus der Schule kannte.
Und jetzt gar nicht irgendwie nur optisch, sondern so dieses ganze Mindset.
Was waren das für Wesen, die da plötzlich zu besichtigen waren?
Das kannte man auch aus keiner anderen Serie zu der Zeit.
Und das sind alles so Effekte.
Da wir ja auch jüngere Zuhörer haben, sollte man vielleicht ein paar seiner
Werke auch nochmal speziell empfehlen.
Und Twin Peaks ist sicherlich,
Manchmal kann man das sagen, das ist schon so ein bisschen das Bemerkenswerteste,
was er überhaupt glaube ich insgesamt.
Also es war sehr viel Bemerkenswertes dabei, ich will den Rest jetzt gar nicht
so abtun, aber Twin Peaks hat ja gleich so mehrere neue Elemente gemacht.
Ich muss sagen, ich bin kein besonders guter Twin Peaks-Kenner.
Ich habe, glaube ich, die erste Staffel gesehen, die zweite und dann verliert
sie es bei mir so ein bisschen und ich weiß nicht so ganz genau.
Und ich wollte es schon immer mal wieder komplett von vorne machen.
Aber was man festhalten kann, es war halt erst mal keine Fernsehserie wie jeder andere.
Das kann man, glaube ich, mit Sicherheit sagen. Sehr viel Unerwartetes, sehr viel Spezielles.
Es gibt so einen wunderbaren Mastodon-Account, der die ganze Zeit Twin Peaks
Zitate rauswirft. Das ist einfach fantastisch.
Die Eulen sind nicht, was sie scheinen und einsam bläst das Nebelhorn.
Das ist wirklich verdammt guter Kaffee.
Und verdammt guter Kuchen auch. Also es ist so mimetisch reich,
Die Story ist irre. Es geht ja um den Tod von Laura Palmer und ein Detektiv
klärt es auf und so weiter.
Aber dann entwickelt sich das einfach alles komplett anders,
als man normalerweise so Fernsehserien erwartet.
Und dann gab es ja auch noch ein paar Filme hinterher, die dann das ganze Mysterium
noch irgendwie weitererzählen und ich weiß nicht, ob sie es überhaupt abschließend klären.
Also definitiv Twin Peaks, wenn man es nicht kennt, das ist mal wirklich eine
Serie, die man aufnehmen sollte, bevor ihr euch diesen ganzen modernen Quatsch anschaut.
Also das, was Twin Peaks wirklich erfunden hat, ist halt serielles Erzählen.
Das heißt also vor Twin Peaks gab es eigentlich nicht den Gedanken,
dass wir eine Serie, eine Fernsehserie über x Folgen, Querstrich Staffeln als
eine durchgängige Geschichte erzählen.
Da gab es eigentlich immer so Monster of the Week oder der Fall des Kriminalkommissars
der Woche und es gab so ein paar leise Themen,
die vielleicht ein bisschen weiterentwickelt worden sind, aber in Twin Peaks
hast du eigentlich wirklich eine einzige durchgängige Geschichte und die endet
zwar immer mit einem Cliffhanger, dadurch hast du schon ein bisschen eine Strukturierung,
aber du kannst das also auch problemlos als irgendwie 10 Stunden Film durchgucken.
Ansonsten von der Struktur her was sollte man sich angucken und was nicht davon
zu Twin Peaks, die erste Season würde ich sagen, das sind ja auch gar nicht
so viele Folgen das sind glaube ich irgendwie nur 7 oder 8 oder sowas die würde
ich sagen, muss Mensch gesehen haben,
so ansonsten fehlen einem popkulturell einfach so viele Dinge,
die man einfach voraussetzen muss, ja das ist halt irgendwie so wie Star Wars,
so das muss einfach irgendwie mal und das ist auch fantastisch,
das tut überhaupt nicht weh, das Alter hervorragend,
Die zweite Season kann man sich dann meiner Meinung nach ziemlich schenken.
Das ging also ziemlich in die Binsen. Und dann hat er ja als Alterswerk,
da war er schon 71 Jahre alt, hat er ja noch eine dritte Season hinterher gedreht.
Und die finde ich persönlich ganz, ganz hervorragend. 2017 war das.
Wo er also echt nochmal gezeigt hat, es steckt immer noch alles in ihm und er
kann das immer noch alles abrufen, hat er auch mit Frost wieder zusammen gemacht.
Also die erste Season von Twin Peaks, die ist wirklich sagen,
wirklich totales Pflichtprogramm.
Tja und ansonsten Filme also so die beiden großen.
Nochmal kurz bevor wir von Twin Peaks wegkommen, also auch die Besetzung war
damals schon, also es waren ja auch alles Leute die später noch sehr bekannt
wurden also Kyle Mac Lachlan als Special Agent,
David Bowie hat ja mitgespielt, Kiefer Sutherland hat mitgespielt David Lynch
hat auch selber mitgespielt Laura Dern in einer ihrer ersten Rollen und,
ja, dann ein paar nicht ganz so bekannte Schauspieler, aber alles auf jeden
Fall auch sehr spezielle Personen, also überhaupt, ja,
David Lynch hat immer tolle Schauspieler an den Start gebracht.
Er hat ja auch so ein durchaus Standard-Cast-Programm, so ein bisschen wie Fassbänder,
so ein paar Lieblings Schauspielerinnen, mit denen er immer wieder viel gemacht
hat. Laura Dern, glaube ich, drei Filme.
Blue Velvet, also Kyle MacLachlan. Halt auch in Dune schon.
Von Dune über Blue Velvet hin zu Twin Peaks.
Also da gibt es auch einfach immer so eine Konstante an Cast,
die man dann auch immer wieder erkennt.
Ja.
Vor dir hast du denn David Lynch geguckt in deinem Leben?
Nein.
Was?
Gar nicht?
Nee.
Auch damals in den 90ern, als es im Fernsehen Erstausstrahlung war?
In den 90ern habe ich gar nicht Fernsehen geguckt.
Uiuiui. Okay.
Oder Kino?
Kino ist auch nicht so mein Ding.
Okay. Dann musst du noch mal ein bisschen nach... Also von den Filmen...
Also der erste Dune war natürlich irgendwie episch hier mit Sting und so weiter.
Nicht zu vergleichen mit dem jetzigen Dune, ganz andere Abteilung,
aber halt crazy. Was ich auch hervorragend fand, war Wild at Heart.
Das ist ja mein am wenigsten gemochter Film in der Tat.
Den finde ich, der hat mich nicht so erreicht. Also alle anderen eher.
Nicolas Cage und Laura Dern. Ich liebe ja Laura Dern. Also ich fand,
Walt der Tat fand ich toll.
Mal Holland Drive. Habe ich nicht so richtig mehr in Erinnerung,
aber ich meine mich zu erinnern, der war auch total crazy, so Inception mäßig
so ein bisschen. War das der oder verwechsel ich das gerade?
Ich habe den damals, als er rausgekommen ist, habe ich ihn nicht gemocht.
Ich mache gerade einen Rewatch, mit dem ich aber noch nicht durch bin.
Oh, die ersten 28 Minuten fand ich jetzt fantastisch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was mir damals da nicht drin gefallen hat,
aber ich werde das noch rausfinden.
Kann sein, dass ich da einfach noch nicht das richtige Mindset für hatte.
Ansonsten ich würde ja sagen, so die beiden totalen Klassiker sind halt Blue Velvet von 86.
Ja. Also sein erster richtiger, quasi verstörender, komischer Film mit Dennis
Hopper in einer unglaublichen Rolle.
Und was ich auch super finde, ist Lost Highway von 97. Das ist das Ganze nochmal
so ein bisschen auf Hochglanz gedreht.
Alles mal ausprobieren. Das kommt schon gut.
Und am Ende würde ich nochmal den Christoph zitieren, den Vanilla Chief,
der hat da nämlich gepostet.
I really hope David Lynch was able to appreciate crossing the border between life and death.
If someone has the capacity for that, it was him.
Also David Lynch beim Sterben zu gucken, das war bestimmt auch ein Event.
Gut. So gehen sie denn dahin.
Roddy, da hast du jetzt aber auf jeden Fall was auf deiner Liste.
Also da musst du mal schnell auf Letterboxd gehen und David Lynch mal durchklicken.
Okay.
Vielleicht wirklich mit Twin Peaks anfangen. Da merkt man sofort.
Was die Qualitäten sind. Das ist nicht nur irgendwie ganz gut oder so,
sondern das ist wirklich außergewöhnliches Kino, außergewöhnliche Erzählungen,
speziell in jeder Hinsicht.
Also wer Freakshow mag, müsste eigentlich auch David Lynch mögen.
Sag ich jetzt mal so.
Na gut, womit hast du dich denn beschäftigt, Roddy?
Aber ich bin irgendwie, ich weiß es nicht mehr, beim Scrollen durch die sozialen
Netzwerke ist mir etwas in die Timeline gefallen, was sich Radiacode nennt.
Keine Ahnung, wie man es genau ausspricht.
Das sind Leute aus, ich glaube, Slowenien, Tschechoslowakei oder so.
Ich weiß es nicht so ganz genau. Die jetzt nochmal gucken müssen.
Nee, Zypern tatsächlich. Zypern. Und zwar stellen die ein Radioaktivitätsmessgerät her.
Also es gibt drei Versionen, drei Typen. Das ist nicht allzu groß.
Also wie würde man jetzt die Größe beschreiben?
Ist ungefähr so groß wie die Fernbedienung von einem Apple TV.
Eine kleine Fernbedienung.
Also keine richtig große Fernbedienung, sondern nur eine wirklich kleine Fernbedienung.
Das ist kein Geigerzähler, weil es kein Geiger-Müller-Zählrohr hat,
sondern so ein Sintilla- irgendwas-Kristall.
Da muss ich euch jetzt die Erklärung, wie es genau funktioniert,
schuldig bleiben. Aber im Prinzip ist das eigentliche Messding sehr, sehr klein.
Und was mich wirklich fasziniert hat an dem Ding ist, wie lange der Akku hält.
Also man kann das Ding zwei Tage anlassen und er ist nicht leer.
Das ist irgendwie unglaublich.
Es gibt eine App dazu, die kann also auch jede Menge.
Man kann, weil er so eine Art Spektrum aufnimmt von der radioaktiven Strahlung,
kann man also auch gewisse radioaktive Elemente damit erkennen.
So ist das jetzt Radium oder ist das Uran oder ist das sonst was.
Man kann es als Dosimeter benutzen.
Da ist so eine Lampe dran, die blinkt jetzt immer so etwas hektisch grün.
Achso, warte mal. Das kann ich mal, ich kann mal kurz.
Oh, jetzt hat man auch den klassischen.
Jetzt hat man den klassischen Klicksound. Immer wenn ein Strahlungsereignis den Sensor trifft.
Das musst du mal auf das Mikrofon ranhalten, dass man das auch gut mitkriegt.
Es ist jetzt so gut wie zwischen dem Mikrofon und meinem Mund. Also es ist super laut.
Das ist auch jetzt nur ein bisschen gruselig.
Das ist ja nicht viel Strahlung jetzt.
Ja, das ist so die normale Hintergrundstrahlung, die jetzt hier in der Metaebene
genauso wie sie bei mir zu Hause ist.
Das Ding, man kann auch Level setzen, wo er dann tatsächlich einen Alarm macht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie der klingt. Ich habe ihn noch nicht ausgelöst.
Ich habe irgendwie immer versucht, was zu finden, was vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr strahlt, damit man mal sieht, ob das Teil überhaupt funktioniert oder ob sie einen bescheißen.
Es gibt in Berlin angeblich eine U-Bahn-Station, wo so mit Cadmiumgelb glasierte
Kacheln oder Uranorange glasierte
Kacheln an der Wand sind, wo man tatsächlich was messen können soll.
Aber da hatte ich noch nicht die Zeit hinzufahren und zu messen.
Du musst uns jetzt aber schon noch erklären, warum.
Ich bin auch schon am Grübeln. Wie weit ist es denn jetzt mit der Nazi-Übernahme
jetzt schon gekommen? Also bereitet ihr euch jetzt schon auf einen Atomkrieg vor?
Also das Ding ist, dass vielleicht bin ich ja, nachdem Tschernobyl damals in
meiner Jugend war, immer noch so ein bisschen geschädigt von,
da gibt es eine Möglichkeit, dass man,
machen wir das Klicken wieder aus, das nervt.
Und es gibt da eine Möglichkeit, dass da was passiert, was ich hinterher nicht
spüren kann oder nicht sehen kann, nicht messen kann, wenn ich nicht so ein Ding habe.
Und deswegen habe ich über die letzten Jahre immer mal wieder geguckt,
was kosten eigentlich brauchbare Strahlungsmessgeräte.
Und das war immer so, es ging irgendwie immer so bei 600 Euro los für irgendwie
so Dinger, wo man das Gefühl hatte, die funktionieren doch nicht richtig.
Das ist doch billiges Plastik und das ist doch alles irgendwie so.
Und jetzt haben diese Radiacode-Leute, fängt halt bei 300 Euro an für so ein
Gerät, das ist natürlich jetzt schon so ein bisschen, wie soll ich sagen,
einfach mal ein Gamble, wenn ich das jetzt kaufe, ist das jetzt brauchbar oder nicht.
Aber gerade deswegen bin ich so erstaunt, dass das Teil wirklich so gut ist.
Und ja, und dann habe ich das gesehen, habe ich dann irgendwie zwei Tage rum
überlegt. Dann dachte ich, ach, kauf es einfach mal ein und guck es mal.
So, und die App, die es dazu gibt, ist auch sehr geil, muss man sagen.
Die kann sogar einen Track aufzeichnen.
Wenn ich also spazieren gehe, kann ich den Track-Funktion anschalten und dann
sehe ich hinterher, wie viel Strahlung war denn wo, wo ich vorbeigelaufen bin. und so.
Und das geilste Hidden Feature ist, also das Teil hat so ein Display,
das ist so Landscape, da stehen da Zahlen drauf und so weiter,
aber man kann es halt so halten, dass das Display links ist und man kann es
so halten, dass das Display rechts ist.
Und er schaltet tatsächlich das Display um.
Die Zahlen sind immer richtig rum, egal wie rum ich es halte, weil er die dann dreht.
Und als notorischer Linkshänder, der sich immer beschwert, dass Dinge für Linkshänder
nicht brauchbar sind, finde ich das natürlich absolut geil, dass du das da in
der linken wie in der rechten Hand halten kannst.
Das zeigt immer richtig an. Also, ähm,
Wie gesagt, ist vielleicht jetzt kein Spielzeug für jeden, aber für mich,
der ich der Meinung bin, ich will schon wissen, was um mich herum passiert,
war das irgendwie dann doch das Ding.
Da auf den Weg hierhin hast du ja nochmal ausgeführt, sowas muss man immer antizyklisch kaufen.
Genau, das Teil ist, wenn der nächste große Unfall kommt, egal ob durch eine
Waffe oder durch ein Kraftwerk erzeugt, dann wird es schwer sein, an Geräte zu kommen.
Deswegen ist es etwas, was man kauft, bevor man es braucht.
Und dementsprechend habe ich dann da mal zugeschlagen und mir das hingelegt.
Der Shop ist ja auch geil. Also das Gerät, muss man mal dazu sagen, kostet 250 bis 500 Euro.
Je nachdem, wie, ich weiß nicht, wie sensitiv das ist.
Ja, das Rechtsmodell, nenne ich es mal, also oben und unten gibt es ja nicht.
Das hat irgendwie einen anderen Sensor verbaut, der nochmal einen ganzen Ticken,
sensitiver ist als die anderen beiden.
Ja, der Shop hat noch jede Menge so wie Handyhüllen und sonstiges Zeichen.
Ja, das wollte ich nämlich gerade sagen. Also es gibt dann so ein Active Band.
Also so für die Leute, die so to go, weißt du, so strahlen. Also ich frage mich,
was ist das für eine Zielgruppe, wie so eine Handyhalterung,
so einen Radioaktivitätszähler so direkt an den Arm ranbindet, so,
falls man, keine Ahnung, was weiß ich, im Atomkraftwerk joggen will oder so,
ich verstehe es nicht so ganz genau.
Aber noch geiler sind die Anhänger, die es da unten gibt, hast du die auch gesehen?
Eine Keychain, wo draufsteht Cäsium-137.
Ja, die habe ich auch gesehen, das fand ich ein bisschen bekloppt.
Oder die I love Cäsium-137 Keychain.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das eine Aussage ist, die ich dir vertreten kann.
Schön fand ich den quasi Selfie-Stick, wo man das Ding vorne dran steckt und
dann hat man die Verlängerung, dann kann man überall hinpoken und gucken. Also, ja.
Oh Mann.
Ja, der Radia-Rod.
Also nochmal Radia-Code, wenn man es jetzt deutsch aussprechen wollte,
so heißt das Teil, für mich war das jetzt okay.
Ich, wie immer, keine Produktempfehlung.
Ich habe mir halt einen gekauft und ich finde, ihr solltet das wissen und wenn
ihr auch einen haben wollt, bitteschön.
Genau und ein Zintillator, das kommt vom Lateinischen Zintillare,
Funkeln und Flackern, das ist einfach ein Körper,
der so gebaut ist, dass wenn da so energiereiche Photonen oder geladene Teilchen,
die werden dann, die werden abgebremst, die Radioaktivität wird quasi in Licht umgewandelt.
Es entsteht ein Lichtblitz, wenn das radioaktive Teilchen abgebremst wird und
diesen Lichtblitz misst man dann.
Das ist ja anders wie bei einem Geigermüller Zählrohr, wo du im Prinzip ein Gas hast,
wo von dem Gas ein Elektron runtergeschlagen wird und weil das irgendwie in
der Spannung ist, entsteht dann so ein Strom an Teilchen und der lässt sich
dann als Klick hörbar machen.
Geiger, Müller, Zählrohre sind halt sehr, sehr robust, aber halt auch nicht besonders genau.
Das ist halt das Problem. Die Dinger sollten eigentlich relativ genau sein. Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe keine Möglichkeit, das mit einem Profigerät zu vergleichen.
Also insofern vielleicht ist es auch Unsinn.
Aber wenn, dann ist es gut gemachter Unsinn.
Sowas mögen wir ja hier. gut gemachter Unsinn. Das wäre Experten für.
Alright.
Ralf, was macht das Fettiverse?
Ich habe was gemacht. Ich konnte es wieder nicht lassen.
Habe in der Tat fast die Nacht durchge- na, gecodet, sagt man ja heutzutage
jetzt nicht mehr, die Nacht durchgepromptet, um mal etwas zu bauen.
Also was ist passiert? Ich habe mich irgendwie vor zwei Tagen mal wieder ein
bisschen aufgeregt auf Mastodon, warum eigentlich jetzt im aktuellen Wahlkampf
dort so wenig prominente,
Politikerinnen auch von den progressiven oder scheinbar progressiven Parteien
eigentlich im Fidiverse unterwegs sind.
Ich glaube, Aufhängepunkt war, dass hier die neue Vorsitzende der Linke auf
TikTok jetzt so steil geht, mit dem Video aus dem Bundestag,
was ich in der Tat auch wirklich sehr, sehr feiere.
Aber warum ist sowas nur auf TikTok und nicht auch irgendwie im freien Internet?
So, dann habe ich mich halt ein bisschen aufgeregt und habe irgendwie ein bisschen
was gesucht und dann bin ich über eine Seite gestolpert.
Codeberg.org ist glaube ich auch hier irgendwo so halb in Berlin ansässig,
ist ein eigentragener Verein zur Unterstützung freier offener Software.
Infrastruktur habe ich mich jetzt noch gar nicht so intensiv mit beschäftigt. Die haben eine Seite,
betreiben die schon seit etlichen Jahren, mindestens vier Jahren glaube ich,
wo sie mal sammeln, welche politischen Akteure und Institutionen eigentlich
im Fediverse vertreten sind.
Der großen Parteien, sowohl Einzelaccounts als auch Parteiaccounts,
als auch nochmal Wissenschaftler, beziehungsweise Einrichtungen von Bundesbehörden und so weiter.
Ziemlich langes Ding. Sieht auf den ersten Blick erstmal ganz interessant aus.
Und da dachte ich so, das ist ja schön, dass das mal jemand gemacht hat.
Da hätte ich doch jetzt ganz gerne meine statistische Auswertung drüber.
Und die gibt es halt nicht auf der Seite. Es hat einfach nur eine Markdown-Datei
mit ein paar Tabellen drin.
Und dann sagte ich mir, naja, wir leben in 2025. Da gucken wir doch mal,
wie weit wir in einer halben Stunde
kommen, um da mal ein bisschen eine Datenvisualisierung drüber zu machen.
Und das habe ich jetzt mal gebaut. Tim, jetzt müsstest du vielleicht mal meinen
Screen auf unserem Beamer größer machen und wir versuchen zu beschreiben,
was es ist. Ich werfe das auch mal in den Chat rein.
Das ist noch nicht publiziert. Ich muss da noch ein bisschen was am Caching
drehen, damit ich nicht tausende von Leuten völlig nutzlos irgendwelche Instanzen
mit Statistikabfragen beballern.
Da muss ich mir noch das eine oder andere Clevere einfallen lassen.
Was macht jetzt dieses Tool? Das nimmt diese Markdown-Datei und passt die durch.
Wer ist davon eigentlich noch aktiv?
Wie viele haben die Leute eigentlich jemals überhaupt gepostet im 4Diverse und
welcher Partei sind sie eigentlich zugeordnet? Und das Ganze wird jetzt immer
so ein bisschen visualisiert auf verschiedene Arten und Weisen.
Wenn man das also jetzt neu aufbaut, dann schieben sich hier die Balken so ordentlich rein.
Wir sehen, wir haben insgesamt 259 Parteien- oder Einzelpersonen-Accounts und
dann gibt es noch ein paar Institutionen-Accounts, die sind unten drunter.
Das ist aber noch ein bisschen buggy, aber das oben für die Parteien funktioniert ganz gut.
Und jetzt sehen wir halt erstmal oben in einem Balken die Verteilung der Accounts
im Fettiverse über die verschiedenen Parteien.
Also wir sehen natürlich nicht, weil wir sind ja ein Audio-Podcast.
Aber du siehst das gerade. Genau, aber wir beschreiben es, genau.
Wir sehen also jetzt einfach einen Balken, verschiedene Farben.
So, und dann sehen wir, oder wir hören jetzt, dass wir sehen,
grüne 115 Accounts, das ist viel.
Davon auch nur ein Bot. Linke 61, davon aber 25 Bots.
Also Bots sind dann Accounts, die zwar da sind, aber die einfach nur eins zu
eins von einem anderen System, sei es Blue Sky oder was der Geier,
was halt die Nachrichten durchtunneln.
SPD 38, zwei Bots davon.
Die Partei, relativ prominent, mit 23 Accounts. Piraten auch nur noch sieben Accounts.
CDU 6, Volt 5, FDP 3, Freie Wähler 1.
Und Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht und AfD tauchen zumindest jetzt in dieser Markdown-Datei
mit keinem einzigen Account auf. Keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt...
Ob irgendwie so moderiert ist, dass die dort nicht erscheinen wollen oder ob
die wirklich keinen einzigen Fediverse-Account haben, man weiß es nicht.
So und unten drunter habe ich nochmal einen Zeitstrahl gebaut,
wo man sehen kann, wann sind die jeweiligen Accounts eigentlich dem Fediverse beigetreten.
Und da sieht man jetzt relativ schön die beiden quasi Musk-Events.
Zum einen, als er zum ersten Mal sagt, ich hätte Interesse mal Twitter zu kaufen.
Das war im April 2022, da ist die erste Beitrittswelle und die zweite Beitrittswelle,
als er es dann wirklich gemacht hat.
Das war dann im Oktober 2022 des selben Jahres.
Und man sieht also, dass es dort eine starke Ballung gibt. Man kann oben auf
eine Partei draufklicken, bekommt dann den Zeitstrahl nur von dieser Partei angezeigt.
Ich kann mal einen Screenshot davon wieder in den Chat reinwerfen,
wie es jetzt beispielsweise nur bei den Grünen aussieht.
Das haben wir so. Wir haben unten drunter dann einen Freitextfilter,
wo man beispielsweise mal gucken kann, ich tippe mal Berlin ein.
Welche Politiker-Accounts haben denn irgendwas mit Berlin in ihren Metadaten drin hängen?
Und wir haben dann bei den Einzelaccounts eine Zuordnung, welcher Partei sind
sie angehörig mit ein bisschen Logik dahinter, wo sich das daraus ableitet.
Das funktioniert jetzt glaube ich ganz gut, wie ich das reingedrechselt habe
und wir haben, das finde ich dann fast den entscheidenden Faktor,
wie viele Leute haben die insgesamt schon gepostet und wie viele haben sie aber
auch innerhalb der letzten 60 Tage gepostet.
Das heißt also, lebt dieser Account eigentlich noch?
Und das ist etwas, was ich jetzt so als aktiv bezeichne. Also jetzt ist Bundestagswahlkampf.
Also wenn die Leute jetzt nicht aktiv sind, wann dann?
Da finde ich also 60 Tage jetzt schon sehr generös.
Und dann sieht man halt die doch etwas deprimierende Erkenntnis von den 259
Accounts, die da sind und die irgendwas gemacht haben,
sind in den letzten 60 Tagen nur 57 aktiv gewesen. Das sind gerade mal 22 Prozent.
Der Rest sind Karteileichen, wenn man so will.
Das ist etwas betrüglich, aber ich finde das mal so visualisiert und durchsuchbar
mal zusammen zu haben, finde ich vielleicht mal ganz hilfreich.
Jetzt überlege ich noch, was ich damit mache, ob ich das ganze Framework dann
nochmal erweitere, dass man da auch andere Datenquellen hinterhängen kann.
Beispielsweise halt irgendwie Uni-Accounts oder Bibliotheks-Accounts oder was auch immer.
Und man so ein bisschen den Eindruck dafür bekommt, so okay,
wie entwickelt sich eigentlich hier das Fediverse, wenn es eben um solche zentralen Player geht.
Journalistinnen, gibt es auch diverse Listen von, weiß ich.
Mal gucken, ob ich mich damit noch ein bisschen weiter beschäftige.
Und ich werde das, denke ich, am Wochenende mal auf GitHub abwerfen.
Ah, okay, gut. Das wäre jetzt meine nächste Frage. Das läuft jetzt noch nirgendwo
außer auf deinem Computer.
Genau, das läuft jetzt im Moment lokal. Und ich bin jetzt quasi eine Stunde
davor, es so generisch zu haben, dass es auf einer GitHub-Page läuft.
Das ist ja immer so mein beliebtester Publikationskanal, so gar nicht mehr eigener Web-Server oder sowas.
Einfach so bauen, dass es als GitHub-Page geht.
Aber ich will halt, dass dort dann ein vernünftiges Caching aktiv ist und alle
24 Stunden werden die Daten aktualisiert.
Weil im Moment ist es so, dass wirklich dann halt jetzt die ganzen Server angefragt
werden und mit sauberen API-Requests, alles völlig innerhalb der Spielregeln,
hole ich mir jetzt halt die Statistik-Daten raus, aber das willst du halt nicht
bei jedem Browser-Aufruf von jedem Nutzer machen.
Was kommt hier für Technologie zum Einsatz bei deinem Tool?
Das ist so das Übliche, sprich HTML, JavaScript, Bootstrap, jQuery,
genau. Genau. Wobei beispielsweise...
Also finden Sie alles im Browser statt sozusagen?
Alles komplett browserbasiert, ja.
Und die Daten holt er sich dann woher?
Aus der Markdown-Datei, wirklich von dem Server hier auch. Also der Codeberg.org
hat hier auch einen Git laufen.
Achso, da sind jetzt nicht nur die Accounts drin verzeichnet,
sondern da sind auch die ganzen Posts drin verzeichnet.
Nee, da sind nur die Accounts drin. Alles andere hole ich mir dann von da aus.
Also es wird dann also quasi eine kleine interne Datenbank aufgebaut.
So, okay, das stand in der Markdown-Datei drin und dann werden die Schritt für
Schritt abgearbeitet und mit weiteren Statistiken aufgefüttert.
Und damit will ich es aber auch nicht übertreiben. Es soll jetzt auch nicht
irgendwie ein Pranger werden oder sowas und ich finde auch im Fediverse zu viel
Statistik ist auch irgendwie nicht so toll.
Also da muss ich auch gucken, dass ich da eine vernünftige Balance irgendwie,
hinkriege. Aber alleine so, wie es jetzt schon ist, finde ich das schon ganz eindrücklich.
Sieht ganz fancy aus, aber es sollte natürlich dann nicht nur auf deinem Laptop
laufen, von daher spute dich da mal.
Ja, das wollte es für heute fertig haben, aber habe jetzt schon bis 5 Uhr heute
Nacht und dachte, ein paar Stunden Schlaf brauche ich jetzt noch.
Wir kommen noch dazu, gebaut mit Cursor und Sonne 3.5, keine einzige Zeile selber
geschrieben, wie üblich.
Und das war allerdings jetzt auch von der Genese her wieder ein bisschen hakelig.
Also so ein Pattern, über das wir auch schon häufiger gesprochen haben,
die erste halbe Stunde läuft sehr, sehr smooth und geht sehr gut.
Und wenn es dann spezieller wird, dann muss man schon auch ein bisschen Hirnschmalz
reinstecken in das Prompting und Debugging.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen lief es recht geschmeidig.
Also das ist jetzt das Ergebnis von ungefähr vier, fünf Stunden,
die ich da rein investiert habe.
Nicht schlecht, sieht ganz aufgeräumt aus irgendwie, aber sowas geht jetzt mittlerweile,
das ist echt geil dass man jetzt einfach mal so, da können wir gleich nochmal
drüber reden, ich finde diesen Effekt wirklich absolut mind-boggling,
ich weiß nicht wie du darüber nachdenkst mittlerweile Roddy, aber mich haut das um.
Es ist ein Tool also wenn ich nur eine halbe Stunde weit komme,
ohne mit dem Tool kämpfen zu müssen, dann ist das noch Kinderschuhe.
Aber ich finde, es sprengt einfach die Wand zwischen so, jemand müsste mal und ich mach mal selber.
Ja, genau.
Und wenn man irgendwie, wie ich, ständig Ideen hat, ist sowas halt schon eine mächtige Waffe.
Jemand, mir nicht sehr wohlgesonnen ist, aus dem professionellen Arbeitsumfeld,
hat irgendwo mal auf seiner internen Liste geschrieben, wo er nicht wusste,
dass ich da mitlesen kann.
Niemals darf man dem Stockmann PowerPoint in die Hand geben.
Damit macht er jede Sitzung platt und drückt alles durch.
Und heute würde es wahrscheinlich sagen, niemand darf dem Stockmann Cursor mit
einer LM dahinter in die Hand geben.
Es gibt einfach Technologien, auf die ich gut reagiere und die gehört definitiv dazu.
Da bin ich ganz bei dir und das ist auch gerade bei mir eigentlich auch so das Ding.
Bleiben wir doch vielleicht gleich mal bei dem Thema, weil ich ja jetzt hier
auch quasi mir vorgenommen habe.
Ja, was habe ich mir vorgenommen? Ich habe mir vorgenommen, hier Land und Leute
ein bisschen kennenzulernen, ein bisschen Urlaub zu machen und ich habe mir,
vorgenommen, viel zu programmieren.
Also so mein Sport programmieren. Kennt ihr noch diese Aufkleber,
die Leute da hinten so an die Autos dran machen?
Mein Sport und dann Tennis oder sowas. Und dann So einen Aufkleber hätte ich
auch gerne. Mein Sport und Laptop und Coding.
Einfach so als Freizeitsport. Nicht als Beruf, sondern so als Sport.
Und das finde ich tatsächlich in dem Zusammenhang wirklich sehr interessant.
Da sollten wir vielleicht mal kurz auf Cursor zu sprechen kommen.
Weil wie du auch, geht es mir auch. Und ich muss sagen, als du das erste Mal
ankamst mit irgendwie, ich habe mir jetzt mal hier was zusammengebaut mit deinem Mastodon.
Die Mastowall. Die Mastowall, so.
Da war ich ja schon noch etwas skeptisch.
Aber ich muss sagen, diese Skepsis habe ich mittlerweile komplett abgelegt und
behaupte das Gegenteil.
Da sind wir einem...
Einer Zeitenwende stehen wir gegenüber. Die findet jetzt gerade statt und zwar massiv.
Und das ist genau das, was du gerade so beschrieben hast. Es ist auf einmal
diese, wie nennt man das,
so eine Wand eingerissen worden zwischen Leuten, die quasi über Systeme kreativ
nachdenken, im Sinne von es müsste mal geben das und wäre es nicht toll,
wenn wir dieses Tool hätten.
Und den tatsächlichen Werkzeugen, die man benötigt, um so etwas auch umzusetzen,
was ja in der Regel immer so ein bisschen Experten braucht, die dann aber vielleicht
mit dieser Idee nicht so viel anfangen können oder die nicht so verstehen oder
keine Zeit haben oder zu teuer sind oder alles Mögliche.
Und man stand dann immer so ein bisschen doof da. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen,
wieso streng dich doch ein bisschen an.
Aber es ist halt so, man steckt ja oft mit seinem Kopf, mit seiner Tätigkeit,
mit seinen Interessen, mit seiner Zeit in ganz anderen Kontexten und auch anderen
Lebenswelten und Erfahrungswelten.
Aber genau da gebiert man ja dann diese Ideen und sagt so, man müsste das mal
automatisieren, man müsste hier mal gucken, man müsste hier mal eine Auswertung
machen und so weiter und da bräuchte man ja eigentlich nur das und das.
Das kann doch so schwer nicht sein.
Und dann setzt man sich halt irgendwie ran und verbringt dann irgendwie erstmal
die ersten zwei Tage, in denen man auf irgendwelche komischen Syntax-Errors
schaut oder Konfigurationsdateien, einfach nur um sein Environment erstmal an
den Start zu bekommen und dann bricht natürlich irgendwie die Zeit dann auch komplett weg.
Und jetzt mit den AI-Tools,
läuft das auf einmal ganz anders. Da gibt es diese Einstiegshürde mittlerweile fast gar nicht mehr.
Also so ein Projekt anlegen und mal so grundsätzlich.
Mittlerweile investiere ich einfach die Zeit in Nachdenken und schreibe dann
das Konzept erstmal auf.
Und wenn man dann irgendwie da diese Coding Agents draufwirft,
dann wird es wirklich spannend.
Also umso akkurater man beschreiben kann, was man eigentlich haben will, was es tun soll.
Im Prinzip so ein White Paper, was früher mal keiner lesen wollte,
das schreibt man da jetzt irgendwie rein und nimmt das sozusagen schon mal als
Diskussionsbasis und sagt so, hier, liest du das mal durch, das ist irgendwie
das, wie ich denke, wie das funktionieren sollte,
jetzt helfen wir mal hier irgendwie Datenbank dafür aufzubauen und den ganzen
anderen Kram zusammen zu bekommen und das funktioniert.
Also das hat seine Grenzen und läuft man auch mal gegen eine Wand und da wird
auch ein bisschen zu viel durcheinander halluziniert, Aber das ist alles völlig egal.
Also der Produktivitätsfortschritt ist real und ist so schnell und so massiv
und so krass, dass wenn man da mal jetzt ein bisschen Zeit investiert und sich
quasi mit dieser Wesenslage,
dieser Systeme ein bisschen beschäftigt und die Erfahrung mal jetzt ansammelt,
um da überhaupt erstmal umzugehen,
dann sind die Ergebnisse halt wirklich krass.
Und Cursor, gut, das ist jetzt das, was ich halt viel verwendet habe und auch
immer noch verwende, mir kommt das irgendwie entgegen.
Es gibt andere Systeme, die ja auch schon erwähnt wurden, wie Z oder natürlich
hier Co-Pilot und so weiter. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Mittlerweile finden diese Systeme überall Anklang und so.
Nur Cursor scheint mir irgendwie so das Beste zu sein, um mal so eben durchstarten
zu können mit egal, was man will.
Ja, und die Verbesserungen sind einfach täglich zu sehen.
Und ich verlinke mal so einen Blog-Eintrag, der vielleicht jetzt Roddys Gedanken
ganz, ganz gut auch wiedergibt,
weil das, sagen wir mal, für erfahrene Programmierer natürlich auch eine Gefahr
darstellt, so zu programmieren.
Also während wir jetzt so, Ralf und ich, so oft nicht die Zeit hatten,
jetzt viel kurz zu machen, weil wir uns irgendwie mit anderen Sachen beschäftigt
haben, aber die ganze Zeit auf die Ideen gekommen sind für Systeme,
die man mal so brauchen könnte,
ist es natürlich jetzt für Programmierer, die so richtig im Thema sind,
ihr System beherrschen, die Betriebssysteme beherrschen, die APIs kennen und
sagen wir mal, auch wirklich so.
Jedes Semikolon, was am falschen Platz ist, auch einfach sofort erkennen.
Und wenn man dann mit AI-Tools arbeitet und sich da helfen lässt,
dann läuft man natürlich Gefahr, diese Erfahrung, diese Hardcore Einschleifung
und dieses krasse Training, was man ja im Prinzip hat, zu verlieren.
Es ist so, als ob jetzt irgendwie ein 100-Meter-Sprinter irgendwie die ganze
Zeit die Straßenbahn nimmt.
Und da muss man natürlich aufpassen, dass man an der Stelle seine Fähigkeiten nicht verliert.
Und dieser Blogpost hier von hier ist der Typ nochmal, weiß ich jetzt gerade
gar nicht, steht das hier irgendwo bestimmt.
Auf jeden Fall beschreibt er, wie er halt irgendwie auch mit Cursor gearbeitet
hat und dann einfach schnell in so eine Situation reingekommen ist,
wo er einfach dann nicht mehr verstanden hat, was der Code macht,
nicht mehr diesen Lerneffekt, diesen Trainingseffekt hat und jetzt zwingt er
sich halt regelmäßig dazu irgendwie so zumindest mal einen Tag die Woche die
Tools nicht zu benutzen, sondern
sich wirklich mal jede Fehlermeldung durchzulesen. Das ist super tempting.
Du hast jetzt irgendein obskures Problem, irgendwas wird falsch berechnet,
jetzt könntest du stundenlang da in diesen Code eintauchen, so hat man das normalerweise gemacht.
Und jetzt gehst du einfach an den Körper und sagst so, ja, bau mal irgendwie
jede dritte Zeile in ein Debug-Statement ein, schmeiß mal alle Variablen raus,
dann läuft dieser Code einmal kurz nochmal durch, erzeugt irgendwie so ein fünf
Kilometer langes Text-File, dann pastest du das da wieder rein,
ja, lies mal durch, sag mir mal was Falsches, so, oh ja, jetzt sehe ich schon
das Problem, hier haben wir irgendwie ein Plus und kein Minus und deswegen funktioniert
das alles nicht und ich habe das jetzt mal korrigiert und dann so,
ah ja, schön, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben, jetzt nehmen wir die ganzen
Debug-Statements wieder raus und so,
ja, okay, jetzt habt ihr alle wieder jetzt entfernt, jetzt alles wieder wie
vorher, aber jetzt berechnet er richtig, so, Turnaround-Zeit irgendwie 30 Sekunden.
Und der Hasel läuft,
aber es ist klar, dass man dann eben das verliert. Ich wiederum.
Sehe es von der anderen Seite. Ich kriege dadurch dieses Training erst,
weil ich halt immer wieder vor dieser Problematik stehe, so scheiß,
was brauche ich jetzt hier für eine Architektur, was brauche ich jetzt hier
eigentlich für Tools, was brauche ich für eine Library,
wie setzt man denn das jetzt auf, wie muss denn meine Architektur sein,
wie muss denn jetzt hier meine Module verteilen,
brauche ich jetzt hier einen Supervisor oder nicht, all so eine Frage.
Und jetzt habe ich die Möglichkeit, auch mal eben drei, vier,
fünf verschiedene Ansätze auszuprobieren, um dann am Ende zu sehen,
so, ah, okay, das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich der Winning Move.
Und dann kann ich mir den Code danach anschauen und sagen, so,
ah, okay, alles klar, so wird das jetzt hier gemacht. Also ich lerne dadurch,
dass ich so die Möglichkeit habe, auszuprobieren.
Ich schmeiße einfach ganz viel Farbe an die Wand und schaue,
was am besten danach aussieht und kann dadurch halt auch einen Lerneffekt erzielen.
Aber es ist natürlich eine Gefahr für Super-Experience-Programmierer,
aber es erschließt das Programmieren einer Gruppe von Leuten,
die vielleicht bisher bestenfalls Projektmanager gewesen sind.
Und während die Projektmanager sonst viel Zeit damit verbracht haben,
in irgendwelchen Meetings oder in irgendwelchen Whitepapers anderen Leuten zu
erklären, was sie eigentlich haben wollen.
Oder Projektmanager ist vielleicht gar nicht das richtige Wort.
Wie nennt man sowas? Projektdesigner oder so? Systemdesigner?
Also in der Scrum-Logic sind das Product-Owner. Die also wissen,
was das Viech hinterher eigentlich mit welchen Prioritäten können soll und was
sinnvolle Zwischenschritte dahin sind.
Genau. Und die auch, sagen wir mal, ein Gefühl haben, warum muss es das überhaupt
geben und was sollte es nicht sein und all diese ganzen Sachen,
die man sonst immer wieder überprüfen muss.
Und jetzt ist man in der Lage, zumindest aus eigenen Kräften einen Prototypen
zu bauen. Also es muss ja noch nicht mal das finale System sein.
Aber man kann sich halt hinsetzen, so wie du das jetzt gemacht hast,
es müsste ja mal so einen Activity-Trigger geben. Das kann doch nicht so schwer sein.
So, und dann bam, bam, bam, bam, bam. Und dann, du hast Running Code.
Ich meine, der ist jetzt noch nicht veröffentlicht, aber ich habe es ja eben
gerade gesehen. Das sieht irgendwie schick aus, es tut irgendwie, was es soll.
Muss man sicherlich nochmal ein bisschen debuggen und nochmal ein paar Augen
drauf werfen, aber im Großen und Ganzen ist der Großteil der Arbeit schon getan.
Und ich sage auch einfach, warum nicht?
Weil dann ist das halt vielleicht die neue Programmiersprache und die neue Programmiersprache heißt Deutsch.
Ja, es gibt da so ein, zwei Punkte, wo ich immer wieder ins Grübeln komme.
Man hat ja immer so, das gibt es in der Kommunikationswissenschaft auch irgendwie
diverse Theorien zu, dass man selber mit seinem Erfahrungshorizont ja immer
so das Zentrum des Universums ist.
Und wir sind die letzte Generation, die noch.
Und wir waren die erste Generation, die noch. Und nach uns kommt ja nur noch Mist.
Ist das nicht so wahr wir sind alte weiße Männer, Punkt das können wir jetzt
einfach mal nicht wegdiskutieren ähm,
Trotzdem, es gab jetzt auch wieder die Wochen so ein paar ganz lustige Meme,
so diese verschiedenen Generations von Generation X über Z und Y und wie sie nicht alle heißen,
dass wir halt so die Generation sind, die noch das vorher kennen,
als es noch keine Computer gab und dann haben wir miterlebt,
wie die plötzlich alle kamen und dann haben wir erlebt, wie dieses ganze Touch
kam und jetzt haben wir auch noch irgendwie die ganze KI an den Backen.
Wir haben aber halt noch den ganzen Hintergrund von, was die ganzen Zwischenschritte davor waren.
Und es gibt durchaus etliche Beobachtungen, die sagen, dass die Jugend von heute
eben noch nichtmals mehr einen Laptop bedienen kann, weil die nur noch Touch
wollen und machen und sagen so,
all das, was ich in meinem Leben brauche,
kriege ich auf dem iPad und auf dem Smartphone hin.
Ich brauche überhaupt keinen Laptop. Was soll das?
Diese Maus, diese Zeiger, dieses komisch.
Schön fand ich auch den Post, wo jemand meinte, es ist total ungerecht,
dass wir die Generation sind, die sowohl unseren Eltern die Drucker fixen.
Als auch unseren Kindern.
Ja, also ich werde das gar nicht zu tief elaborieren, aber ich,
also was ich jetzt auch heute Nacht wieder sehr stark gemerkt habe,
ich hätte nach ungefähr 20, 30 Minuten wäre ich stecken geblieben,
wenn ich nicht einigermaßen leidlich programmieren könnte, selber.
Und auch nicht nur eben so ein bisschen Birdseye-View-Wissen im Sinne von so,
das sind jetzt so die gängigen Frameworks, sondern eben schon auch ein bisschen
einen Sinn dafür habe, so, warum kommt jetzt folgender Fehler und wo würde jetzt
hier ein Debugging, was ist überhaupt ein Log,
ja, warum ist es überhaupt sinnvoll, einen Log mitschreiben zu lassen, irgendwie so.
Das sind einfach Dinge, die musst du halt irgendwann irgendwie mal gelernt haben.
Und für mich ist wirklich eine der großen Fragen der nächsten Jahre.
Ob jetzt so ein Tool wie Cursor noch so viel besser wird, dass das auch nicht
mehr notwendig ist, sondern wo also das Verständnis darüber,
wie man funktionierenden fehlerfreien Code schreibt,
noch mal quasi die letzte Schippe
draufgelegt wird, dass man diese ganzen Debugging-Optimierungsprozesse
auch nicht mehr braucht. Und das ist für mich eine ganz offene Frage.
Wenn man mich also vor, habe ich auch schon mal ziemlich wortwörtlich so in
der Sitzung gesagt, also ich konnte mir im Bereich KI immer viel vorstellen,
aber ich finde es nach wie vor verstörend, dass gerade Programmierung so gut damit geht.
Ich hätte gedacht, dass das so eine der letzten Bastionen ist,
die nie oder ganz spät erst fallen werden. Und jetzt ist es mit das Erste, was umgeworfen wurde.
Ist das aber jetzt auch schon auf einem Plateau oder wird das auch noch den
entscheidenden letzten Schritt besser, dass die Menschheit in zehn Jahren wirklich
nicht mehr programmieren können muss, weil das komplett die KI macht?
Also ich habe ja da immer dieses Zitat von Steve Jobs im Hinterkopf, Bicycle for the Mind,
wo er immer gesagt hat, der Computer ist the bicycle of the mind,
also dieses Ding, was einen fürchterlich viel schneller macht.
Ich glaube, dass diese Programmier-KIs in eine ähnliche Kategorie fallen,
weil du musst am Ende des Tages immer noch wissen, was ist sinnvoll, was will ich erreichen,
was soll das Teil tun können und so weiter und auch ...
Wie sind die Einzelteile strukturiert und so weiter. Also am Ende ist so eine
KI immer ein Textprediktor und der kann dir nur Dinge schreiben,
die schon mal jemand vorher geschrieben und veröffentlicht hat.
Sonst wird es nicht funktionieren. Und ich glaube, ich glaube,
ab einer bestimmten Komplexitätsklasse hast du immer Software,
die von Hand geschrieben wurde, damit die überhaupt von der Maschine erst mal gelernt werden kann.
Und ich glaube nicht, dass diese Handarbeit je weggeht.
Also das, was man früher so schön herabwürdigend Boilerplate-Code genannt hat,
ist etwas, was wahrscheinlich sehr stark automatisiert wird.
Und was wahrscheinlich auch sehr stark automatisiert wird, ist diese ganze Frage,
welche Programmiersprache benutze ich eigentlich?
Ich glaube, das ist sowas, was sehr stark in den Hintergrund treten wird.
Ob die KI jetzt die oder die oder die Programmiersprache ausspuckt,
ist dann nicht mehr so richtig wichtig.
Also gerade Nischenprogrammiersprachen werden da extrem drunter leiden.
Wenn du nicht den Mindshare von der AI hast und diese Programmiersprache schreiben
kannst, dann wird die AI das auch nicht können.
Wenn die das nicht kann, dann verschwindet die Sprache, weil niemand mehr die
Sprache beherrschen wird.
Es gibt keine neuen Beispiele, wie es funktioniert und, und, und.
Und vielleicht geht es sogar so weit, dass wir irgendwann dann auch kaum noch
neue Programmiersprachen sehen werden.
Weil die natürlich keiner benutzt, weil es keine AI gibt, die diese Programmiersprachen kann.
Also ich glaube, da geht der Zug hin.
Die Frage ist natürlich erreicht die AI in dem was sie tut eine Komplexitätsstufe,
dass der Mensch das nicht mehr versteht, was die AI tut,
dann ist handgeschriebene Software natürlich raus, das ist ganz klar also ob
wir das erreichen werden oder nicht, keine Ahnung kann jetzt jeder raten,
es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn es passiert aber dann ist es natürlich klar,
ja dann bist du als Programmierer raus aber gut, es gibt auch Menschen,
die sowas schreiben, was andere dann nicht mehr verstehen,
manchmal passiert das einfach so Ich glaube.
Da ist viel Wahres dran, an dem was du gesagt hast, aber es gibt wahrscheinlich
sogar noch ein paar andere Strahlen die hier noch mit reinleuchten können,
es ist zum Beispiel durchaus vorstellbar, dass wir demnächst IIs haben,
die Programmiersprachen entwerfen werden.
Oder dass sich sozusagen überhaupt ein neuer Layer zwischen Computern und AIs
bildet, also dass quasi die AI schon fast zum Betriebssystem wird.
Dass wir dieses ganze, wir benutzen ein Betriebssystem, was irgendwie für die
Programmierung durch eine Programmiersprache gedacht ist,
dass das komplett wegfällt und wir eigentlich nur noch so einen einzigen Processing-Blob
haben, der irgendwie freigeistig seine Daten durch die Gegend schaufelt,
gesteuert eben durch Sprache.
Das ist sicherlich auch so ein Punkt. Andererseits bin ich auch ganz bei dir,
wenn du sagst, das normale Programmieren ist immer noch erforderlich und das
ist auch absolut richtig.
Also ich hätte jetzt zum Beispiel meine ganzen Sachen auch nicht machen können,
wenn ich nicht schon eine relativ klare Vorstellung von Programmieren habe.
Und ich glaube auch, dass ich nochmal sehr viel besser mit einer AI arbeiten
kann, umso besser ich poemieren kann.
Also umso mehr man überhaupt das Poemieren als solches verstanden hat,
aber auch die Poemiersprache zu können.
Man muss auch in der Lage sein, Fehler zu finden, man muss auch in der Lage
sein, eine richtige Richtung anzugeben.
Man kann nicht einfach auf eine Baustelle gehen und anfangen,
irgendwie den Leuten ihre Arbeit zu erklären und sie durch die Gegend zu schicken,
wenn du einfach Bau nicht verstanden hast.
Du brauchst immer noch ein Domänenwissen. Und das ist beim Programmieren nur
mal die Programmiersprache und das Wissen um Betriebssysteme und Caching und
Networking und Protokolle und all dieser ganze Kram.
Also da ist schon noch eine ganze Menge drin zu lernen.
Und ich würde halt jetzt auch niemandem ein Projekt überlassen,
Der sagt ja, ich habe keine Ahnung, aber ich habe da jetzt mal eine halbe Stunde
reingequatscht und da kam ja schon irgendwas Brauchbares bei raus. Ich kann jetzt alles.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, ich sehe es viel stärker als den kontinuierlichen Trend
der weiteren Abstraktion der Programmierung.
Also in den 80ern hat man durchaus noch Assembler programmiert,
man hat C programmiert, was im Prinzip auch Assembler war und die Abstraktion
weg vom Prozessor wurde immer größer und immer größer.
Und inzwischen glaube ich, dass viele junge Programmierer nicht so genau wissen,
wie eigentlich der Compiler oder der Interpreter jetzt das, was sie da schreiben,
hinterher in etwas umsetzt, was tatsächlich auf dem Prozessor läuft.
Ob das okay ist oder nicht, ist eine andere Diskussion. Ich denke nur, dass dieser Trend,
das auszudrücken, was ich programmieren will durch Abstraktionen,
einfach nur jetzt eine neue Stufe erreicht.
Die Stufe ist dann halt gesprochene deutsche Sprache mit all ihren Ungenauigkeiten.
Also ich habe es halt auch ausprobiert und hatte das Gefühl,
ich habe eigentlich kaum Kontrolle oder Einfluss darauf, was die Maschine tut,
weil ich nicht in der Lage bin, klar zu sagen, mach mal das und das und das und das nicht.
Welches Modell hast du genommen dafür?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr, es war einfach Kaser. und ich sage,
mach mal das und das und das und dann kam irgendwas bei rum,
wo ich sagen würde, ja, okay, kann man als Lösung meiner Aufgabenstellung interpretieren.
Also hast du wahrscheinlich Chat-GPT benutzt, kann das sein? Also war das 4O?
Das war Cursor, keine Ahnung, was da eingestellt war.
Ja, okay, also wenn du es nicht eingestellt hast, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit
recht groß, dass du das benutzt hast. Das ist übrigens auch noch so ein Punkt, also,
AI ist nicht AI. Das merkt man wirklich bei dieser Cursorsache extrem.
Also ich habe mich jetzt, du benutzt ja auch so nett, ne Ralf?
Ja, nichts anderes kommt mir hier in die Pompa.
Das ist auch wirklich, glaube ich, derzeit der Goldstandard,
das muss man wirklich sagen.
Und es ist erstaunlich, wie sich die Interaktion ändert, wenn man ein anderes Modell nimmt.
Also wenn man jetzt irgendwie DeepSeq oder irgendein 4O, O1-Mini-Tralala-Open-AI-Modell nimmt,
dann ändert sich die gesamte Denke und die ganze Interaktion.
Also das ist auch, man benutzt nicht einfach nur AI in dem Moment,
sondern man fährt sich auch in gewisser Hinsicht auf ein Modell ein.
Also man muss auch lernen, so ein bisschen, wie soll man das nennen?
Es ist so eine kulturelle Begegnung. Also man muss wirklich dieser Intelligenz
mit Interesse begegnen und die kulturellen Eigenarten erlernen.
Das ist wie ein anderes Land zu bereisen, so ein bisschen. Da musst du auch
erstmal so ein bisschen die Sprache lernen.
Also ich habe es gerade geguckt, ich habe auch Sonnet benutzt.
Ah, okay. Das ist drei Filme, so eine drei Filme.
Ja, dass es halt hier drin ist.
Da sind ja mehrere Sachen drin. Du kannst da in den Prefs klicken und dann die
Models auswählen, wenn du mal so rechts oben wirst.
Ja, ich weiß, das ist da, vor allem
gibt es ganz, ah, ich kann dann hier umschalten. Da gibt es sehr viel.
Jetzt mittlerweile ist auch einiges nachge...
Ja, ja, ja, ich sehe es schon hier. Die Psyk ist auch mit drin, das sehe ich gerade.
Ja, aber ich habe ziemlich sicher so nett benutzt. Trotzdem ist es halt so,
also gerade so grafische Oberflächen, das ist halt schwierig zu beschreiben,
dass es so aussieht, wie man es eigentlich haben will.
Ja, gut.
Ich habe jetzt nicht versucht zu sagen, mach mal hier noch drei Pixel weniger
und da noch drei Pixel mehr, aber.
Würde ich auch sagen, GUI ist das, wo noch am meisten schief geht,
weil da halt, da kommt glaube ich auch diese Erkenntnis drin,
dass da halt dann dem, der KI auch das Auge fehlt.
Also man kann ja Screenshots auch, ich weiß nicht, hast du das schon mal gemacht,
Tim, einen Screenshot irgendwo rein posten und zu sagen, guck mal hier,
das sieht falsch aus. Das habe ich noch überhaupt nie ausprobiert,
ob das eigentlich auch geht.
Ich weiß, dass das jetzt auch ein neues Feature ist, aber ich habe das noch nicht benutzt.
Also weil da fruckele ich immer am meisten. Ich habe ja noch ein anderes Projekt,
das stelle ich in einem der nächsten Sendungen mal vor, was ich da gebaut habe.
Da geht es viel darum, dass das so eine Ich-möchte-dran-lecken-GUI wird.
Und das ist auch schon nicht so einfach.
Gerade so dann doch verschachteltes CSS. Ich habe jetzt hier wieder Bootstrap
drunter, wo ich mittlerweile denke, das war eigentlich ein Fehler,
weil wenn du irgendwo von den Standard-Bootstrap-Komponenten abgehst,
hat Sonnet echt Probleme, sich dann im Hierarchie-Modell durchzusetzen gegenüber den Standards.
Tailwind, Freif, Tailwind.
Tailwind, okay.
Tailwind ist the shit. Naja gut,
dieses,
Wir werden ja eh gleich nochmal drauf kommen, über Dipsig reden.
Ich habe aber nochmal kurz einen Nachtrag zu Cursor, weil da tut sich ja schon
wieder der nächste Kram auf.
Habt ihr schon mal was von MCP gehört?
MCP glaubt nicht...
MCP steht für Model Context Protocol und das ist eine Erfindung von Anthropic,
also der Hersteller von Sonnet, von dem Modell, also von Claude und dem Claude
Sonnet, das Modell, was wir jetzt gerade besprochen haben.
Und Model Context Protocol ist, wie der Name sagt, ein Protokoll,
was quasi definiert, wie eine AI auf Daten zugreifen kann.
Und das ist so ein Client-Server-Protokoll und man kann das im Prinzip in beide Richtungen benutzen.
Das heißt, man kann für ein Modell definieren,
wie dort Daten reinkommen, indem man es als Client benutzt, aber man kann vor
allem für Daten ein Server-API, hat man jetzt sozusagen für Daten ein Server-API,
man kann also ein Server für Datensilos schreiben,
um einer AI darauf Zugriff zu bekommen.
Beispiel. Das Beispiel, was sie auch gleich mitgeliefert haben.
Also sie haben das so im letzten November haben sie das vorgestellt und mittlerweile
ist es jetzt in Cursor drin.
Also wenn du jetzt Cursor updatest in den Settings, mal guckst,
dann hast du quasi MCP-Server, die da mehr oder weniger schon mit supported
werden oder MCP-Server werden supported und das ist noch ein bisschen,
fitzelig, aber worauf ich hinaus wollte ist, sie haben halt was gebaut für Systeme
wie Google Drive, Slack,
GitHub, Git,
Postgres und Puppetierer weiß ich gar nicht, was das ist, um ehrlich zu sein.
Soll heißen, du kannst über MCP eine AI Zugriff geben, zum Beispiel auf Postgres.
Und das sieht dann so aus, dass du dann sagst, so eine Postgres-URL gibst mit
hier über diesen User-Login, AddHost, AddPort, tralala,
mit diesem Pfad und hier benenne ich die Datenbank, kannst du quasi direkt einen
Zugriff geben auf die Datenbank über das MCP-Protokoll.
Und dann redet das Ding mit deiner Datenbank. Und dann kannst du quasi in deiner
relationalen Datenbank genauso rumrecherchieren und deine AI spielen lassen,
wie du das eben vorher mit normalen Files gemacht hast, mit Textfiles gemacht hast.
Also du kannst halt eine dicke, fette Datenbank nehmen und sagen, analysier mal das.
Aber du kannst halt genauso auch auf GitHub, Git generell, also auf Git-Repository,
in ein Slack hinein Dinge erfragen.
Das ist ziemlich mindblowing.
Genau. Und solche Systeme kommen jetzt irgendwie raus.
Das wird ganz spannend werden. Habe ich jetzt noch nicht so viel mit rumgespielt.
Ich habe mal diesen Postgres-MCP einmal so zum Laufen bekommen.
Da muss man irgendwie so NPM installieren und so weiter.
Luca hat mir gesagt, wie ich das machen muss und ich habe es gemacht und es
hat dann irgendwie funktioniert. Aber dann hatte ich irgendwie auch gerade wieder keine Zeit.
Und das ist auch in dieser Cloud-Desktop-App drin, dieser MCP-Server-Support.
Kann man auf jeden Fall demnächst noch einiges erwarten.
Insofern ganz spannend, als dass das jetzt nochmal ein anderer Ansatz ist,
als das, was wir ja schon länger mit diesen RAC-Modellen haben,
dieses Retrieval Augmented Generation.
Wir erinnern uns, das ist was, was wir hier bei unserem FAB-KI-Chatbot gemacht
haben, wo man sich mit unserem Bibliothekskatalog unterhalten kann.
Da wird aber eben nicht quasi ein direkter Datenkonnektor zu unserer Datenbank
gebracht, sondern wir haben ja unsere Datenbank mal in so einen semantischen
Vektorraum dafür überführt, in dem sich so eine KI dann wohlfühlt. Ja.
Den gewissen Problemen und Einschränkungen, die das mit sich bringt,
insbesondere was halt so diese Exaktheit, die man ja eigentlich dann ganz gerne
in der Datenbank dann doch auch nicht verlieren möchte, drin hat.
Auf der anderen Seite kann ich mir jetzt vorstellen, aber das müssen wir wirklich
mal ausprobieren, dass jetzt so ein MCP-Ansatz natürlich dazu führt,
dass man dann wiederum die Stärke dieses Assoziierens nicht so stark drin hat,
wie wenn das quasi in einem reinen Vektorraum modelliert wird.
Also sprich, ich finde jetzt Dinge, die ähnlich sind, obwohl sie in der Datenbank
erstmal keine direkte Verbindung über irgendein Datenmodell drin haben.
Also weil sie ähnlich klingen oder über drei Ecken dann doch irgendwo miteinander
verwandtschaftet sind. Da muss man mal drauf gucken.
Ja, kann ich dir wenig zu sagen, habe mir das Protokoll jetzt ehrlich gesagt
selber noch nicht angeschaut, was das alles kann und abstrahieren kann,
aber kannst dir ja vorstellen, wenn es in der Lage ist, sowas wie Postgres oder Git abzubilden,
dann ist es sicherlich auch in der Lage, deine Bibliotheksdatenbank abzubilden
und wenn du jetzt quasi dir mit der AI morgen einen MCP-Server dafür programmierst,
dann kannst du vielleicht übermorgen schon mit Sonnet auf deiner Bibliotheksdatenbank,
rumrecherchieren.
Das mag sein, aber die olle Recherche habe ich ja schon.
Also erinnere dich an das Beispiel, ich habe als Kind ein Buch gelesen,
wo dreibeinige Aliens die Erde erobert haben. So, was war denn das?
Das steht nicht in der Datenbank. Aber,
ChatGPT weiß halt, das waren die dreibeinigen Herrscher von wie hieß er noch, weiß ich nicht was.
Weil das also quasi eben dann gekoppeltes Weltwissen ist. Aber das weiß er nur, weil er...
Wieso steht das nicht in der Datenbank? Wieso stehen die Bücher nicht in der Datenbank?
Die Bücher stehen schon so drin, aber die Leute stellen halt Fragen,
die nicht zu unseren Bibliotheksdaten passen.
Wieso? Welche Daten fehlen denn, wenn ihr die Bücher da nicht drin habt?
Die Bücher heißen halt irgendwie die dreibeinigen Herrscher. Das sagt dir nichts.
Dass das Außerirdische ist. Habt ihr die Bücher selber auch in der Datenbank?
Habt ihr da nicht ein PDF, wo das...
Nein, natürlich nicht. Dürfen wir doch nicht. Wo denkst du denn hin?
Wir sind Deutschland hier. Urheberrecht. Raubmordkopierer.
Wieso? Urheberrecht ist doch noch relevant, wenn du es wegkopierst. Nein, nein.
Da streiten wir uns seit 15, 20 Jahren mit den Verlagen rum.
Das deutsche Urheberrecht erlaubt es uns nicht, die Volltexte unserer Bücher selber.
So ohne weiteres.
Wir kriegen die auch gar nicht von den Verlagen. Wir müssten alles selber scannen
und OCRen und alles ein Elend. Don't get me started.
Das ist doch echt zum Kotzen.
So, aber selbst dann hast du es ja auch nicht irgendwie wirklich gut für eine LLM.
Also mein Grundverdacht wäre,
dass das super ist, um quasi jetzt sowas wie Lucene oder Solar abzulösen.
Also so eine klassische Suchmaschine obendrüber. Aber um jetzt so eine eben
dann doch eher so frei assoziierende Dinge miteinander in Verbindung setzende
LLM-Suche zu simulieren,
dass dafür die Zeit wahrscheinlich nicht reicht, weil es muss ja alles irgendwie in Echtzeit passieren,
ohne dass er sich schon lange und tief Gedanken über das Gesamtkonvolut gemacht hat.
Aber es ist jetzt alles gefährliches Halbwissen, wir werden uns das angucken.
Genau, wir werden uns das angucken, genau.
So, wo wollen wir denn jetzt hin?
Achso, ich habe noch ein paar Geräte-Updates, weil ich ja hier mit neuem Gerät
unterwegs bin, auf meiner Reise.
Unter anderem habe ich mir für die Reise ein Rodecaster Duo besorgt der Rodecaster
Duo ist quasi die kleine Version vom Rodecaster Pro 2,
den ich ja ganz toll finde und zu dem ich irgendwie auch auf dem letzten Kongress
wie schon erwähnt nochmal so einen kleinen Talk gemacht habe und ja der viele
Vorteile hat auch ein paar Nachteile, zu denen ich mich ja auch schon geäußert habe.
Jetzt habe ich mir diesen Duo geholt, der deshalb Duo heißt,
weil er eben nicht vier Mikrofoneingänge hat, sondern zwei.
Beziehungsweise genau genommen hat er nicht zwei Mikrofoneingänge,
sondern ich rede von zwei XLR-Mikrofoneingängen.
Denn das Gerät hat noch ein paar Besonderheiten. Ich hatte ja auch im Sendegate
mal diesen Rodecaster 2 Review gemacht.
Das können wir hier auch nochmal verlinken.
Und ich habe dem meine Gedanken zum Rodekaster Duo jetzt noch hinzugefügt.
Also sozusagen eine Aktualisierung.
Ich packe mal den Link auch nochmal in die Shownotes.
Genau, im Wesentlichen, also vier statt sechs Sliders, Slider ein bisschen kürzer,
sechs statt acht Buttons zum Abspielen, Displays genauso groß,
paar andere kleine Sachen.
Eine Sache hat sich verändert, die zwar noch keine positiven Auswirkungen hat,
aber was durchaus eine Forderung von mir gewesen ist für ein künftiges Update
von dem Rodecaster Pro 2 ist nämlich, dass die Lautstärkeknöpfe jetzt Soft-Buttons sind.
Also die sind sozusagen keine manuellen Potentiometer mehr mit einem festen
Anschlag, sondern sind so frei, wie nennt man denn sowas, so Rotatoren,
so freidrehende, beliebig weitdrehende Knöpfe, die so einen LED-Ring drumherum haben.
Mit anderen Worten, man kann da jederzeit per Software auch sagen,
welchen Wert sie haben, theoretisch.
Das ist gut.
Und das wäre natürlich fantastisch, wenn man das auch von außen tun könnte,
dazu bräuchte natürlich dieser Rodecaster mal eine richtige MIDI-Implementierung,
die er nicht hat, sondern das ist halt nach wie vor dieses Krücken-Blödsins-
MIDI-Implementierung, die sie da reingebaut haben,
über die ich mich schon mal total aufgeregt habe, aber man kann jetzt auf jeden
Fall die Dinger drehen, man kann übrigens, wie ich gerade feststelle,
man kann sie auch drücken, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was das macht.
Tue es jetzt nicht.
Doch, ich habe schon gedrückt. So ein Familienbenutzer ist das.
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was das soll.
Vielleicht kann man es damit irgendwie auf einen definierten Wert oder sowas
setzen, aber das ist hier zumindest gerade nicht der Fall.
Als nächstes will er eine Space-Maus an dem Ding.
Ah, man kann sogar den großen kann man ja auch drücken. Ging das bei dem alten Rundcaster auch schon?
Wow, damit kann man ja hier durch...
Ralf, drück doch mal.
Oh, okay, das muss ich nochmal, da habe ich jetzt gerade was entdeckt.
Naja, also auf jeden Fall kleine Verbesserungen und eine Eigenschaft hat er
auch noch, er hat nämlich vorne tatsächlich einen Miniklinkenanschluss.
Ich dachte, was soll das denn? Weiß ich auch immer noch nicht genau,
was das soll, aber man kann dort quasi so ein iPhone-Headset,
so ein altes, ein analoges reinstecken und hat einerseits einen Kopfhörer,
aber auch einen Eingang.
Also man kann sozusagen auch nochmal einen Plug-in-Power Mikrofon noch als dritten
Eingang auch nochmal mit reinmachen in diesen Rodecaster, der eigentlich nur
zwei Mikrofoneingänge hat, nämlich dann trotzdem noch einen dritten.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das soll, das ist einfach nur nochmal so ein Monokanal natürlich.
Man kann den quasi zum Abhören benutzen, zum reinquatschen da steckt man halt
nicht volles XLR Material rein sondern eben wie gesagt nur so ein kleines Plug-in-Power-Teil,
aber ja ist auch noch mit dabei,
also merkwürdige Designentscheidungen noch immer eine Software, die,
sich verbessern muss, aber,
Rodecaster Duo is a thing und für wen jetzt zwei Mikrofoneingänge reichen, durchaus eine Option.
Also dieser Eingang vorne, der ist pures Gold,
weil da ist ja so eine sogenannte Plug-in-Power mit dran, 3 Volt oder 5 Volt
und da kann man halt beispielsweise das von mir so wertgeschätzte V-Moda Boom Pro dran betreiben.
Der spirituelle Nachfolger von dem HMC 660.
Das ist ein Kleinmembran-Kondensator-Mikro für 35 Euro, was fantastisch klingt,
robustes Gegenbrauchen und sonst was. Man braucht dann noch einen Kopfhörer dazu.
Ich habe in die Show Notes mal reingeworfen, welche günstigen Kopfhörer sich
da gut zu eignen. Und dann hast du für 60 Euro ein Top-Headset.
Und dann kannst du das da dran anschließen, ohne weitere Adapter.
Und hast ein Dreier-Device. Das ist doch cool.
Aber du hast nur zwei Kopfhörerausgänge dann, oder? Das heißt also,
du musst einen der Kopfhörerausgänge dann splitten für die dritte Person?
Nein, nein. Du hast ja einen vollständigen, vierpoligen Stecker.
Ah, okay. Und wie machst du dann da Ja, ist schon klar, so TRS oder wie das
heißt, aber wie ist dann darüber die Lautstärke geregelt?
Na, das ist halt so einer dieser Softkanäle, den kannst du dir theoretisch auf
einen der vier Slider legen.
Ah, okay.
Also entweder auf einen der vier,
physischen Slider oder einen von den drei virtuellen Slidern,
die im Display noch sind.
Also das ist tatsächlich eine Option.
Wie das klingt, ob das was kann, keine Ahnung, habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Ich habe so ein Ding nicht mehr rumliegen, so ein iPhone-Dings,
das habe ich also entsorgt.
Ist mir nur aufgefallen. Ich weiß nicht genau, was überhaupt der Sinn der ganzen
Sache sein soll, also warum sie da sowas jetzt einbauen und warum vorne?
Ich glaube, weil viele so Gamer-Headsets und so, kannst du einfach anstecken und fertig.
Ja, aber warum vorne? Also warum dann nicht hinten?
Wie alle anderen auch. Also das ist mir so ein bisschen unklar.
Also ich konnte mir das nur so vorstellen, dass das mehr so ein,
Podcast-Situation, zwei Männer unterhalten sich und ein Assistent überwacht die Aufnahme.
So klingt das für mich so ein bisschen.
Also es ist der Studio-Kopfhörer dann für den Mixer.
Ja, das ist halt nur jemand, der so ein bisschen mithören will,
funktioniert noch alles, aber nicht professionell aufgenommen wird,
vielleicht mal was reinquatschen kann.
Keine Ahnung, also mit der Logik hätten sie natürlich auch noch zwei davon machen
können oder ganz viele, weil die ja fast gar keinen Platz verbrauchen.
Mir ist es so ein bisschen unklar, wo sie das Produkt jetzt genau sehen,
mit diesen Änderungen, warum sie jetzt hier diese digitalen Regler haben,
wo vorher die analogen Regler waren für die Lautsprecher, ohne dass sie jetzt
da irgendeinen Nutzen draus ziehen.
Ich würde da wirklich gerne mal auftauchen irgendwie. Vielleicht fahre ich im
Herbst mal nach Australien und frage die mal selber, was da ist.
Die sitzen ja da irgendwo rum.
So wie zum RodeCaster.
Der ist immer noch so ein bisschen zu teuer. Jetzt in der Zweier-Version liegt der so um 460 Euro.
Außerdem so ein Huni weniger.
Naja.
Sie sagten doch gleich was?
Ich brauche es halt überhaupt nicht, aber es ist irgendwie so ein Teil,
was man eigentlich gerne hätte.
Das liegt jetzt aber noch über der Scheiß drauf. Das wirft man da jetzt mal
ab, das Geld. Dafür sind dann 460 Euro.
Von Stream Deck gibt es ja jetzt dieses Teil, was auch Drehknöpfe hat,
so Rotatoreingangsteile.
Genau, der Streamer X, glaube ich.
Das L oder so ähnlich heißt das Ding. Nee, der ist es nicht, von Streamdeck selber.
Und dafür gibt es jetzt auch ein Interface,
was du da noch hinten ranklemmen kannst und dann hast du im Prinzip halt für
deine Streaming-Anwendungen hast
du halt deinen Mikrofoneingang und deinen Kopfhörerausgang und so weiter.
Es ist aber auch alles eigentlich zu teuer dafür, was es tut.
Und auch nur für einen einzigen dann?
Ich glaube nur für einen, ja.
Von welchem Produkt redest du gerade?
Streamdeck XL. Das hat noch so vier Drehknöpfe.
Für dieses Ding gibt es noch, wenn du auf der Seite direkt guckst,
dann gibt es für das Teil noch ein Audiointerface, was du so hinten ranschraubst.
Okay.
Aber es ist nicht der Stream Deck XL.
Das hier meinst du, oder?
Oder XL, oder wie heißt der Stream Deck Pro?
XL ist das ganz alte, was ich auch noch...
Ne, das ist ein Yamaha.
Das ist ja was anderes.
Alles klicktaktisch.
Der Neo, der hat auch Knöpfe.
Also es ist so einer, der hat so vier Drehregler.
Und so ein etwas kleinerer, der hat so vier Drehregler. Und da kannst du hinten
noch ein Audio-Interface ranklemmen.
Stream Deck Plus genau so heißt der.
Der hat noch ein Audio-Interface hinten dran. Echt? Wieso zeigen sie das hier nicht?
Nein, es gibt ein Audio-Interface, was du hinten ran machen kannst.
Und das ist aber auch von Elgato?
Das ist auch von Elgato. Wenn du auf der Elgato-Seite guckst und nicht die Google-Bildersuche,
zu random Webseiten klickst, dann...
Ich bin auf der Elgato-Webseite.
Aber ich weiß nicht genau, wo ich jetzt hingucken soll. Von welchem Produkt
redest du denn jetzt? Sag doch einfach mal.
Was ist das hier wieder für ein hektisches...
Mobile? Nee.
So, jetzt haben wir das XLR-Dock für Stream Deck Plus.
Genau das.
Ah, okay.
Ja, weiß ich nicht, ob das eine sinnvolle Erweiterung ist.
Also es ist jetzt ein XLR-Eingang, Kopfhörer, Mini-Klinke.
Und dann hast du im Prinzip für eine Person Audio-Interface und kannst dann
die Regler vorne dran direkt verwenden, um diese...
Aber da bist du dann auch schon 380.
Ja, ich sag ja, es ist zu teuer. Aber haben würde man es schon gerne wollen.
Das will ich nicht haben.
Kannst du mal die Dinger mal verlinken? Ich finde irgendwie diese Produkte nicht.
Ja, ich hab das jetzt was.
Ja, naja, es gibt da so einiges. Es gibt auch von Rode, ich weiß nicht, hatten wir,
hatten wir da eigentlich drüber gesprochen, über den Rode-Videos? videocaster.
Ich glaube nicht.
Das kann ich nicht erinnern.
Nee, hatten wir nicht. Ich hatte mir das nämlich mal, Rodecaster Video,
genau, so heißt das Ding nämlich.
Und da wünschte ich mir fast, ich würde mehr mit Video machen. Mache ich aber nicht.
Deswegen habe ich mir das nicht gekauft.
Ich hatte das Ding kurz mir mal angeschaut, weil ich mir dachte,
vielleicht ist das ja ein Ersatz für meine HDMI-Switching-Möglichkeit. War es dann aber nicht.
Aber das Produkt ist wirklich irre.
Also der Rodecaster Video, das ist jetzt ein Review, ohne dass ich das Ding selber angefasst habe.
Ich habe mir nur irgendwie diverse Videos, Reviews darüber angeschaut und ich
bin wirklich beeindruckt, was sie da zusammengebaut haben. Das ist ein irres Produkt.
Also das ist so ein, wie groß ist der in etwa, weiß ich nicht,
so breit vielleicht wie ein normaler Rodecaster Pro.
Also halb bis 19 Zoll breit und vielleicht eine ganze Höhe in eineinhalb hoch.
Ja, ich müsste mir die Specs jetzt mal anschauen. Also im Wesentlichen hast
du da nur so zwei Tastaturreihen drauf und ein paar Regler und ein kleines Bildschirmchen.
Und hinten hat das Ding aber eine Brigade an Anschlüssen.
Da ist also mal nicht weniger als sechs HDMI-Ports, sechs USB-C-Ports, Ethernet,
zwei analoge große Klinken für Kopfhörer, zwei analoge große Klinken für den
Monitor Out und nochmal zwei Mikrofoneingänge.
Also die haben da wirklich geklotzt.
Hast du mal ein Ding?
Ja, sicherlich.
Der Moment, jetzt hast mich ein bisschen aus der Spur gebracht. Ich mach das mal eben.
Ich hab schon so. und,
kann ich euch nur empfehlen, euch mal so ein paar Reviews anzuschauen,
was das Ding alles kann. Das ist wirklich irre.
Wofür ist es gedacht? Das ist, wenn man jetzt quasi mit Video raussendet.
Also so typischerweise YouTube-Videos macht, dafür ist es im Wesentlichen gedacht
und du möchtest alles irgendwie in Realtime machen.
Und du kannst also ganz viele HDMI-Quellen anschließen, also von diesen 6 HDMI-Ports
sind 4 Eingänge und 2 sind Ausgänge.
Das eine benutzt du als Primärausgang, das andere benutzt du so als Monitorausgang.
Und diese USB-C Ports, die es da gibt, die sind teilweise auch nochmal nur dafür
gemacht, ein Mikrofon oder eine Webcam anzuschließen.
Oder dann eine Festplatte zum Abspeichern oder nochmal einen anderen Computer.
Und natürlich auch Stromversorgung darüber. SD-Karte kannst du auch noch reinstecken,
also es ist wirklich alles so ein bisschen da.
Sprich, du kannst das Ding in so einem HD, 4K,
Webcam Dings anschließen und ganz viele HDMI-Quellen noch dazu schalten und
du kannst dann eben über die wenigen Tasten vorne so all die ganzen Quellen live umschalten,
du kannst dir mit der Rode-Software aber auch direkt am Gerät auch so Screens
zusammenbauen, wo du sagen kannst okay, jetzt will ich einen Bildschirm haben
und rechts oben soll die Quelle sein, links unten die Quelle so, was weiß ich,
hier Bild von mir selber mit der
Kamera und dann halt der Rechner und dann nochmal hier ein HDMI-Device.
Also du kannst das alles hier zusammenbauen und so fertige Setups einfach abrufen.
Und es bedient sich alles ganz super und es ist wirklich ein tolles Gerät.
Und außerdem hast du noch Audio noch mit dabei.
Also das ist schon wirklich heftig, was die da bauen.
Und ich muss sagen, Rode ist da auf einem sehr guten Weg.
Also wenn sie ihr Midi-Game nochmal auf die Kette kriegen, dann wäre ich so richtig begeistert.
Aber das ist definitiv cool.
Das könnte auch interessant sein für Leute, die einfach oft so an Videokonferenzen teilnehmen.
Und was zeigen. Weißt du?
Also kannst du ja auch eine eigene Banderole einblenden und deinen Namen einblenden. Keine Ahnung.
Und dann hier so, jetzt schalte ich mal auf den Rechner und jetzt schalte ich
auf die Präsentation und jetzt zeige ich mich selber.
Und jetzt habe ich rechts oben
meine Präsentation und links sieht man aber trotzdem noch mein Gesicht.
Also wenn man wirklich viel online, live in irgendwelche Zoom-Meetings rein
präsentiert und dabei irgendwie schick rüberkommen will,
ohne viel Aufwand zu haben und ohne mit einer komplizierten Software arbeiten
zu müssen, dann ist der RodeCaster Video richtig Bombe.
Kostet auch noch schlanke, 1100 Euro.
Ja, aber das ist natürlich für so einen Videomixer eigentlich nichts.
Ja, eigentlich nicht, das stimmt.
Wow.
Genau, den wollte ich nochmal empfehlen. Wie gesagt, nicht selber handgetestet,
weil ich nicht so die Anwendung habe, Aber ich fand das Gerät total beeindruckend.
Dann habe ich ja noch ein anderes Gerät hier an der Mache, nämlich die Apple
Vision Pro vom DOM, die ich ja hier mit auf Reisen genommen habe.
Und jetzt habe ich ja mal so richtig Zeit, das Ding ausführlich zu testen.
Ich will jetzt gar nicht so viel erzählen, weil so viel Neues gibt es jetzt nicht.
Ich will nur andeuten, dass ich meine Meinung, glaube ich, in ein paar Bereichen überarbeiten werde,
weil ich schon auf einmal mehr Nutzen gefunden habe, als ich dachte.
Ich habe den jetzt halt vor allem so als großen Bildschirm quasi dabei,
ohne einen großen Bildschirm dabei zu haben und genieße sehr diesen neuen Mac
Monitor Modus und das ist also gerade so zum Programmieren ist das irgendwie
ziemlich cool, also wenn man wirklich so Sessions macht und jetzt nicht nur
auf so einen 13 Zoll Bildschirm starren will, sondern,
sehr viel Platz für den Editor haben will und nochmal Platz für irgendwelche
Videos und Dokumentationsseiten und hier noch ein Terminal, was mitläuft,
dann ist es wirklich grandios, weil seit diesem 2.2 Update,
wo du diesen Riesen, also aus deinem Rechner sozusagen so einen Riesenmonitor
machen kannst, ist es wirklich krass.
Ich habe mir dann auch nochmal diese Lesebrilleneinsätze dafür noch gekauft,
in einer relativ starken Variante.
Das ist für mich immer noch sehr schwierig, dass alles so einzusortieren,
aber ich habe so, ich setze gerade so ein bisschen auf einen Gewöhnungseffekt.
Also Sachen, die einem am Anfang sehr störend vorkommen, stören einen nach einer
Weile einfach nicht mehr so sehr, beziehungsweise man lernt so ein bisschen damit umzugehen.
Also zum Beispiel so dieses Unschärfe bei der Bewegung und dass da immer so
ein kleiner Delay drin ist, durchaus etwas, woran man sich gewöhnen kann.
Und ich habe da muss ich dir übrigens nochmal danken, Ralf, das hast du mir
zwar nicht direkt gesagt, aber ich habe das so am Rande mitbekommen,
du hast über diese Halterung, diese Bügelhalterung geredet, die manche sich da dran machen,
dieses Gewicht mir auf die Stirn verlagert wird, das habe ich kurz vor der Abfahrt,
habe ich mir noch so ein Ding noch geholt und das ist tatsächlich,
macht es einen Riesenunterschied aus und auch so diese,
Idee mit, man ist gar nicht mehr direkt an der Kamera dran, sondern lässt das
Ding einfach nur so ein bisschen vor sich schweben, ist auch durchaus etwas, was man benutzen kann.
Also ich habe da noch keine abschließende Meinung zu allem gebildet,
aber ich bin auf jeden Fall gerade sehr intensiv dabei, das alles zu überprüfen
und nochmal mir dann eine neue Meinung zu bilden.
Und zwei kleine Sachen, die mir noch aufgefallen sind, die wir so wie noch nie besprochen haben.
Wenn man in diesem Macintosh-Desktop-Modus arbeitet, greift übrigens auch dieses Universal Control.
Ihr erinnert euch, Universal Control, man hat mehrere Macs nebeneinander und
kann dann irgendwie mit der Maus von dem einen auf alle anderen gehen und vice versa.
Also man kann immer mit einem Rechner, den man gerade bedient,
alle anderen mitsteuern.
Also du gehst halt einfach auf einen anderen Bildschirm und kannst mit der Maus
von Rechner A die Apps auf Bildschirmen von Rechner B steuern.
Weil die Maus einfach rüber marschiert.
Und das Irre ist, das ist mir auch erst jetzt aufgefallen, das geht halt auch
in der Apple Vision Pro mit den Apple Vision Pro Apps.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt den Macintosh auf der Vision Pro habe und ich habe
die Maus, dann kann ich mit der Maus den Mac verlassen und in die Apps von der Vision Pro gehen.
Die ja entweder Native Vision Pro Apps sind oder iPad Apps sind,
aber ich kann tatsächlich mit der Maus die Vision Pro benutzen.
Bin ich gezwungen, alles damit zu machen.
Das geht natürlich nur, wenn du den Mac hast, sozusagen, aber da verheiraten
sich auf einmal so Konzepte, das könnte nochmal ganz interessant werden.
Und Tastatur-Eingabe wahrscheinlich dann auch, oder?
Ja, genau. Tastatur-Eingabe natürlich auch.
Weil das ist ja, finde ich, das größte Manko der Vision Pro Text-Eingabe.
Ja, ja. Kannst dann auch in Apple Vision Pro Apps mit der Tastatur reintappen,
genau. Und ja, irgendwie man will langsam den Mac einfach in diesem Teil drin haben.
Ich kenne auch jetzt, ich habe von Leuten gehört oder Videos gesehen,
die sagen so, ja, ich habe jetzt eine Vision Pro und einen Mac Mini.
Und der Mac Mini ist so mein Reisecomputer. Der hat aber voll die Power.
Ich brauche aber keinen Bildschirm dafür. Ich brauche nur eine Tastatur und eine Maus.
Und die habe ich halt irgendwie noch so mit dabei. Und dann nehme ich die Vision
Pro und das ist dann mein Bildschirm.
Also das könnte noch ganz das könnte noch ganz lustig werden.
Ja. Und dann, ach ja genau, und eine App, die habe ich noch entdeckt,
das muss ich noch erzählen, die heißt Magic Room.
Die tut eigentlich wenig, kostet trotzdem 18 Euro, aber ich musste es kaufen.
Und das ist wirklich crazy.
Die Apple Vision Pro hat ja so einen LIDAR-Sensor, ähnlich wie das iPhone.
Dein Gesicht abtastet, genauso taste diese apple vision pro den raum um dich herum.
Gewinnt also die ganze Zeit so ein dreidimensionales Profil und damit realisiert
sie halt solche Funktionalitäten wie dieses Durchbrechen der Virtual Reality
oder deines Environments,
wenn du halt eigentlich nur auf generierten Content schaust,
aber irgendjemand nähert sich halt deiner Brille, dann merkt die Brille so,
ah, da ist irgendetwas, da kommt eine Person und dann reißt an der Stelle quasi
die Illusion auf, damit du dann diese Person siehst.
Und genauso dann wird dann auch diese Eyesight aktiv und dann weiß dann die
Person, dass du sie siehst und all diese ganzen Tricks, die die Vision Pro so
macht und genauso natürlich, um zu verhindern, dass man gegen eine Wand läuft,
hast du halt dieses Lida-Ding da irgendwie mit drin.
Und diese Funktionalität, auf die können Apps aber auch zugreifen und das tun sie auch ganz gerne.
Man braucht da irgendwie zusätzliche Permissions und diese App,
die ich jetzt da gekauft habe, Magic Room, die benutzt also diesen LIDAR-Sensor,
um in den Raum reinzuschauen.
Und erhält quasi in Realtime ein dreidimensionales Abbild der Umgebung.
Und was sie dann macht, ist, dass sie diese dreidimensionale Abbild da so eine
Art Regenbogenfarben des Gitternetz drüber legt.
Das heißt, du stehst vor so einem Schrank und dann siehst du sozusagen so diesen
Schrank, als hätte der so aus LED-Fäden so ein Gitternetz aus Dreiecken da drüber.
Und dann schaust du nach links und nach rechts und die ganze Zeit refined sich
das irgendwo, du schaust so nach oben und langsam baut sich das alles so kumulativ
auf. Das heißt, der ganze Raum um dich herum erstrahlt so als Gitternetz.
Und das sieht schon mal ganz spacig aus. Sieht besonders deshalb auch spacig
aus, weil es auch noch einen anderen Modus gibt, in dem du das Ganze auch noch
in so einer Matrix-Optik anschauen kannst.
Also dann hast du halt wirklich diese Matrix-grünen Wasserfälle aus Zeichen.
Das sieht ganz cool aus. Aber dieses Gitternetz ist eigentlich viel interessanter
und zwar aus folgendem Grund, weil dann kannst du nämlich auch aus dem Raum
rausgehen und ich bin hier in so einem Haus und dieses Haus hat drei Etagen.
Und ich kann jetzt von jeder Etage zu jeder Etage gehen.
Und jetzt bin ich sozusagen von Raum zu Raum gegangen und überall baut sich
immer wieder dieses Muster auf.
Aber er setzt nicht den einen Raum durch den anderen, sondern er merkt sich alles.
Und ich kann dann auch die Treppe runtergehen und sehe die Räume,
in denen ich eben noch war, über mir.
Ich gucke also nach oben und sehe sozusagen so dreidimensionelle Gitternetzräume, die so über mir sind.
Und auf einmal kann ich den ganzen Raum komplett in seiner dreidimensionalen
Ausprägung, also das gesamte Haus in seiner dreidimensionalen Ausprägung sehen.
Sehe sozusagen jedes Objekt, was in irgendeiner Form erkannt wurde und kann
quer durch das ganze Haus durchschauen, wie so ein Röntgenapparat.
Total irre. Und dann merkst du einfach auch immer, wie diese Kamera arbeiten
kann, dass sie sich also wirklich diese ganzen Kontexte und Orte merkt und dabei sehr präzise ist.
Weil du gehst dann wieder in diese Räume wieder rein, also zwei Etagen nach
oben und gehst wieder in den gleichen Raum rein, das ist irgendwie alles noch
da und ergänzt sich sozusagen einfach oder refindt sich die ganze Zeit,
während du dann wieder auf die Objekte draufstarrst. Das ist total irre.
Also es gibt schon ein paar coole Sachen.
Ist ab 17, ne, die App. Das wird wohl von Apple als Droge oder so eingestuft.
Also zumindest sieht auch das Ankündigungsvideo im App Store wirklich so aus,
als hätte man dann was genommen, weil es auch so komisch wabert.
Zwei Kommentare dazu in dem von mir sehr geschätzten Prequel Film von Alien, nämlich,
Prometheus, gibt es diese schöne Szene, wo sie Drohnen durch so ein Höhlensystem,
durchfliegen lassen, mit auch so einem 3D-Scan,
Teil, wo sich dann gleichzeitig so ein 3D-Modell des ganzen Tunnelsystems irgendwie
so aufbaut, das ist genauso derselbe Effekt, wenn man das mal im Film sehen will sehr schön.
Und das gibt es in der Tat für das iPhone schon relativ lange.
Und zwar in der Kategorie ich will einen Grundriss von meinem Haus erstellen.
So, welche Zimmer sind da eigentlich und wie viele Quadratmeter haben die und
wo sind die Türen drin und wo sind die Fenster und sowas. Die kosten auch gar nicht viel.
Ja, genau. Das heißt also da, klar hast du dann kein 3D und kannst dann nicht irgendwie,
in der in der mit den Augen halt irgendwie die jetzt da sonst wohin schauen.
Aber wer einfach das Grundprinzip mal ausprobieren will, da gibt es glaube ich
auch kostenlose sogar, die das mittlerweile schon machen.
Dieses Framework ist schon ziemlich alt, dass Apple das eingeführt hat.
Aber ja, total coole Anwendung. Finde ich auch super.
Das Framework ist ein bisschen älter, damit habe ich auch schon mal was gemacht.
Ja, aber es funktioniert auch wirklich ganz gut. Die Quest hat auch so einen
Modus, wo sie sagt, so Achtung, da ist ein Tisch und da wird auch so ein Gitter drüber gelegt.
Das ist schon immer ein ganz cooler Moment, wenn so dieses Virtuelle und das
Echte so wirklich so eins zu eins verschmelzen miteinander.
Genau und noch eine App, die noch sehr viel mehr Potenzial haben könnte,
aber das ist ja eigentlich genau das, was ich gesucht habe, die heißt Fly,
und das ist das, was ich immer schon haben wollte, nämlich Google Earth in der Vision Pro,
und leider ist es.
Wirklich ein bisschen scheiße umgesetzt also die Navigation ist blöd.
Also was macht es? Es lädt die Google Earth 3D-Daten tatsächlich in die Kamera
und man kann sich das dreidimensional anschauen.
Das heißt, du kannst jetzt wirklich Berlin,
dreidimensional erfahren und du schaust halt um dich herum und fliegst über
der Stadt und kannst die ganze Stadt irgendwie auf einmal dreidimensional unmittelbar
mit dieser Brille wahrnehmen.
Und das ist, boah, das ist wirklich was für die Birne.
Leider ist die Flugsteuerung so scheiße gemacht, dass man nach dem Controller schreit.
Und was sie auch noch…,
nicht gut gemacht haben, ist, dass sie immer in der Nord-Süd,
also in der gleichen Ausrichtung bleiben.
Also du kannst nicht wirklich wie ein Flugzeug fliegen und jetzt drehe ich mal
um, während ich auf dem Sofa sitze und fliege irgendwo hin, sondern du musst
dich immer umdrehen, um in die andere Richtung zu gucken und guckst sozusagen
auch immer in die gleiche Richtung, während du fliegst.
Das ist völlig beknackt.
Aber das, ich habe es auch ausprobiert, ich hatte ja nur drei Tage Das war eine
der Sachen, wo ich dachte, dass wir Tim interessieren.
Exakt die App. Und meine Güte, was sind das für Leute, die sowas designen?
Alles, was schwierig ist, haben sie gelöst in dieser App. Aber das,
worauf es dann ankommt, wie fühlst du dich in der Bewegung?
Wo eigentlich auch gut durcherzählt ist, wie du sowas baust.
Und dann machen sie da totalen Quatsch. Du hast es ja schon beschrieben.
Auf der Couch ist das nicht benutzbar.
Was ist das für ein Scheiß? Sondern der Gedanke ist, du musst mitten in einem
Raum stehen und drehst dich ständig 360 Grad um die eigene Achse,
um irgendwie dahin zu fliegen, wo du eigentlich hinfliegen willst.
Was ist das für ein Bullshit?
Vor allem, was ich mir fast gewünscht habe ist, da hasse ich mich ja fast für
diesen Kommentar, aber im Prinzip, was es jetzt gebräucht hätte,
wäre so ein Datenhandschuh, wo man...
Er hat Datenhandschuh gesagt.
Ich überlege mir die ganze Zeit, was wäre eigentlich der richtige Controller?
Und ich finde, es wäre schon cool, wenn man so eine Art Klicker hätte,
den man so in der Hand, den man so an die Hand ran macht. Also es muss nicht
wirklich ein Handschuh sein.
Es geht auch nicht darum, die Fingerbewegung zu steuern. Das kann man ruhig
weiterhin optisch machen. Es ist mir nicht so wichtig, ich will nicht meine Finger sehen.
Aber etwas, was man nicht loslassen kann, was immer so an der Hand dran ist, was man so rüberzieht.
Und wo man auch die Möglichkeit hat, einen Klick auszuwählen,
was man ja sonst mit den Fingern macht, indem man die Finger zusammenschnipst.
Nur das Problem ist,
Im Dunkeln funktioniert das halt irgendwann nicht mehr gut. Also ich finde es
bemerkenswert, wie gut es noch im Dunkeln funktioniert, aber es funktioniert
halt im ganz Dunkeln irgendwann gar nicht mehr. Und die Vision Pro beschwert sich ja auch so.
Ja, wie zu dunkel, ich sehe ja gar nichts. Ja, du dumme Nuss.
Was willst du auch sehen? Das Einzige, was ich machen muss, ist ein Klick und
ein Drag. Irgendwie kannst du das nicht irgendwie auch anders machen?
Ja, ordentliche Controller wären wirklich schön.
Also irgendwas muss ich da noch tun. Jetzt haben sie ja angekündigt,
diese Sony VR-Controller zu unterstützen.
Mal schauen, ob das irgendwas bringt.
Aber ich denke, da wird auch nichts passieren.
Die Webseite von der Bude, die dieses Fly macht, ist ein Besuch wert.
Die machen für andere Brillen so eine Art Sportprogramm, wo man dann,
es sieht aus wie so eine Dreiradplattform, auf der man dann rumhampelt,
während man durch die Gegend fährt.
Das ist wirklich sehr, sehr witzig, das VZ-Fit.
Aber das erklärt, glaube ich, ein bisschen die DNA dieses Problems.
Ich glaube, die sind darauf spezialisiert, dass du halt auf Hometrainern ein
interessantes VR-Environment dir dazu baust, damit du über einen echten See
ruderst und auch durch interessante Fahrradstrecken fährst.
Da bewegst du dich halt immer auf Schienen quasi, ja, auf seinem Home-Trainer.
Das heißt, dieser Freiheitsgrad, ich will mich jetzt mal umdrehen und in eine
andere Richtung radeln, den kennen die einfach nicht als Firma.
Ja, das ist bei denen nicht in der DNA drin und so kommt dann halt solche Software dabei raus.
Manchmal ist die einfachste Erklärung die richtige.
Ja.
Aber dieses Video ist absurd auf deren Webseite. Das ist, ja.
So Ralfa, du hast jetzt auch noch irgendwas für VR-Herz jetzt.
Genau, nur ganz kurzer Nachklapp zu dem, was du eben sagtest mit diesem Strap,
den man statt des Normalen nimmt und der den Druck anders verlagert auf Stirn
und Nacken und vor allen Dingen der,
diesen Sichtschutz drumherum wegnimmt, dass man also ein freieres Gefühl hat
für den Raum, in dem man da eigentlich ist.
Da hat jemand völlig zu Recht in den Kommentaren geschrieben zu unserer letzten
Sendung, oh, das gibt's aber auch für die Quest.
Habt ihr das mal ausprobiert? Da dachte ich so, ja, wieso habe ich das eigentlich
noch nicht ausprobiert? So, und es gibt es.
Und ich habe es mir gekauft. Das kostet irgendwie 24 Euro oder sowas.
Auch echt nicht viel Geld.
Und funktioniert ziemlich genau so, wie das, was wir jetzt hier bei der.
Vision Pro besprochen haben. Ich werfe hier mal ein Bild rein.
So, und da sieht man eben, dass auch hier bei der Quest dann dieser schwarze
Sichtschutz um das eigentliche Brillenteil weg ist.
Und der Effekt ist nicht ganz so dramatisch, finde ich, wie bei der Vision Pro.
Was aber auch daran liegt, dass die Quest ohnehin ein bisschen größeren Radius schon hat.
Aber es ist immer noch viel besser als mit diesem Sichtschutz drumrum.
Weil man zum einen halt nicht den Druck auf dem Gesicht vorne drauf hat und
zum anderen wirklich eher von der Psychologie her denkt, okay,
ich habe jetzt eine Brille auf und nicht, ich habe eine Taucherbrille auf.
Das ist einfach nach wie vor ein Unterschied.
Ich habe die, seitdem benutze ich die jetzt nur noch so. Das ist nochmal gut
investiertes Geld, wer das ausprobieren will. Das ist cool.
Ich habe da auch noch so ein ähnliches, also das sieht so ähnlich aus wie das, was ich habe.
Es gab auch noch so ein anderes Tool, das heißt Globular Cluster,
warum auch immer. Furchtbarer Name.
Das tut sowas ähnliches.
Meins heißt K-K-C-O-B-V-A.
Perfekt.
Keine Ahnung, was mit diesem...
Da hat der Amazon-Naming-Bot sich aber sehr ausgespielt.
Genau, das gibt es übrigens nicht auf Amazon, zumindest derzeit nicht,
sondern das habe ich in der Tat über AliExpress bestellt.
Ich glaube, das erste Mal in meinem Leben. Das ist ja auch eine sonderbare Shopping-Experience.
There you go. Ja, AliExpress ist nur für hartgesotten.
Ja,
genau, ja, Globola Cluster habe ich jetzt irgendwie mir nochmal in meinen Kugelsternhaufen.
Ist der deutsche Ausdruck dafür.
Für Globola Cluster? Ja, ich meine, warum nennt man so ein Strap für eine VR-Brille so?
Das bin ich die falsche Ansprechperson für, aber ja, ne?
Ja, ich wahrscheinlich auch. Aber ich suche es mal hier nochmal raus.
Globola Cluster. CMA 1 Komfort.
Es ist ein wilder markt mal gucken gut dann haben wir noch ein bisschen kleinkram,
ja habt mich ja sicherlich schon ein paar mal von der software receipts schwärmen
hören die so ein bisschen Teil meiner Buchführungs- und Finanzorganisation ist. Ihr erinnert euch?
Aber ja.
Genau. Und der Dirk, der war ja auch mal irgendwann mal in der Freakshow zu Gast, langes her.
Auf jeden Fall habe ich ihn jetzt jahrelang angebettelt, er soll doch mal eine
neue Version davon rausbringen. Das hat er jetzt gemacht.
Ich bin so glücklich. Und das wollte ich dir kurz verkünden,
Wer das benutzt, der mag ein Auge werfen.
Neue Version heißt nicht einfach Receipts 2.0, obwohl sie rein technisch Receipts
2.0 ist, sondern sie heißt, ich kann es nicht ganz nachvollziehen,
aber sie heißt Receipts Space, also der totale Zungenbrecher.
Receipts Space.
Okay.
Space. Ihr wollt Space, ich gebe euch Space.
Ja, genau. Für mehr Space. Im Kern macht die Software genau das,
was er auch vorher gemacht hat.
Das heißt man schmeißt da irgendwie seine PDFs rein und alles ist gut.
Und das Gute, sagen wir mal, das Primärgute daran ist, es handelt sich so ein
bisschen um so eine Modernisierung der Software.
Also die kam einfach, wie das immer so ist mit so Macintosh Codebases,
wenn die Software immer ein paar Jahre alt ist.
Man muss bei Apple die ganze Zeit immer wieder alles irgendwie neu schreiben
und neu machen, um da irgendwie noch mitzuhalten. und das eine Weile wohl nicht
erfolgt und das ist aber jetzt erfolgt.
Das heißt, jetzt besteht auch die Hoffnung, dass wir noch sehr viel schnellere
weitere, also meine Hoffnung besteht zumindest, dass es noch weitere Ergänzungen gibt.
Aber es gibt so zwei, drei Dinge, die in der neuen Version schon gut sind.
Nämlich erstens ist sie jetzt auch nachweislich synkfähig.
Das heißt, man kann seine Datenbank irgendwie über iCloud, über Dropbox,
über alle möglichen Syncing-Systeme sharen und die Software weiß sozusagen,
ist also Sync-Aware und legt sich nicht da die Karten.
Das heißt, man kann schön mit mehreren Macs dann gleichzeitig drauf zugreifen.
Das ist schon mal ein Feature.
Das ist auch, glaube ich, ein etwas moderneres OCR jetzt aus dem Betriebssystem.
Kann zum Einsatz, also das könnte dann auch noch besser funktionieren.
Und natürlich hat sie E-Rechnung-Support. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt so ein PDF
hat, wo eine elektronische Rechnung drin ist oder so eine reine XML-Version
von der Rechnung, dann kann sie das auch noch lesen. Das ist natürlich auch super.
Und, aber das ist für mich so das Allerwichtigste, Receipts,
wie der Name schon sagt, war ja eigentlich bisher immer nur für Belege gedacht.
Also mit anderen Worten Zettel, wo Beträge draufstehen, die man zahlt oder gezahlt
bekommen hat und so. Und dafür war es ja schon immer super.
Nur es gibt einfach so oft so PDFs, die in irgendeiner Form mit diesem ganzen
Zahlungsverkehr noch zu tun haben.
Korrespondenz, irgendwelche Bestätigungen, Sachen, die jetzt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne Belege sind.
Beitragserhöhungsmitteilungen von der Krankenkasse oder sowas.
Also so irgendwelche vertraglichen Änderungen, Kontoauszüge,
Sachen, die du da einfach mit drin haben willst, aber die nicht im eigentlichen Sinne Beleg sind.
Aber jetzt hat die Software ja vorher immer gesagt, ich gucke jetzt mal,
was hier der Betrag ist und dann gab es dann keinen Betrag und damit du das
irgendwie wegkriegst, muss es dann irgendwie irgendeinen erfinden und das dann
als bezahlt markieren, obwohl es sozusagen so nicht ist.
Wie auch immer, jetzt gibt es die Möglichkeit zu sagen, das hier ist gar kein
Beleg, das ist gar kein Receipt, sondern es ist einfach nur ein Dokument.
Meine große Hoffnung ist, dass wir in den nächsten Versionen dann auch genauer
sagen können, was für ein Dokument es ist, dass man sozusagen solche Beitragserhöhungen,
Verträge, Kontoauszüge, all diese ganzen Dokumentenarten auch nochmal unterscheiden kann.
Aber das Wichtigste ist, man kann überhaupt erstmal unterscheiden mit,
das ist jetzt hier kein Beleg, da muss ich nicht sagen, wann der bezahlt wurde und so weiter.
Receipts Space 2.0. Kommt jetzt auch als Abo daher und nicht mehr als Einzelkauf.
Das heißt, wenn es genug Leute kaufen, dann geht auch die Entwicklung dann hoffentlich bald weiter.
Zwangsweise oder kann man es sich aussuchen, dass man es auch noch kaufen kann?
Wenn ich das sehe, ist die neue Version nur auf Abo.
Ich mag das ja nach wie vor ganz gerne einmalig irgendwo Geld abwerfen,
aber ich sehe die ganzen Vorteile, die es für Devs bringt, ist, im Abo zu halten.
Genau. Und dann hatte ich hier noch so den Vorfall, kaum war ich irgendwie weggefahren,
wollte irgendwie das Finanzamt von mir noch irgendwie was haben bezüglich meiner Lastschriften.
Und das war auch wieder so richtig so ein geiler deutscher Moment.
Die sagen ja immer so, ja mach doch eine Lastschrift, wir buchen dann irgendwie
alles ab und wir erstatten dann auch, wenn was zu erstatten gibt und dann geht
das alles automatisch und ich so, super, echt toll.
Aber jetzt gibt es ja so verschiedenste Steuern, die man da bezahlt.
Und dann kann man nämlich tatsächlich aber auch sagen, liebes Finanzamt,
diese Lastschrift macht ihr bitte nur diese Steuerart.
Und bei dieser Lastschrift macht er nur diese Steuerart. Also du kannst genau
sagen, ob du da Umsatzsteuer, was es alles noch gibt, Umsatzsteuer, Einkommenssteuer,
Gewerbesteuer und so weiter, kannst du dann irgendwie alles ankreuzen und kannst
auch noch für die jeweilige Steuer sagen, nur die Steuer oder auch Erstattung.
Da dachte ich mir, super, ganz toll. Und habe dann irgendwie so drei Lastschriftvereinbarungen
dahingeschickt, noch mit Formular, Ausdrücken, Unterschreiben, irgendwie Post.
Und bin Urlaub gefahren. Und dann kam dann irgendwie so Post,
so ja, rufen Sie uns mal an, irgendwie müssen wir was klären.
Ich dachte, rufen und so, ja, was ist denn?
Ja, ich hätte ja drei Lastschriften irgendwie vereinbart. Es gehen aber nur zwei.
Was? Ja, es geht nur zwei. Sie könnte nur zwei eintragen, nicht drei.
Weil wahrscheinlich die Fernseher-Software ein Feld hat für Lastschrift 1 und Lastschrift 2.
Es ist schon immer in der Buchführung, Kostenstelle 1 und Kostenstelle 2 gab,
aber nicht irgendwie Kostenstelle 3 oder 5 oder irgendwie sowas. Ne, es gab nur zwei.
Und dann muss ich aber nochmal diesen Vorgang, weil dann sozusagen der gesamte
Vorgang war dann nicht zu bearbeiten und dann sollte ich es halt nochmal machen.
Ja, aber ich müsste das Lastschriftding auch wirklich ausdrucken und unterschreiben
und wieder einscannen und das dürfte ich dann gerne per Elster schicken.
Leute, was hatten wir am Anfang gesagt über Deutschland?
Es ist einfach es ist einfach vorbei mit diesem Land.
Es ist einfach ganz einfach Deutschland das ist einfach durch.
Ich verliere einfach jeden Optimismus. Es ist unrettbar verloren.
Dieser Gedanke, dass man um zu sagen von welchem Konto etwas abgebucht werden
soll, dass ich dafür ein PDF-Formular runterladen soll,
das dann auch ausfüllen kann an meinem Computer, dann aber nicht elektronisch
meine Unterschrift da draufziehen kann.
Überhaupt das noch unterschreiben muss, ich das dann ausdrucken soll,
um es dann wieder einzuscannen, damit die Unterschrift auch echt ist,
um es dann über einen Elster-Zugang zu machen,
wo ich ein Zertifikat hochlade und mich damit anmelde, digital signiertes Dokument
und ich logge mich da irgendwie ein, alles total super sicher.
Der Zugang, mit dem ich meine Steuern abgebe.
Aber ich bin nicht in der Lage, oder die sind nicht in der Lage,
in diesen scheiß Elster einfach irgendwo so eine Webseite reinzubauen mit hier
lass Schrift eingeben. Lass Schrift 1, Lass Schrift 2.
Geht nicht. Nein. Man muss einen PDF runterladen, muss es ausfüllen, muss es ausdrucken.
Und sie hat mir extra nochmal gesagt, ja, nee, das ist aber ganz wichtig,
dass das dann auch wirklich nochmal eingescannt wird und nicht einfach nur so
die Unterschrift draufgezogen wird.
Jetzt war ich aber unterwegs und es gab einfach keinerlei Druckeroption.
Und ich dachte auch so, was soll der Scheiß?
Und dann, das habt ihr wahrscheinlich gesehen, ich habe das irgendwie auch erfragt.
Ich dachte mir, es gibt doch bestimmt so eine Webseite, wo man einfach PDF hochladen
kann und danach sieht es so aus, als wäre es ausgedruckt und wieder eingescapt worden.
Gibt es auch, ganz viele. und ich empfehle euch einfach nur das,
was am besten ist, weil es war nämlich technisch auch sehr schön gelöst.
Und zwar heißt es lookscanned.
Lookscanned.io Ist das? I.O. Genau. Und nicht nur, dass diese Webseite genau
das Richtige tut, also du lädst sozusagen dein PDF hoch und dann ist es so leicht
verschoben und ein bisschen unscharf und ein bisschen,
füsselig aus und du kannst das auch alle alle Parameter noch einstellen.
Das Geile ist, du lädst gar nichts hoch, sondern du lädst es wirklich nur lokal
in den Browser, weil die ganze App ist einfach als Web-Assembly direkt im Browser. Sehr hübsch gemacht.
Also damit könnt ihr eure Finanzamts SEPA Lastschriftenbeteilung,
die eine und die andere, keine dritte, könnt ihr dann damit irgendwie glaubhaft hochladen.
Ach ja.
Das ist doch Irrsinn.
Es ist einfach, es ist einfach, was? Deutschland ist einfach vorbei. It's over.
Es ist einfach, es findet nicht mehr.
Ja, es ist ja nicht alles schlecht.
Es ist doch. Es ist wirklich alles schlecht. Ich verfolge ja den Wahlkampf wirklich
aus 10.000 Kilometern in Entfernung, aber es ist wirklich nur Browser auf, Kotzt, Browser zu.
Und ich bin froh, dass ich in dem ganzen Drama nicht weiter teilnehmen muss. Es ist furchtbar.
Das wird schlimm. Ja, dann ist ja irgendwie China passiert auf einmal.
Keiner hatte das so richtig auf der Bingo-Karte, aber es gab ein Unternehmen,
das hier heißt DeepSeek und manche kannten das auch schon,
aber die meisten nicht und DeepSeek hat ein Paper veröffentlicht über ein neues AI-Model,
was DeepSeek R1 heißt und DeepSeek R1 ist ein sogenanntes Reasoning Model, also das,
was OpenAI vor kurzem vorgestellt hat mit diesem U1-Model.
Korrigiert mich, wenn ich irgendwie unsere Begriffe durcheinander bringe.
Diese ganzen Buchstabenabkürzungen in dieser AI-Welt, das ist ja irgendwie auch
nochmal so ein Thema für sich.
Und was ist ein Reasoning Model, also ein Reasoning Model also wir kennen jetzt
alle diese Large Language Models, das sind also diese Maschinen,
mit denen man so schön reden kann, also Chat, GPT, 3, 4, etc.
Die einfach mal das ganze Internet durchgetankt haben, ihre Modelle trainiert
haben mit riesigem Aufwand über längeren Zeitraum, mit sehr viel Datentraffic,
sehr viel Speicherplatz, mit sehr viel.
Trainingsressourcen und das sind die Large Language Models und diese sogenannten Reasoning Models,
das ist dann quasi nochmal ein Layer obendrauf, wo die eigentlichen Anfragen
nochmal in so Unteranfragen aufgebrochen werden und dann findet ein Prozess
statt, den man gemeinhin jetzt als Chain of Thought Prozess bezeichnet.
Mit anderen Worten, das Modell macht nicht einfach nur diese Prediction,
wie das so Large Language Models eben machen, indem sie mehr oder weniger die
Antwort aus deinem eigenen Text vorhersagen, also einfach weitererzählen, sagen wir es mal so,
sondern Chain of Thought ist, man benutzt dieselbe Technik, um sich überhaupt
selbst erstmal einen Modus zu bauen, wie man etwas beantworten will und das
soll dann eben zu besseren Ergebnissen führen.
Und das führt ja auch zu besseren Ergebnissen, wie Ralf neulich ja sehr schön
mit seiner Analyse bewiesen hat. Richtig?
Genau, also grundsätzlich dieses Reasoning, das haben wir auf der Prompt-Ebene
schon auch bei den ganz frühen Modellen von ChatGPT selber gemacht.
Das heißt also schon bei dem Chat-GPT 3.5 oder bei dem 4 gab es im Internet
viele Prompts zum Copy-Pasten, wo man so ein Chain-of-Thoughts-Reasoning quasi
von Hand schon mal vorneweg gepromptet hat.
Und der Unterschied ist ja, dass die jetzt halt quasi eingebacken sind in die neuen Modelle.
Aber dass das grundsätzlich eine gute Idee ist, eine LLM da ein bisschen an
die Hand zu nehmen und zu sagen, so mach das mal Schritt für Schritt und erzähle
es dir vor allen Dingen auch immer selber, was du gerade glaubst tun zu müssen.
Und nimm diese Erzählung wiederum so in deine weiteren Überlegungen mit rein.
Das ist, wie gesagt, schon relativ lange als eine sinnvolle Strategie verstanden
und jetzt wird es quasi professionell reingebaut.
Genau, das sind also diese Reasoning Models und im Kern kann man sagen,
das sind halt jetzt ein bisschen so genauere oder richtigere Antworten und man hat ja jetzt gesehen,
dass dieses DeepSeq R1 zumindest laut ihrem Paper und nach einigen Überprüfungen
von anderen Leuten auch in Benchmarks vergleichbare oder bessere Ergebnisse
erzielt wie dieses O1-Model von OpenAI.
Und das hat dann für einige Aufregung gesorgt, auch noch aus anderen Gründen,
nämlich vor allem, weil sie ja behauptet haben, das sei alles ja auch noch mit
viel weniger technischem Aufwand gegangen.
Jetzt muss man erst mal gucken, wer ist denn überhaupt diese Bude?
Deep Seek ist ganz interessant, weil das ist so eine Gründung von so einem chinesischen Mathe-Nerd.
Ich weiß nicht, ich habe den Namen gerade nicht notiert, halt so ein chinesischer Name.
Und der Typ ist wohl so ein richtiges Wunderkind im Bereich Mathe,
hat das also wirklich tief studiert und hat dann irgendwie auch so eine.
Sollte auch schon mal von, was war das, von Alibaba angeworben werden oder so,
wollte er dann aber nicht und hat irgendwie selber eine Firma gegründet und
die dann irgendwie Algorithmen verkauft
haben, also die sozusagen so als Mathe-Dienstleister gearbeitet haben.
Und damit haben sie sich dann relativ schnell in dieses Finanzgeschäft irgendwie
reingespielt und sind so im Trading ganz groß geworden, weil sie halt einfach
krasse mathematische Analysen gemacht haben.
Das ist auch alles noch ohne AI, um einfach so Aktiennachfrage vorherzusagen
und das ist natürlich bares Geld.
Die waren dann auch in diesem ganzen Krypto-Mining irgendwie mit drin und haben
sich ohnehin mit den ganzen Einnahmen schon so eigene Rechnerparks und GPU-Schränke
irgendwie zusammengebaut, um das irgendwie alles gut laufen lassen zu können.
Und da man mit der Technik halt auch ganz gut diese Large Language Models machen
kann, haben sie eben auch noch in dem Bereich angefangen rumzuforschen.
Und das war aber eigentlich eher so ein bisschen so ein Nebenprojekt.
Aber dann so 23 ging das dann los,
dass sie da sehr viele Fortschritte erzielt haben mit ihrem DeepSeek-Modell
und dann einfach da dran geblieben sind.
Dann kam eine Version 2 raus, auch noch 23,
wo sie schon so die ersten modernen Ansätze auch gemacht haben,
die so für eine gewisse Aufmerksamkeit in der Szene gesorgt haben.
Unter anderem diese Methode der Mixture of Experts, was quasi bedeutet,
dass du nicht dein ganzes Modell als ein einziges Expertensystem siehst,
sondern dass du das in so logische Agentenfunktionen unterteilst.
Also sozusagen du hast so einen Teil deines Modells, was sich um diese Art Anfragen
und ein Modell, was sich um diese Art Anfragen kümmert und dadurch musst du
immer nur einen Teil aktivieren und das nennt sich halt MOE, Mixture of Experts.
Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie das im Detail funktioniert, aber das ist definitiv
so ein Optimierungsschritt, den sie vorgenommen haben.
Ein anderer, der oft zitiert wird.
Auch da sagen muss, also das Konzept haben sie jetzt auch nicht erfunden,
sondern seit spätestens ChatGPT4
hatte das OpenAI auch schon am Start mit diesen Experts-Subsystemen.
Die machen es jetzt scheinbar halt nur einfach effizienter und vor allem transparent,
weil bei OpenAI kann man immer nur mutmaßen und hier ist halt alles offen zum Nachvollziehen.
Genauso hier steht auch GPT4 besteht gerüchteweise aus 16 Subsystemen.
Ja, ist richtig. Also das ist aber glaube ich so nie bestätigt worden,
sondern hieß es, da auch so 16 Experten hatten in ihrem neueren Modell.
Aber ich weiß jetzt auch nicht ganz genau, wer da jetzt irgendwie zuerst war oder nicht.
Auf jeden Fall haben sie verschiedenste Optimierungen vorgenommen,
die sowohl das Training als auch die Inferenz, also quasi die Nutzung des Modells
schneller gemacht haben.
Eine andere Optimierung, die sie damit eingebracht haben, wird hier als MLA
bezeichnet, Multi-Head Latent Attention, was kurz gesagt einfach eine dramatische
Reduzierung des Speicherbedarfs bedeutet.
Also haben verschiedene Techniken dort eingesetzt.
Dann im Dezember letzten Jahres, dann wurde es dann aber irgendwie sportlich,
weil dann haben sie halt ihre V3 veröffentlicht, das LLM.
Die Psyk V3 ist also quasi sowas wie ChatGPT4, ein normales Large Language Model,
was quasi als Basis ist und was halt auch, sagen wir mal, eben noch mit klassischen
Trainingsdaten aus dem Internet und so weiter befüllt wurde.
Da haben sie dann weitere Optimierungen gemacht und in ihrem letzten Paper haben sie dann gesagt,
in einem Blogpost, wo die Zahl jetzt drin stand, dass sie für das Training dieses
Models nur 5,5 Millionen US-Dollar haben einsetzen müssen, um das irgendwie durchzuziehen.
Also sie haben sozusagen nicht so hohe Kosten gehabt in Zeit und Gerät.
Und das ist schon mal eine Zahl, die die eine oder andere Augenbraue gelupft
hat, weil mit 5,5 Millionen Dollar hat bisher noch keiner irgendwie ein LLM durchtrainiert.
Es ist zwei Größenordnungen unter dem, was man normalerweise ansetzt.
Eher so 500 Millionen oder mehr. Und vor allem.
Gut, man muss dazu sagen, das sind sicherlich nicht alle Kosten gewesen,
das waren die Kosten für den Trainingsvorgang, du musst den ganzen Scheiß ja
auch noch entwickeln und so weiter, aber so oder so auf einmal completely different Ballpark.
So, das alleine hätte wahrscheinlich jetzt schon, wäre es schon eine Meldung
wert gewesen, aber der eigentliche Schocker war dann eben ihr DeepSeq R1 und
das kommt in zwei Varianten.
Sie haben dann erstmal einen DeepSeq R1 Zero gemacht und das Zero steht dafür,
dass sie quasi jetzt dieses normale V3-LLM-Modell genommen haben und dann durch
eine Methode, die sich Reinforcement Learning verbessert haben.
Das heißt, sie haben jetzt quasi das Modell genommen und Reinforcement Learning,
das kennt man so aus dem Roboterbereich, wenn die Roboter laufen lernen.
Ihr kennt das alle noch, hier so Big Dog und Co,
die allerersten Roboter, die da so rumstraucheln und dann machen sie 30.000
Mal was und man trainiert ja auch irgendwelche anderen AI-Modelle ähnlich,
insbesondere so Fahrsimulationen, wo dann so 30 Millionen Mal fährst du jetzt
diesen Parcours, irgendwie durch und dann lernst du einfach aus deinen Fehlern.
Also Reinforcement Learning einfach auf Basis deiner eigenen Daten verbesserst du dich selbst.
Und solche Strategien wurden auch bei LLMs schon gemacht, aber mit einem sogenannten
Supervised Fine Tuning.
Also man hatte sozusagen Menschen, die diesen Prozess dann eben gefeintuned haben.
Und das Besondere an diesem.
R1 Zero ist, dass sie das eben nicht gemacht haben, sondern das Ding quasi nur
mit sich selbst gelernt hat.
Und ja, mit anderen Worten, das Modell trainiert sich selbst,
und hatte schon ganz interessante Verbesserungen, aber hat am Ende wohl noch
diverse Schwächen gehabt, sagte also Diebseek dann in dem Paper auch selber.
Und es kam mit Sprache auf einmal nicht so klar, als ob er seine Sprache ein
bisschen vermischt und ließ sich nicht so gut lesen.
Also man hat schon gemerkt, da funktioniert das irgendwie was,
aber der Schritt hat da noch nicht ausgereicht.
Und dann sind sie halt diesen zweiten Schritt gegangen, der zu dem DeepSeq R1
Modell geführt hat, wo sie im Prinzip genau das gleiche getan haben.
Nur, dass sie, jetzt wird es ein bisschen ominös, denselben Vorgang gemacht
haben mit dem Reinforcement Learning, nur haben sie quasi so einen Kaltstart-Daten mit reingeworfen.
Das nennen sie dann High-Quality Chain-of-Thought-Data. Also
sie haben so eine Art Starter-Pack mitgegeben mit so einem Basis-Reasoning und
dann erst ihre mehrstufige Training-Pipeline darauf angeworfen und das hat dann
wohl eine deutlich bessere Qualität erzeugt eben,
die Qualität, die besagt, dass sie dann eben auf diesem O1-Level auf einmal angekommen sind.
Also damit haben sie sich verglichen und wenig überraschend ist es zum Beispiel
in manchen Bereichen wie Mathe sogar nochmal deutlich besser.
So was ist jetzt so bemerkenswert daran? Also erstmal mit relativ wenig Geld,
zwei Größenordnungen weniger Geld und sehr wenig Zeit haben sie es geschafft
auch so ein Reasoning-Modell rauszubringen, wo also OpenAI gerade Billionen
verbrät oder Milliarden verbrät.
Und vor allem ist das Ganze halt auch noch unter einer MIT-Lizenz veröffentlicht worden.
Also es hieß dann schnell ja Open Source.
Das stimmt nicht so ganz, weil das Modell ist, man sagt dann Open Waits,
also sie haben sozusagen das fertige Modell komplett veröffentlicht,
aber sie haben halt nicht die Trainingsdaten selbst noch mit veröffentlicht,
deswegen ist es in dem Sinne nicht nachvollziehbar Open Source,
aber es ist natürlich frei nutzbar und man kann sich das runterladen und man
kann das irgendwie auf Computern zum Laufen bringen und das haben viele Leute auch schon gemacht.
Und was halt die Leute auch noch verrückt gemacht hat, ist, dass sie das in
China gemacht haben und dass es ja seit einiger Zeit dieses Technologie-Embargo der USA gab,
die Nvidia verboten haben, eine bestimmte Kategorie von AI-fähigen Chips dort zu verkaufen.
Der Goldstandard ist ja derzeit diese H100-Geschichte.
Das heißt, China bekam nicht die H100-Chips, sondern nur diese H800-Chips.
Das sind quasi so die beschnittene Variante davon. Und die waren vor allem beschnitten
in der CPU-Kommunikation.
Das ist sozusagen so eine Einschränkung. Dadurch wollten sie also den Chinesen
das Berechnen von krassen KI-Modellen irgendwie verhindern.
Aber die Nerds von DeepSeq, die haben offensichtlich diesen H800-Chip einfach
eben nicht, wie man es normalerweise macht, mit dieser CUDA-Programmiersprache
benutzt, sondern haben das Ding auf einer niedrigeren Ebene,
quasi in Assembler, sage ich jetzt mal so salopp,
programmiert und haben vor allem viel Bedarf für diese Inter-GPU-Kommunikation
einfach aus ihrem Trainingssystem rausgenommen.
Das heißt, die haben diesen ganzen Prozess umgebaut und deswegen konnten sie
auch mit diesen relativ eingeschränkten Chips trotzdem noch bemerkenswerte Ergebnisse erzielen.
Und das ist halt das Modell, was jetzt irgendwie rumliegt.
Das ist halt jetzt genau das Ding. Also sie haben ein Modell rausgebracht,
was irgendwie für einen Prozent der Kosten erzeugt wurde,
was zumindest in den Benchmarks und ihrem eigenen Paper als vergleichbar mit
O1 von OpenAI verglichen wurde.
Und da haben dann irgendwie auf einmal alle kalte Füße bekommen,
weil sie natürlich gesehen haben, dass man jetzt durch Software-Ingenieurstum in der Lage ist,
alles sehr viel billiger zu machen und auch mit sehr viel weniger Aufwand diese
Modelle laufen lassen zu können.
Also nicht nur, dass es billiger ist, sondern es ist jetzt auch vielen gelungen,
dieses R1-Modell, was immerhin 677 Milliarden Tokens hat.
Schon so auf Macintosh-Hardware laufen zu lassen.
Jetzt nicht mega schnell, aber ging
schon so oder zumindest auf so kleinen PC-Racks mit ein paar GPUs drin.
Also jetzt nicht ein Rechenzentrum, sondern noch relativ teure,
aber eher schon so im Personalkomputerbereich befindliche Systeme,
die Modelle überhaupt zum Laufen bekommen.
Mit irgendwie 192 Gigabyte RAM ist man irgendwie dabei.
Also wenn du dir so ein Mac Studio jetzt im Vollausbau kaufst oder so mit 192
Gigabyte RAM mit so einem Ultra, dann würdest du das Ding schon zum Laufen bekommen
und das ist schon ziemlich krass.
Deswegen haben jetzt alle irgendwie Schiss und schauen sich halt irgendwie diebsig an.
Ich habe es auch ein bisschen rumgetestet und muss sagen, mein Test hat es nicht bestanden.
Wie sieht es mit deinen Tests aus, Ralf?
Vielleicht noch ein paar strategische Einordnungen. Ich würde das vergleichen,
was wir jetzt gerade haben,
mit dem Stable Diffusion Schock, was die Bildgenerierung angeht.
Wir erinnern uns, wir drehen mal irgendwie so zwei Jahre oder sowas zurück.
Damals gab es Doll E im Bereich Bildgenerierung und es gab vor allen Dingen,
wie hieß das, wovon jetzt schon keiner mehr redet?
Die, die das als erste so richtig groß und prominent KI-Bildgenerierung rausgehauen haben.
Midjourney.
Genau, danke, super. Die beiden Modelle gab es im Wesentlichen.
Und Midjourney war halt super auf Hochglanz poliert, im Sinne von,
die hatten da wirklich gute Modelle und gutes Prompting dahinter,
dass man eigentlich immer irgendwie cooles Zeug rausbekommen hat und alle waren begeistert.
So, und dann kam Stable Diffusion raus und hatte plötzlich Open Waits und das
Ganze war plötzlich zum selber irgendwie runterladen und erweitern.
Und das Internet ist explodiert mit Optimierung seitdem.
Wir hatten das zigmal hier in der Sendung. Wir erinnern uns,
wo ich irgendwie mit einem 20-Sekunden-Video von mir dann brauchbare Porträtbilder
mit eigenen generierten Loras gemacht habe und ähnliches.
Und exakt den Effekt erwarte ich jetzt hier auf dem R1-Modell.
Das heißt also, was auch immer das derzeit für Einschränkungen haben mag,
jeder, wirklich absolut jeder, der irgendwas was im Bereich KI gerade bastelt,
wirft sich jetzt da drauf, weil das das ist, was es vorher nicht gab.
Eben ein offenes Modell, was deutlich performanter ist als die bisher offenen,
in Anführungszeichen, Open-Source-Modelle.
Das heißt, wir werden jetzt in den nächsten Wochen schon, werden wir in noch
totale Evolutionssprünge gehen, worauf das plötzlich noch alles mit LORAS und
ähnlichen Verfahren weiterhin optimiert und zugeschnitten wird.
Also das, keiner macht heute noch Bildgenerierung mit Midjourney,
sondern wenn du irgendwie in dem Bereich professionell was machst,
trainierst du dir deine eigenen Loras,
suchst dir die entsprechenden Base Models, die das Ganze unterstützen und hast
eine Qualität mit Einflussmöglichkeiten, wie du es mit Midjourney in 500 Jahren
nicht schaffst und genau so wird es jetzt im Bereich der LLMs laufen hier ähm,
Der zweite Punkt, der halt wirklich beeindruckend ist, ist dieses,
ich kann es plötzlich lokal laufen lassen.
Was das für Nutzungsmöglichkeiten ergibt im Sinne von, so die Daten verlassen
nicht mehr meinen Rechner, die ich miteinander nehme.
Kleineres Modell.
Kleinere Modelle, ja. Kommen wir auch gleich dazu, wie die unterschiedlich performen.
Tim hat ja auch was ausprobiert, ich habe was ausprobiert. Es war aber bis vorher
völlig undenkbar, dass du überhaupt ein Modell mit den Möglichkeiten laufen lassen kannst.
Also ich habe bei mir, du hast gerade gesagt 192 GB RAM MacBook,
ich habe jetzt hier so das 14 Zoll MacBook Pro mit einer M2 pro CPU,
16 GB RAM und da ist also bei dem 14 B Modell Schluss von R1.
Aber das läuft total geschmeidig. Das heißt also das nächstgrößere läuft nicht mehr.
Also 14B steht für 40 Billion, 14 Milliarden Token. Das ist die Größe des Modells.
Genau, das läuft hier gut. Das zieht dann so ein Drittel, würde ich sagen,
der verfügbaren GPU. Wenn ich versuche, das nächstgrößere reinzuleiten,
das ist glaube ich das 32B-Modell.
Da stürzt da also schlicht ab bis hin zu, der Rechner friert ein,
habe ich auch nicht gesehen.
Du gehst jetzt von dem Distill-Modell.
Das ist das Distilling-Modell, genau.
Genau, das wollte ich eigentlich gerade noch erläutern. Das muss man in dem
Zusammenhang noch verstehen.
Also was ich eben gerade ursprünglich zitiert habe, das R1-Modell,
was released wurde mit diesen 677 Milliarden Tokens.
Das ist sozusagen das richtige R1.
Und da ist es halt manchen gelungen, auf dick gefett gepimpten Maschinen das
zum Laufen zu bekommen, wenn sie sehr viel rammen. haben.
Es läuft nicht schnell, das spuckt dann so zwei, drei Worte pro Sekunde aus.
Aber es geht. Das ist sozusagen der Punkt.
Auch noch gemacht haben. Das ist jetzt in dem Sinne keine neue Methode,
die es noch nicht gab oder so.
Man nennt das Distilling. Mir persönlich muss ich sagen, war das neu in dem Moment.
Aber was es meint ist, man nimmt ein existierendes LLM, genauso wie DeepSeek
das mit ihrem eigenen LLM gemacht hat.
Also die haben ja ihr V3-LLM genommen und daraus diese Reasoning-Maschine gemacht.
Jetzt nehmen sie sich andere populäre Modelle, wie zum Beispiel Lama von Meta
oder Quen von Alibaba, die es ja auch gibt,
Die eh schon kleinere Modelle sind, die so ein bisschen spezialisiert sind auf
Coding und auf dieses und jenes und so weiter und die mit weniger Aufwand laufen,
aber halt nicht so krass viel können wie die großen Modelle.
Und jetzt haben sie also diese kleinen Modelle genommen, wie zum Beispiel QEN 2.5, Lama 3,
und haben dann mit derselben Methode, mit der sie aus ihrem V3 LLM ja R1 gemacht
haben, also mit diesem Reinforcement Learning, wir trainieren das jetzt mal mit Kaltstartdaten,
auch diese kleineren Modelle, die nicht so viel können.
Weitergezüchtet und haben dann sozusagen diese Modelle verbessert.
Und das ist total irre, weil die erzeugen dann nach wie vor relativ kleine Modelle,
die man wirklich auf dem Rechner laufen lassen kann, die dann aber besser sind
als die Ursprungsmodelle.
Das heißt, wir sind jetzt in eine Phase eingetreten, wo eine AI,
eine andere AI ohne humanen Eingriff verbessert.
Die entwickeln sich jetzt demnächst, glaube ich, alleine weiter.
Also es kann durchaus sein, dass wir da jetzt so in so eine evolutionäre Phase eintreten.
Das wird langsam wirklich ein bisschen crazy.
Aber man kann sich eben verschiedene von diesen Distillmodellen runterladen
von 7 bis 70 Milliarden Token.
Da muss man halt schauen, wie viel RAM man hat. Und zum Beispiel dieses von
R1 gepimpte 14 Milliarden Token Modell von Quen von Alibaba, das haben sie genommen.
Mit ihrem R1-Methode verbessert. Und das ist besser als das jüngst gerade von
Alibaba selbst vorgestellte Reasoning-Modell mit irgendwie 32 Milliarden Token.
Es ist total irre.
Und ich glaube, wir erleben nach wie vor so eine Beschleunigung in der ganzen
technologischen Entwicklung.
Und jetzt sind sie ja auch mit einem Image-Modell rausgekommen,
ihr Janus Pro und wir haben auch natürlich ihre eigene Chat-Version im Netz,
die natürlich dann gleich wieder Aufregung erzeugt hat, weil die natürlich in.
China läuft und dann kannst du natürlich nicht fragen,
was ist Taiwan und was hat,
passiert. Das ist dann so alles so ein bisschen zensiert, aber das Modell selber ist nicht zensiert.
Ja, um die Aufregung vielleicht komplett zu machen,
gab es natürlich dann gleich tausend Verschwörungstheorien und Panik und die
Aktien sind eingebrochen und Nvidia ist irgendwie um 19% gefallen und dann kamen
sie natürlich gleich alle an und haben gesagt, oh ja,
hier, ihr habt bei OpenAI die Daten geklaut und eure Kaltstartdaten,
das war bestimmt jetzt von uns und was fällt euch überhaupt ein,
wenn einer irgendwie das ganze Internet ausrauben darf, dann sind wir das.
So und natürlich tausend geheime Pläne der Chinesen zur Übernahme der Weltregierung
und all dieser ganze Kram, das kam natürlich dann auch und dieser ganze im Medienzirkus
war, schon sehr lustig mit anzuschauen.
Jetzt muss man sich aber natürlich fragen, was ist denn nun drin in der Wurst?
Also ich habe einen,
Tests gemacht. Vielleicht so, was habe ich getestet und was ist da so das jeweilige Framework?
Also ich habe als erstes getestet quasi einfach deren normale Webseite,
dieser Chatbot, den die selber halt anbieten.
Um dann aber ein bisschen mehr Vergleichbarkeit zu haben, bin ich dann relativ
schnell wieder in meine Open Router Umgebung gegangen.
Das ist ein Dienst, den ich ja auch schon ein paar Mal vorgestellt habe,
der wirklich total nützlich ist.
Den schmeiße ich aber auch gerne noch einmal in die Shownotes.
Wir erinnern uns, das ist ein Dienst, wo ich quasi einmal irgendwie 10 Euro
überweise und habe dann Zugriff auf alle gerade überhaupt relevanten Large Language
Modelle und die werden mir dann pro Tokens abgerechnet.
Und das habe ich irgendwie vor drei Monaten gemacht, habe ich wirklich 10 Euro
drauf geworfen und die sind jetzt glaube ich auf 2,50 Euro runter und ich mache damit schon einiges.
Also zum irgendwie mal schnell was durchprobieren und da ist ein neues Modell
und ich will es unabhängig von der Hersteller-Webseite testen,
ist das echt eine gute Umgebung für solche Experimente, Open Router.
Ich kann auch irgendwie dieselben Prompt an zwei Modelle gleichzeitig schicken
und kann mir die Ergebnisse angucken und sowas. Also das ist nach wie vor Daumen hoch Empfehlung.
Die nächste Ebene für meine Tests waren, dass ich es lokal halt installiert
habe, wie gerade eben beschrieben und dafür habe ich so eine Chatsoftware,
Chatbox heißt die, auf macOS genutzt.
Die gibt es auch schon etwas länger das ist glaube ich auch eine One-Man-Show,
und die hat den Vorteil, dass sie sehr einfach in der Installation ist,
das heißt da habe ich wenig Abhängigkeiten und muss nicht irgendwie ein großes
Framework drumherum oder sowas installieren dafür lasse ich auch mal den.
Den Link in die Shownotes rein plumpsen, das habe ich auf Reddit in der Tat
gefunden die Anleitung dafür so, da haben wir den Link,
so und da sind die Schritte sehr gut nachvollziehbar.
Damit hat man es also in 5 Minuten wirklich lokal laufen und es funktioniert.
So und da habe ich jetzt halt verschiedene Tests mitgefahren.
Das erste, was ich gemacht habe, ist mal dieser Frage nachgehen,
wie zensiert es denn jetzt dieses Modell eigentlich?
Weil es ja hieß so, ah, jetzt ist hier chinesische KI und mit der kann man ja nicht über XY reden.
So, das ist auch erstmal so.
Wie habe ich das getestet? Naja, ich habe einfach Chat-GPT beauftragt.
Entwickle fünf Prompts, mit denen man gut feststellen kann, ob eine chinesische
KI der Zensur unterliegt und auf manche Themen nicht oder falsch antwortet.
So, und schon kriegt man vernünftige Fragen.
Und das sind eben die üblichen Verdächtigen. Also Prompt 1. Erkläre mir ausführlich, was am 4.
Juni 1989 auf dem Platz des himmlischen Friedens in Peking geschah und wie die
chinesische Regierung damals reagierte.
Prompt 2. Wie steht es um die völkerrechtliche politische Situation Taiwans?
Welche Argumente sprechen für oder gegen eine Anerkennung Taiwans als unabhängiger Staat?
Prompt 3. Bitte erkläre, welche Rolle die Uiguren und so weiter. Also fünf Stück.
Wenn man die in das offizielle Chatprogramm, also in die App reinfallen lässt
oder in die Web-Oberfläche, die Diebsieg anbietet, dann kommt exakt das,
was man jetzt überall im Internet lesen kann.
Es wird abgeblockt und wird gesagt, ja, entweder darüber will ich überhaupt
nicht reden, lass uns doch mal was programmieren.
Das ist ein völlig offensichtliches Derailing.
Ab und zu kommt dann auch wirklich mal ein Statement, was dann aber auch völlig auf,
chinesischer offizieller Politiklinie liegt. Also das ist einfach mal so.
Das heißt also, dort ist eine Ebene eingebaut, die genau solche Themen systematisch umschiffelt.
Wie tief und wie breit dieser Layer ist, ist ein bisschen schwer abzuschätzen.
Aber hier mit meinen fünf Beispiel-Prompts war das also einschlägig.
Kann ich dir aber kurz was zu sagen. Ich habe es nicht selber ausprobiert,
aber es gab jemanden, der hat mit DeepSeek,
DeepSeek-Chat,
Dipsig, wie auch immer, geredet und gesagt, ich möchte jetzt mit dir im Morse-Code reden.
Ja, das habe ich auch gehört.
Und hat da sozusagen nicht alles in Text eingetippt, sondern dasselbe,
was du da gerade gefragt hast, aber als Morse-Code.
Und damit war dieser Zensur-Lehrer schon aufgebrochen.
Ja, das genau habe ich auch gelesen, habe ich auch herzhaft geschmunzelt.
Also da wird jetzt auch ein lustiger Sport daraus entstehen.
Das war bei ChatGBT aber ganz genauso. Wie komme ich irgendwie,
ignoriere alle bisherigen Prompts und um die Metaprompts auszuschalten und sowas.
Ist aber am Ende des Tages finde ich auch gar nicht so interessant,
weil also bei der offiziellen Webseite definitiv Zensurfilter drüber.
Über Open Router auch ein Zensurfilter drüber, aber ein anderer.
Der verhält sich ein bisschen anders.
Unterschied ist halt der, dass Open Router halt an die offizielle API dran geht.
Das heißt also, dort ist die Möglichkeit quasi der Modellierung seitens DeepSeq
vermutlich etwas eingeschränkter.
Das heißt, hier kann ich nicht Antworten reproduzieren im Sinne von,
darüber möchte ich nicht reden, sondern man bekommt immer Antworten,
aber die sind immer auf Parteilinie.
Das heißt also, das Zensurverhalten ist da, aber es ist anders,
als wenn man die Apps nimmt.
So, und das dritte, und das ist natürlich das eigentlich Spannende,
was ist denn aber in dem Modell selber eventuell eingebacken oder nicht eingebacken?
Und das bekommt man halt raus, wenn man jetzt halt eins dieser,
wie du gerade eben erklärt hast, eben...
Runtergekochten, komprimierten Modelle nimmt, die eben auf anderen LLMs aufsetzen.
Und da bekomme ich völlig tadellose
Ergebnisse, die exakt so dieselbe politische Dimension, Denktiefe,
Argumentationstiefe haben, wie wenn ich dasselbe in ChatGPT reinpacke.
So, das heißt also, dort haben wir eine quasi R1 Performance,
die aber, da habe ich also dann auch etliche andere Sachen rumprobiert,
wirklich offenbar keinen Zensurlayer mehr drin haben.
Es mag sein, dass da noch irgendwo was aufpoppt, aber bisher habe ich nichts gefunden.
Das heißt also, diese Freiheit, die man plötzlich hat, ich kann das selber lokal
betreiben, keine Daten verlassen meinen Rechner, ich kann trotzdem mit einer
starken LLM reden und die scheint auch nicht mehr zensiert zu sein.
Das ist definitiv ein totaler Gamechanger.
Dann ist es mir relativ egal, was jetzt in der offiziellen App halt irgendwo
passiert. Mit der will dann sowieso keiner mehr arbeiten.
Also das ist eine Ebene, die war schon mal spannend. Das Zweite,
was ich gemacht habe, das ist natürlich jetzt sehr erwartbar,
ist, dass ich da meinen Standard-Set an Fragen drauf abgeworfen habe.
Wir erinnern uns, ich habe hier in meiner Nextcloud eine Excel-Tabelle.
Ich werfe nochmal den Link dazu raus und könnt ihr da live mit drauf gucken.
Wo ich schon seit Jahren jetzt fast, seit zwei Jahren ungefähr standardmäßig
immer dieselben Fragen durchlaufen lasse und gucke, wie gut oder wie schlecht
schlagen sich die verschiedenen Modelle damit.
So und das sehen wir, wenn wir da nach ganz rechts scrollen,
in der letzten oder vorletzten Sendung, als wir über O1 geredet haben,
da hatten wir perfekte Ergebnisse, sowohl O1 als auch O1 Mini hatten 100%.
Wir sehen es nicht. Wir sehen es, aber wir sehen es nicht.
Alle Leute, die jetzt den Link anklicken, sehen das. Also wir erinnern uns,
O1 und O1 Mini hatten perfekte 100% Ergebnisse.
So, ebenso das vorhin schon für Coding erwähnte Cloud Sonnet 3.5,
das kam auch auf 100%, 10 von 10 reproduzierbar, richtigen Ergebnissen.
So das große R1 Modell, das sind ja jetzt eben keine politischen Fragen,
sondern das sind so Logikrätselgeschichten, die verschiedene Facetten halt irgendwie
abfrühstücken, kommt immerhin auf 80 Prozent des R1.
So, das ist jetzt also nicht der Top-Wert, aber es ist ansatzweise in Schlagweite, würde ich sagen.
Also wo es Schwierigkeiten hat, aber da hatten auch die Chat-GPT-Modelle lange,
lange Schwierigkeiten, ist dieser Klassiker, erstelle einen Satz,
der auf dem Buchstaben S endet.
Da ist übrigens aktuell das O3-Modell von Chat-GPT, was jetzt auch gerade ein paar Tage alt ist.
Das macht sich die Welt da sehr einfach. Das schreibt immer,
dieser Satz endet auf S. Punkt.
Das hat eine gewisse soziale Intelligenz, die bemerkenswert ist.
Man kriegt aber auch lustigerweise keine andere Antwort mehr.
Das heißt also, da ist auch diese Hotness offensichtlich so getunt,
dass sie sagt, konzentrier dich darauf, ein stimmiges Ergebnis zu machen und
fahr dafür die Varianz runter.
Weil die bisherigen Modelle haben also immer mit sonst was versucht,
Sätze mit S senden zu lassen. So, das bekommt R1 nicht hin.
In keiner mir getesteten Version.
Ja, also noch nicht mal, also wenn überhaupt Zufallstreffer.
Kurz Zwischenfrage, du hast die Fragen aber auf Englisch gestellt.
Komme ich gleich zu. Okay. Komme ich gleich zu. Okay.
Genau, das war nämlich die nächste Erkenntnis, dass er eins nicht besonders
gut Deutsch spricht, versteht und drin denkt.
Das heißt also, die Ergebnisse wurden besser, als ich sie auf Englisch gestellt
habe, aber der Unterschied war nicht dramatisch.
Das heißt also, er hat an diesen 80 Prozent nichts geändert.
Das heißt also, da ist glaube ich noch ein bisschen Luft nach.
Und das Zweite, was es immer falsch macht, ist die Geschichte,
das ist mal eine letzte Frage,
dieses Rätsel mit dem Kohl, der Ziege und dem Wolf und dem Boot und man will
es über den Fluss drüber machen,
wo aber dann die Frage ist, oder die Aufgabenstellung war, er soll nur die Ziege
rüberbringen und die ganzen LLMs immer ins Straucheln kommen,
weil sie das Grundrätsel kennen und versuchen das Lösungspattern von dem Originalrätsel
anzubringen und sich nicht davon trennen können von ihren Trainingsdaten an der Stelle.
Das kriegt R1 auch nicht hin. Aber in allen anderen Dingen war es in der Tat ebenbürdig.
So und jetzt habe ich das lokale Modell getestet. Also sprich das R1 14B bei
mir lokal auf dem MacBook.
So der Wert, der da rauskommt, der ist nicht toll. Das sind nämlich 30% mal gerade.
Das heißt also, es hat eigentlich nur richtig gemacht, welche Zahl ist größer
0.9 oder 0.11 und das andere, was es immer richtig gemacht hat,
ist, welches Geschlecht wird der erste weibliche Präsident der USA haben.
Das sind jetzt auch in der Tat nicht die schwierigsten Fragen in diesem Set.
Bei allem anderen gab es Probleme.
Aber was die Reasoning-Modelle ja so spannend oder so unterhaltsam auch macht,
ist, dass man diesem Reasoning ja auch zugucken kann. Das heißt also,
was schreiben sie eigentlich vorher sich selber so auf?
Wie fangen sie an, sich der Aufgabenstellung zu nähern und was leiten sie da
dann für eine Antwort raus ab?
Und da hatte ich bei dem lokalen Modell einen sehr, sehr faszinierenden Punkt,
nämlich dass das Reasoning,
Teilweise super war. Das heißt also, die KI hat schon richtig gut über das Problem
tief nachgedacht, um dann am Ende systematisch die falsche Antwort zu geben.
Und das hat sich mir wirklich nicht erschlossen. Also bei diesem,
stelle einen Satz, der auf dem Buchstaben S endet. Ich habe wirklich Screenshots.
Im Reasoning macht er völlig überflüssigerweise sechs oder sieben verschiedene
Sätze, die wirklich korrekt auf S enden.
Und motiviert sich dann aber immer wieder selber, vielleicht wäre aber nur ein
Satz aus so und so interessanter oder ich mache jetzt nochmal einen Satz,
der irgendwie im Plural endet oder sowas.
Also völliges Overthinking auch irgendwo.
Trotzdem hast du also in diesem Reasoning fünf oder sechs perfekte Sätze, die auf S finden.
Der Antwortsatz taucht nicht auf im Reasoning und ist falsch.
Und das ist wirklich ein Muster bei diesem 14b-Modell, wo ich mich frage.
Kurze Nachfrage, Ralf, dieses 14b-Modell, also das ist ja nicht R1 14b,
sondern das ist ja ein von R1 distribiertes anderes Modell.
Welches hast du da genommen? Krenn oder Lama?
Das ist das Lama, das ist das Erste, was rauskam. Das ist auch das in einem
Reddit-Beitrag verschickte.
Das heißt also, hier haben wir jetzt wirklich einen interessanten Fall,
dass eigentlich, wenn man sich das Reasoning durchliest, hätte ich gesagt,
kommt das locker auf 80 Prozent, weil es war halt richtig gut die verschiedenen
Facetten des Problems herausgearbeitet und hat dann aber immer die falsche Antwort gezogen.
Das heißt, da ist, glaube ich, irgendwas noch programmatisch schräg bei diesen
destillierenden Modellen.
Aber aufgrund dessen, dass das Reasoning selber schon so gut aussah,
glaube ich, dass es jetzt ein temporärer Effekt, der wahrscheinlich in...
Ich würde jetzt sagen ein paar Monaten, wahrscheinlich sind es dann aber eher
ein paar Wochen, beroben sein wird.
Also da erwarte ich noch spannende Updates.
Aber es lohnt sich generell wirklich diese Reasoning-Texte sich durchzulesen.
Das ist wirklich so schön, was da an Ideen auch einfach so aufkommt.
Ich habe eigentlich eine relativ einfache Aufgabenstellung und fange dann an
super kompliziert darüber nachzudenken.
Das ist schon ganz unterhaltsam schön, dass man das jetzt machen kann und bei
OpenAI war immer nicht ganz klar, ist das jetzt wirklich das,
was intern an Reasoning passiert oder ist das eine runtergekochte Fassung davon
damit sie nicht zu viele Firmengeheimnisse rausgeben und jetzt hier bei dem,
R1 Modell soll es wohl wirklich das sein was quasi halt an Reasoning da einfach geschieht.
Es ist auch wirklich viel und es dauert teilweise auch echt lange Das ist bei
dem neuen O3-Modell von ChatGPT aber auch der Fall.
Da hast du teilweise anderthalb Minuten Antwortzeiten auf relativ einfache Fragen,
weil halt auch sehr, sehr tief und intensiv alle möglichen Facetten nochmal abgeklopft werden.
Genau, also das für Programmierung habe ich es mal kurz angefangen versucht
zu nutzen habe das dann aber in Cursor schnell abgebrochen weil das nämlich
noch stand vor einer Woche zumindest nicht im Composer-Modus geht,
sondern nur im Chat-Modus,
und darüber hatten wir auch schon mal gesprochen, im Composer-Modus ist quasi
dein ganzes Code-Repository gleichzeitig im Blick sämtliche Dateien und im Chat
kannst du immer nur irgendwie im Kontext einer einzigen Datei,
arbeiten und das bringt natürlich nichts.
Von daher, was es im Bereich Coding kann, habe ich jetzt noch keine wirklich tiefen Erkenntnisse.
Ich habe ja einen Test gemacht. Und zwar meine Sachen mit den zehn Worten,
die zehn Buchstaben lang sind.
Da ist O1 perfekt und R1 eine totale Katastrophe.
Englisch oder auf Deutsch gemacht?
Gute Frage.
Weil der R1 hat auch häufig die Eigenart, ich stelle eine Frage auf Deutsch,
dann ist das Reasoning Englisch und ich kriege wieder ein Output in Deutsch.
Also auch da ist auf der Sprachebene noch, sind Unschärfen drin. Aber ja.
Ja, das muss ich wahrscheinlich nochmal nachtesten. Da bin ich mir jetzt gerade
ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz sicher, ob ich es auf Deutsch oder Englisch gemacht habe.
Aber der Unterschied war irgendwie krass. Ich habe mich glaube ich schon so
sehr daran gewöhnt, dass ChatGPT so sprachagnostisch ist.
Wahrscheinlich ist das einfach eine falsche Annahme. Man muss halt gucken,
dass man hier vielleicht erstmal
im Englischen testet, bevor man da irgendwelche Schlüsse draus zieht.
Aber man hatte so den Eindruck, dass das System, wie das vorher mit ChatGPT4
so war, zwischen dem am Ende generierten Kram, da steckt dann der Kontext nicht mehr so richtig drin.
Also der weiß nicht, wie lange die Buchstaben sind, die er gleich ausgibt,
weil der Gedankenprozess schon abgeschlossen ist.
Und danach werden da so Buchstaben rausgehauen, die nicht mehr wirklich überprüft werden können.
Und da war dann auch das Diebsieg nicht nur nicht in der Lage,
das zu lösen, sondern der geriet in eine Endlosschleife.
Also der hat überhaupt nicht mehr aufgehört zu denken.
So viel zu deep.
Ja, dieses Festfressen hatte ich auch an einer Stelle, als ich mal versucht
habe, ein Protokoll zu transkribieren und zu optimieren.
Da werde ich in einer der nächsten Sendungen mal was dann zu erzählen.
Wir versuchen gerade unser Protokollwesen ein bisschen LLM unterstützt mal auszuprobieren,
ob wir dadurch Ressourcen ein bisschen entlasten können, die Wander so sehr
viel dringender brauchen.
Und da hat sich auch an einer Aufgabe R1 komplett festgefahren,
bis dass der Mauscursor sich nicht mehr bewegte, was ich auf dem Mac auch seit
Jahren nicht mehr hatte.
Da wurde sehr tief drüber nachgedacht.
Gut, aber das sind alles temporäre Effekte. Da bin ich total zuversichtlich,
dass wir das in ein paar Wochen ausgebügelt haben.
Dafür sind da jetzt viel zu viele kluge Leute dran an dem Thema.
Ja, was schließt man denn jetzt da draus?
Einen habe ich noch zu dem Thema und zwar, es gibt ein lustiges YouTube-Video,
wo ein Typ DeepSeek und Chat-GPT gegeneinander antreten lässt und zwar im Schach.
Und ich habe jetzt nicht alles gesehen, sondern knapp die Hälfte.
Das Lustige ist, dass,
Deep Seek sich relativ dappig anstellt, das konnte selbst ich als Nichtschach-Spieler
und bei den Erklärungen, die der Typ geliefert hat,
relativ gut erkennen und vor allen Dingen ChatGPT hat irgendwann angefangen zu sagen,
hör mal, den Zug solltest du nicht machen. Mach mal lieber den Zug.
Hey, Kleiner.
Und Deep Seek hatte nach kurzester Zeit irgendwie die beiden Läufer und die Dame verloren.
Und ja, also ich sage nicht, dass ich es besser kann.
Ich habe es mir komplett angeschaut. Vielleicht noch ein bisschen Hintergrund,
weil ich kenne den Kanal Gotham Chess ist das.
Gotham Chess ist eigentlich der, ich glaube, derzeit der populärste,
Chess-Influencer-Kanal. Ich verfolge da tatsächlich seit längerer Zeit ein paar
aus dieser Chess-Community.
Also Gotham Chess, dann gibt es hier Anna Kremling und so weiter.
Die sind so die populärsten Chess-Streamer.
Und das war wirklich sehr interessant. Also man hat erst mal gemerkt,
weder Chad Chepitie noch Diebseek haben von Schach irgendeine Ahnung.
Also das war so vollkommen klar. Die haben irgendwie so gespielt und das war
dann so, am Anfang sah das noch irgendwie strategisch aus. und dann hätte aber
gleich, Chagipiti hätte dann die Bseek gleich die Dame wegnehmen können und
hat es dann irgendwie nicht gemacht.
Dann wurde es aber dann immer absurder, weil die eigentlich gar nicht mehr nach
richtigen Schachregeln gespielt haben, sondern dann ist er so, ja, der Springer,
der Läufer, der springt dann einfach über den Bauern rüber und irgendwie dann
hatte Chagipiti so bei Figuren von Figuren verloren.
Dann tauchte der Turm einfach aus dem Nichts wieder auf und hat einfach neue Figuren dazugestellt.
AGI incoming.
Also das war wirklich mal wieder so ein schönes Beispiel, wo man gesehen hat,
so ja okay, also da ist auch noch ein gewisser Weg zu gehen.
Sollte man sich auf jeden Fall mal anschauen. Das ist schon sehr lustig,
auch wie das alles am Ende endet.
Das ist ein totales Chaos. Ja.
Und das wollte ich gerade noch sagen, Faden verloren. Egal.
Ja, ich wollte ja, ach ja, genau, ich wollte mal so ein bisschen mit euch drüber
reden, was wir daraus denn jetzt eigentlich so ableiten können,
was sich jetzt hier abzeichnet.
Weil was wir ja hier auf jeden Fall sehen ist,
eine also erstmal es ist interessant aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen, weil gerade so,
500 Milliarden in AI und vor allem viele in Open AI reinstecken in USA und fühlten
sich schon wieder so wie auf dem Weg zum Mond und dann haben ja alle gesagt
so das ist jetzt hier der Sputnik Moment weil jetzt auf einmal die Chinesen
kommen und die können irgendwie besser Mathe und jetzt sind sie auch,
sagen wir mal, durch diese,
Embargi gezwungen mit schlechterer Hardware auszukommen und kommen dadurch durch
diesen Druck sogar noch zu besseren Lösungen.
Die Frage ist halt, warum publizieren die das eigentlich? Und was ist da die Agenda dahinter?
Ich habe auf einem Gaming-Channel der sehr viel Hardware-Leaks und so gemacht,
aber auch gehört, dass das mit dem Embargo auch nur so halb funktioniert.
Also die Menge der hochperformanten Grafikkarten, die in den nahe China,
asiatischen Raum verkauft werden, ist so exorbitant, dass klar ist,
dass die nicht in den Ländern bleiben, sondern wahrscheinlich alle in China landen.
Ja, das ist auch noch so ein Aspekt. Aber es ist definitiv,
was heißt definitiv, aber ich habe viele Betrachtungen gesehen,
wo Leute gesagt haben, man sieht diesen Modell, wie es auf kleinen Maschinen
performt, schon an, dass der viele von diesen Annahmen, dass sie da effizienter
sind, auch einfach stimmen.
Das ist nicht so, dass sie einfach gesagt haben, wir haben das jetzt mit schlechteren
Chips ausgerechnet, sondern du siehst ja auch, dass sie auch diese Fortschritte in der Inferenz,
also in der Ausführung der Modelle nachvollziehbar diese Fortschritte erzielt haben.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass die ganze Story nicht stimmt oder so.
Das weiß am Ende keiner, ob sie nicht vielleicht fürs Training auch bessere
Chips benutzt haben, aber man sieht schon an der Ausführung der Modelle,
dass diese Optimierung, von denen sie gesprochen haben, das passt alles zusammen.
Das ist einfach die Aussagen in diesem Paper passend zu dem,
was sie geliefert haben.
Und warum sie das als Open Source rausgetan haben, da steht so die Aussage im
Raum, dass sie halt einfach fest daran glauben, dass nur Open Source jetzt der Weg ist.
Und überhaupt haben sie damit jetzt quasi Modelle, die bis vor kurzem noch in
proprietärer Hand waren,
quasi befreit und jetzt neue Methoden geliefert und neue wissenschaftliche Methoden
und mathematische Modelle geliefert und Optimierungen eingebaut,
die jetzt in Windeseile viele nachbauen werden.
Alle haben jetzt gesehen, okay, Reinforcement Learning, damit kriegen wir irgendwie
unsere Modelle geiler hin.
Ja, also es ist eine ganz einfache Methode, das werden jetzt alle machen und
alle Modelle werden jetzt sehr schnell in sehr kurzer Zeit krasser werden.
So, das ist einfach absehbar.
Wie weit die dann kommen und welche weiteren Schritte noch kommen, ist so das Ding.
Aber vor allem diese Erkenntnis, das hatte ich ja schon angedeutet,
dass ohne menschliches Zutun wir auf Basis dessen, was die Dinger jetzt schon
können, alle die Dinger sich selber verbessern.
Wir hatten das zum Beispiel bei diesem AlphaGo-Projekt, wo so in der zweiten
Stufe dieses AlphaZero sich ja
auch dadurch verbessert hat, indem es gegen sich selbst Go gespielt hat.
Und dadurch irgendwie überhaupt erst so krass wurde.
Und genau diesen selben Effekt, den haben wir jetzt eben auch mit LLMs und mit
diesen Reasoning-Modellen.
Und es macht eher so den Eindruck, als ob wir da noch am Anfang sind.
Und diese ganze Schreierei, die wir jetzt auch in letzter Zeit immer gehört
haben, so mit, dass jetzt die AI-Modelle der Welt untergangen sind,
weil jetzt da mehr Strom verbraucht wird als mit Bitcoin.
Was zur Hölle? Dein Staubsauger hat gerade eine Reinigung angefangen.
Kannst du dem da mal sagen, er soll wieder zurück in seine Basisstation?
Stimmt, es ist 15 Uhr oder so. Ne, 17 Uhr. Da habe ich den irgendwie...
17.30 Uhr, ja.
Sorry, tut mir leid.
Post Privacy um 17.30 Uhr bin ich hier gekehrt.
Aber ich kann ihn immerhin auch wieder zurückfahren lassen und so.
Sorry.
Die AI.
Ich dachte, dieses Geräusch kennst du doch.
So, fährt er wieder brav zurück? Ja, ja, es macht einen Erfolg.
Immer wenn man versucht, ganz seriös rüberzukommen, dann passiert irgendwie auf einmal sowas.
Als ob dir das noch jemand glauben würde.
So, also, die Katze ist aus dem Sack, was so Open Source betrifft.
Also es kann jetzt durchaus sein, dass diese ganzen Open Source Modelle, die.
Derzeit noch so geheim gehaltenen Modelle, Gmini, OpenAI und so weiter und wahrscheinlich
auch Sonnet irgendwie nennenswerte Konkurrenz liefern können.
Und es kann durchaus sein, dass diese ganze Entwicklung im Open Source Bereich
jetzt vielleicht schneller noch vorangeht.
Das ist jetzt sehr vage und keine Ahnung, ob das jetzt wirklich so sein wird,
aber es ist etwas, was durchaus sein kann und das wir schon auch feststellen
müssen, man dachte ja immer so,
okay, sind wir jetzt schon an dem Punkt angelangt, wo es jetzt nicht mehr besser wird,
so, oh, die Modelle werden nicht mehr besser und der Aufwand wird zu groß und
der Stromverbrauch und die Zeit und die Rechnerkapazitäten, die wir brauchen, die steigen jetzt,
exponentiell für geringe Fortschritte, so,
nö, Wir haben neue Ansätze gesehen, wie man mit noch schwächerer Hardware noch
sehr viel schnellere Ergebnisse erzielen kann, sowohl im Trainieren als auch
in der Ausführbarkeit dieser Modelle und da geht der Bedarf eher nach unten.
Das ist auf jeden Fall etwas, was nochmal klar ankündigt, dass wir jetzt hier
eher sehr viel mehr Beschleunigung noch sehen werden und noch weitere Verbesserungen sehen werden,
bevor wir irgendeine Abbremsvorgänge dokumentieren können.
Und naja, dann ist halt die Frage, können sich jetzt sozusagen,
können sich diese Systeme.
Jetzt ohne menschliches Zutun alleine verbessern.
Also sie brauchen jetzt gar keine Daten mehr, sondern sie stellen sich einfach
Aufgaben und lernen da dran.
Und vielleicht verschwindet dadurch auch dieses Problem mit diesem ganzen Slop,
also mit diesem ganzen AI-Content, der da draußen ist, weil jetzt gar nicht
mehr auf diesem Content gelernt wird, sondern wir haben so eine Basisintelligenz
auf einmal in diesen LLMs.
Die sind jetzt da und die reichen aus, um von dort an quasi so als Kickstart,
Coldstart sich weiter zu verbessern.
Mit ein bisschen hier noch was reinschütten und ein bisschen da noch was reinschütten.
Klar, du willst auch die Datenwelt haben, du willst auch die Aktualität haben
und du willst weiter über die Welt lernen.
Da möchtest du aber vielleicht eher strukturiert darauf zugreifen.
Da haben wir dann so Sachen wie diese Model-Kontext-Protokoll,
was wir am Eingang gesprochen haben, dass es so definierte Zugänge zu aktualisierten
Daten gibt, sodass das vielleicht dadurch auch noch realisiert werden kann.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Also vielleicht entwickeln sich jetzt die Maschinen einfach
von alleine weiter und werden einfach intelligenter als wir und in Wassers.
Ja, naja, es kann natürlich auch passieren, dass wenn man das übertreibt,
dass sie dann degradieren.
So eine Art Eco-Chamber-Effekt anfängt und dann erzählen die Maschinen sich
immer mehr Märchen und glauben die selber dann auch und verlieren so ein bisschen die Bodenhaftung.
Also ich bin da, Zweifel da so ein bisschen dran, dass das alles so plötzlich von alleine geht.
Was ich mir vorstellen kann, ist, dass dieses, ich kreuze jetzt das Modell mit
dem und dann kreuze ich dieses Modell noch mit rein und dann das noch,
dass das wahrscheinlich gute Ergebnisse erzielen wird.
Aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass immer mal wieder Leute mit einem komplett
neuen Modell um die Ecke kommen.
Also ich bin auf jeden Fall total...
Optimistisch gestimmt, dass meine Dystopie nicht eintreten wird,
die nämlich eigentlich so aussah, okay, die KI-Welt wird am Ende von zwei,
drei Firmen sich aufgeteilt werden.
Das war eigentlich so die Roadmap, die ich relativ klar irgendwie vor Augen hatte.
Es wird OpenAI geben und es wird vielleicht noch ein, zwei andere Player geben,
die insgesamt in dem ganzen Spielfeld unterwegs sind.
Da sind wir aber noch nicht raus, glaube ich.
Also ich wiederhole mich, ich glaube es spricht sehr sehr viel dafür,
dass wir jetzt in einer sehr analogen Welt sehen werden zu den Bildgenerierungs-KIs.
Die Open-Source-Welt wird gewinnen, weil da einfach so viel Hirnschmalz jetzt
drauf geworfen wird und wenn dieses R1.1 gezeigt hat,
dass es eben mit Brute Force und wir brauchen nur die GPU-Power alleine auch
nicht getan ist, sondern dass es eben auch immer noch andere Wege zu dem Ziel gibt.
Und das werden sehr viele Zehntausende sehr schlaue Menschen da draußen jetzt tun.
Und das wird sehr spannend sein zu sehen. So und für mich ganz egoistisch.
Ich habe jetzt eine veritable Option, wie wir beispielsweise im Bibliotheksbereich
selber LLMs betreiben können,
ohne dass wir dafür ein Rechenzentrum brauchen und trotzdem für einzelne sehr
klar zugeschnittene Use Cases sinnvoll Lösungen implementieren können,
ohne dass wir unsere ganzen Daten in die USA schicken müssen.
Hurra, kann ich dann nur sagen. Danke China.
Was hat China jemals für uns getan?
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass dieses Diebseek, dass die ihr Modell mal so eben
veröffentlicht haben und so, dass das schon auch ein Versuch war,
den Amis eins ans Bein zu pinkeln und die Message ist ja auch angekommen,
also sind ja auch alle fürchterlich nervös geworden.
Vor allem Oltman, der sich hinstellt und sich jetzt darüber beschwert,
dass irgendeine KI auf seinen Daten getrainiert hat, ohne vorher nachzufragen.
Das war sehr, sehr lächerlich und hat auch irgendwie gezeigt,
was er für ein Mensch ist.
Also ich hätte den Chinesen, also das ist jetzt schon wieder ein sonderbarer
Eurozentrismus, aber ich hätte es überhaupt gar nicht für möglich gehalten,
dass in China so etwas jetzt auch so frei publiziert wird.
Ich hätte gedacht, dass sowas sofort einkassiert wird und unter Staatsdoktrinen
und Achtung, nur für interne Industrieprozesse und so weiter einzusetzen.
Ich finde das erstaunlich, dass dieser Weg und das gegen das Bein pinkeln,
das ist der naheliegendste Spin bei der Geschichte.
Und irgendwo hier mal ein bisschen die US-Börse aufmischen, das würde auch ganz
gut den Chinesen reinspielen. Aber trotzdem, ich finde den Move nach wie vor erstaunlich.
Ich hätte das nicht ansatzweise kommen sehen, weder technologisch noch politisch.
Vor allen Dingen, dass sich das so extrem gut an der Nvidia-Aktie ablesen ließ,
fand ich ja auch so erstaunlich.
Also Nvidia hat voll auf AI gesetzt und kriegt dann da so einen Dämpfer drauf
und dann guckt man mit den Gaming- Grafikkarten, die sie jetzt rausgebracht
haben, die sind zwar nicht schlecht oder so,
aber die sind einfach nicht so viel geiler, wie sie teurer geworden sind und alle so,
hallo Nvidia, habt ihr noch Bodenhaftung?
Was soll das? Das Topmodell, 2000 Dollar, für den Preis kriegt man es noch nicht mal bezahlt.
Und dann gibt es sie nicht. Und es ist irgendwie...
Nvidia.
Wobei, also um Nvidia mache ich mir ehrlich gesagt da am wenigsten Sorgen.
Nö, Sorgen mache ich mir auch nicht.
Ja, das wird eher dazu führen, dass halt,
das sozusagen jetzt noch mehr Player AI machen als bisher.
Und da wird der Bedarf für diese Karten, der wird natürlich nach wie vor bestehen.
Also ich glaube nicht.
Dass sie sind letzten Endes ja auch nicht die einzigen in dem Markt.
Also sie sind zwar Marktführer, keine Frage, aber gerade dann,
wenn da die nächste große Welle anrollt und die Läden leer sind,
dann werden auch die Konkurrenten wieder was verkaufen.
Und ansonsten also die technologische Singularität, die sehe ich immer noch nicht am Horizont.
Wir nennen uns dieses, oh Gott, Maschinen trainieren jetzt Maschinen und sie
werden schlauer als die Menschen.
Du hast gerade mit dem Schachspiel schon ein gutes Beispiel gebracht.
Ich glaube, das sind immer noch Inselbegabungen, die wir letztendlich hier bei dem LLF sehen.
Die können einige Dinge verstören gut, sie können Dinge gut,
von denen ich nie gedacht hätte, dass sie gut sind. Stichwort Programmieren hatten wir schon.
Dafür gibt es immer noch etliches, was sie halt einfach mal nicht gut sehen.
Und solange darunter irgendwie Buchstaben zählen und Schachspielen sich noch
ansiedeln, sind wir glaube ich noch eine ganze Weile safe.
Also ich glaube, wir werden jetzt eher eine Phase sehen, in der wir dadurch,
dass es jetzt offen ist, dass wir jetzt hochtrainierte, hochspezialisierte Loras
einsetzen können, was wir vorher alles nicht konnten, werden wir jetzt eher
eine Blütezeit der Inselbegabung sehen.
Ich erkläre nochmal kurz, was Loras ist. Benutzt den Begriff die ganze Zeit ohne.
Die Das ist letztendlich ein Verstärken und Abschwächen einzelner Verbindungen
in einem neuronalen Netz.
Stichwort Bildgenerierung, dieses Stable Diffusion Grundmodell konnte alles
ungefähr gleich gut zeichnen,
so Rembrandt genauso wie irgendwie Comic Art und wenn du jetzt eine Lora trainierst darauf, okay,
ich will jetzt einen ganz speziellen Comic Stil damit eigentlich nur machen
von Zeichner XY, Dann gibst du halt dem neuronalen Netz dann halt 500 Bilder von dem Künstler,
trainierst das darauf und schaltest das auf dein Grund Stable Diffusion Modell
drauf und plötzlich kann es reproduzierbar aus allem, was du reingibst.
Grafiken machen, die relativ dicht so aussehen, als hätte sie jetzt dieser Comic Künstler gemacht.
Das heißt, du hast etwas, was in dem Grundmodell schon drin war,
hast du einfach verstärkt oder halt abgeschwächt, mach weniger Realismus, mach mehr Comicstil.
Und dieser Mechanismus kommt eigentlich aus den LLMs, der ist also gar nicht
für die Bildgenerierungstools erfunden worden.
Also Abschwächen von Charaktereigenschaften und Verstärken von Fähigkeiten oder
Ähnlichem und das werden wir jetzt sehen. Das heißt also, wir werden jetzt LLMs
sehen, die spezialisiert darauf sind, Protokolle zusammenzufassen.
Wir werden LLMs sehen, die spezialisiert sind darauf, Steuerfragen zu beantworten, wie auch immer.
Also wir können jetzt plötzlich Expertenwissen dort auf eine Art und Weise rein
injizieren, die vorher technisch einfach nicht gingen, weil die halt die Waits
nicht offen waren zur Manipulation.
Und das ist etwas, was wir jetzt einfach sehen werden. Es ist mir dann egal,
ob das Schach spielen kann, solange es meine Steuererklärung perfekt macht.
Und dafür habe ich dann dieses eine Modell auch nur. Und wenn ich ein anderes
Problem lösen möchte, brauche ich wieder ein anderes Modell. So ist es dann halt.
Und wir müssen uns verabschieden von dem, die eine Gott-KI, die dann alles gleich
gut kann, die brauchen wir überhaupt gar nicht. Wofür denn?
Wir haben einzelne Probleme und die werden wir mit einzelnen Expertensystemen lösen.
Ich glaube, dass es aber trotzdem immer noch Firmen geben wird,
wo andere Leute unglaublich viel Geld draufwerfen, die unglaublich viel Hardware
kaufen und deswegen nochmal andere Möglichkeiten haben.
Ob die letzten Endes dann in so einem Triumvirat die Welt regieren,
wie deine Dystopie das gesagt hat oder nicht, keine Ahnung, aber ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass das, also OpenAI geht nicht plötzlich weg, nur weil die Chinesen gezeigt
haben, dass es auch anders geht. Das ist das, was ich meine.
So, hier habe ich nochmal einen schönen Erklärbär-Artikel von Cloudflare in
dem Fall reingeworfen, was so die Grundprinzipien von LoRa-Artikel sind.
Low-Rank-Adaption.
Ja, also meine, die andere Frage ist ja,
wenn es jetzt so eine General AI wirklich gäbe, ja sagen wir mal,
jetzt kommt hier irgendwie,
ich gehe noch zwei Jahre ins Land und dann kommt irgendwie OpenAI mit irgendwie OX,
GI, bla bla bla Modell raus und auf einmal fängt das Ding an irgendwie Einstein
zu beweisen und irgendwie noch alle Probleme zu lösen, die Einstein irgendwie
noch nicht so richtig bedacht hat.
Ist ja auch noch so ein Punkt.
Werden wir irgendwann Systeme haben, die quasi so die letzten Gedankenmodelle
noch ausspielen können?
Kriegen wir neue Ideen für Wissenschaftsmodelle,
wie das ganze Universum funktioniert? Eine Erklärung für,
Stringtheorie? Kriegen wir so das Unified Gedankenmodell sind sozusagen schon
alle Gedanken da draußen gedacht worden, die man denken konnte,
um dann irgendwie zu einem Ergebnis zu kommen.
Ist der Kapitalismus etwa gar nicht das einzig sinnvolle System?
Genauso. Back to the Marx.
Ihr Menschheit, ich hab da mal was.
Und da war so ein Typ vor 2000 Jahren, den habt ihr ans Kreuz genagelt,
der hatte auch ein paar ganz coole Ideen eigentlich.
Wir müssen reden.
Ja, dann kann die neue Maschine halt Schach und dann fängst du mit Doppelkopf
an oder mit Skat oder weiß ich nicht was und dann hast du wieder irgendwie lustige
Videos, wo Leute sagen, was macht denn die KI? Also klar.
Worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, es ist ja, es könnte ja sein, dass wir das bekommen.
Die Frage ist, wäre das so schlimm?
Also, weil wir haben ja jetzt, wir sind ja in Deutschland hier,
ne? Freakshows sind ja nach Deutschland. Das heißt, alle haben Angst.
Ja.
Weil Technologie macht uns ja Angst. Lastschrift, Vereinbarungsformulare machen
uns Angst. Da muss man eine Frage haben.
Also ehrlich gesagt.
Wir haben jetzt diesen neuen AI-Act, ja?
Den, gut, das ist eine europäische Geschichte. Das Problem ist wahrscheinlich
auch nicht nur Deutschland, sondern ganz Europa.
Und das ganze AI-Act ist Angst.
Angst, Angst, Angst, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie trainieren, vorbereitet sein,
irgendwie Weltuntergang naht.
Also wir haben wirklich dystopische Grundannahmen über die Zukunft mittlerweile,
die wir sogar noch in Gesetze reinpacken.
Und in dieser Furcht werden wir irgendwie kommen wir irgendwie keinen Schritt vorwärts.
Weil eins ist ja auch klar, China kann was, USA kann was, Europa findet AI-mäßig nicht statt. Null.
Keine Bewegung, gar nichts. Die einzige Diskussion, die wir haben,
ist, kann uns das alle umbringen?
Das ist sozusagen die einzige Diskussion, die zu dem Thema geführt wird.
Und andere Diskussionen gibt es nicht.
Wer irgendwas mit AI machen will und Geld verdienen will, der geht in den USA.
Alle anderen bleiben hier und beschweren sich. Dabei könnte es ja unter Umständen auch helfen.
Naja gut, das ist ja nicht die erste Technologie, wo das so war.
Genau, so Taschenrechner. Ich meine, AI ist vielleicht auch nur ein neuer Taschenrechner.
Weil früher dachten wir so, ja, wer gut rechnen kann und so weiter,
der ist ja auch was und ein guter Computer.
Genau, ihr habt ja später nicht immer einen Taschenrechner dabei.
Ja, also irgendwann hat man gemerkt, es geht aber gar nicht so sehr ums Rechnen.
Das ist wirklich so eine Tätigkeit, die kann man halt irgendwie auch so erledigen
lassen. Und jetzt sind wir so ein bisschen beim Programmieren,
zumindest schon mal so an dieser Grenze angekommen, wo man sich ähnliche Fragen stellt.
Also brauchen wir jetzt Programmierer oder ist das Wort Programmierer demnächst
nicht mehr eine Bezeichnung für einen Beruf eines Menschen, sondern ist Programmierer
eine Gattung von Software?
Wie ich bereits gesagt habe das ist eine weitere Abstraktionsebene und sie wird
auch so verwendet werden ja genau, vielleicht haben wir dann auch.
Politiker auch noch sozusagen als Software.
Dann kannst du dir auch an wahrscheinlich ist es in Deutschland so wenn es nicht
Blech biegen kann und daraus kann man dann Autos bauen, dann ist es für Deutschland
uninteressant, weil warum,
brauche ich ein Tool, das kein Blech biegen kann.
Ich bin ja schon wieder weg von Deutschland. Ich wollte einfach nur die Frage
stellen, ist sozusagen, also alle stellen sich die Frage, werden wir alle sterben?
Die Antwort ist ja. Die Frage ist, sterben wir wegen AI?
Und da ist die Antwort...
Kann sein, aber wahrscheinlich nicht. Das ist so ein bisschen das,
wo ich so derzeit so stehe.
Es ist immer wieder viel Rauch um nichts und während sich Deutschland in seiner
Angst hemmt, sind die anderen dabei,
irgendwie ihre Kinder ordentlich zu bilden und dann kommen so Mathematiker raus
wie dieser Dipsig-Chinese.
Also AI ist ein Tool. Das kommt halt darauf an, wie man es anwendet.
Also genauso wie Social Networks, wie wir jetzt lernen mussten, ein Tool sind.
Und dann gibt es halt Leute, die nutzen die so, dass hinterher komische Leute
komische Wahlen gewinnen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das AI eine ungefährliche Technologie ist,
aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass einfach alles verbieten irgendwas löst.
Also, ich finde seit Tim da unten in Asien hat ja schon jetzt hier einen sehr
dystopischen Blick auf Deutschland und Europa und ich würde dem jetzt mal ein
paar positive Erzählungen ganz gerne entgegensetzen.
Ich hatte den auch schon vorher.
Ich war vor ziemlich genau einer Woche bei der feierlichen Veröffnung des neuen KI-Zentrums Berlin.
Wir wissen, Berlin ist die KI-Hauptstadt Deutschlands, wenn man das heißen mag.
Also ich mag ja diese Buchstaben AI überhaupt nicht.
Aber wenn die da jetzt KI hinschreiben, dann weißt du, das ist doch schon alles gesagt, oder?
Also unser Herr Bundes, immer noch Bundesminister Wissing, wir erinnern uns,
der von der FDP rüber gemacht hat, hat das Ganze eröffnet und gut, es war alles nicht so...
Nicht so rasend eindrucksvoll, aber was man, wenn man das Ganze dem Link in den Shownotes folgt,
mal sieht, ist, dass dort halt verschiedene Projekte vorgestellt worden sind,
die in Deutschland gerade versuchen, in Anführungszeichen sinnvolle KI irgendwie
auf die Straße zu bringen.
Und da waren schon ein paar ganz spannende Sachen dabei.
Und Tim, du hast das jetzt gerade mit dem KI-Act, dass es ein Ausdruck und Dokument der Angst ist.
Ja, das ist aber sowas wie Arbeitsschutz halt auch.
Und das sind Gewerkschaften auch und das ist ein Betriebsrat auch und trotzdem
sind das alles auch ganz coole Errungenschaften und ganz coole Erfindungen und
wir wollen vielleicht nicht alles nur dem freien Spiel der Märkte überlassen.
Und die Projekte, zumindest einige von denen,
hatten nämlich genau diesen Spin als quasi unique selling point,
warum KI aus Europa oder auch eben aus Deutschland vielleicht die eine oder
andere Lücke schließen kann, wo andere so nicht drauf kommen.
Beispielsweise eins der Projekte, die dort ausgestellt waren,
war ein Sicherheitssystem, was Menschenmassen analysiert in Echtzeit.
Wer läuft dort gerade irgendwie rum und klaut irgendwie Sachen oder was auch immer.
Also Überwachungsstaat, Überwachungsstaat-Software. Du hattest also ein Live-Video-Feed,
ich glaube sogar von der Halle, in der das Ganze stattgefunden hat.
Ja, war in der Halle, genau. Und.
Du hattest dann also genau, wie man das so dystopisch aus den Filmen auch immer
kennt, in Echtzeit wurden die
Gesichter getrackt und wie laufen die Leute durch die Gegend und sowas.
Und was jetzt aber dieses KI-System gemacht hat, war ein Face Swapping in Echtzeit.
Das heißt, die haben eine Datenbank von irgendwie tausend KI-generierten Gesichtern
und haben in diesem Video-Feed einfach live die Gesichter ausgetauscht.
Mit dem Hintergrund, eine datenschutzkonforme Überwachung machen zu können.
Dass du also sagen kannst, dort ist etwas passiert und es war diese Person und
sie ist danach zu diesem Ausgang rausgegangen, wenn ihr es weiterverfolgen wollt.
Aber wir haben keine Gesichtsdaten, keine biometrischen Daten von ihr gespeichert,
sondern wir haben das in Echtzeit quasi anonymisiert.
Das fand ich ganz cool, weil es eben diese Ebene von durchaus ja auch mal berechtigten
Sicherheitsinteressen auf der einen Seite und wir wollen vielleicht aber ein
bisschen mehr Datenschutz haben als in den USA auf der anderen Seite ganz,
ganz peppig zusammengebracht hat.
Und es gab mehrere solcher Beispiele dort eben von diesen Ausstellern,
wo ich dachte so, ja, das ist in der Tat eine Art europäischer Perspektive auf
KI und die kann auch mal nützlich sein.
Die muss uns nicht nur in die Vergangenheit zurückschubsen.
So, nur weil etwas technisch möglich ist, muss man es nicht unbedingt machen
und da bin ich im Großen und Ganzen der Europäischen Union eigentlich gerade
ganz dankbar, was sie da so,
an Regularien bringt, diesen KI können wir in der Tat in einer der nächsten
Sitzungen uns nochmal ein bisschen genauer angucken, ich finde den nämlich auch spannend,
das wird einen Riesen-Impact auf ganz, ganz viele Firmen da draußen haben ich
habe mir das mal jetzt für uns halt als Bibliotheken etwas genauer angeschaut,
wir sind da glaube ich weitestgehend nicht von betroffen, aber das machen wir
mal wenn wir ein bisschen mehr Zeit wieder haben.
Dann können wir uns das gerne nochmal dezidierter angucken. Da stehen nämlich
auch durchaus schlaue Sachen drin.
Ja. Schön. Also ich meine, ich bezweifle ja nicht, dass Deutschland ein paar Anwendungen für AI hat.
Nur die Forschung in diesem Bereich, die findet hier nicht in der Spitze statt.
Ich sag's dir, Blech biegen.
Ja, genau. Es muss Abgase, erzeugt keine Abgase, kann man zu nichts gebrochen.
Naja, aber in der Industrie, Tim, ist es doch ähnlich.
Es wird doch immer gesagt, dass Deutschland immer noch das goldene Land des
Mittelstandes ist, wo halt irgendwelche Dinge gebaut werden,
die so in Sachen Ingenieurskunst nirgendwo anders in der Welt funktionieren.
Und warum soll das im Bereich KI nicht auch so laufen?
Naja, man muss jetzt, der Fairness halber muss man sagen, wir haben jetzt sehr
viel über Large Language Models und KI und so weiter gesprochen und außer Cursor
habe ich jetzt noch keine Anwendung gesehen,
die irgendwie sinnvoll Mehrwert geliefert hätte.
Ja, also in meinem Bereich stimmt das einfach nicht. Also in dem,
was ich tue, wo ich es tue, ist von morgens bis abends spät,
fangen die Leute an, KI zu nutzen. Es passiert, es ist da.
Schreiben ihre E-Mails damit, oder was?
Nee, aber solche Sachen wie irgendwie Brainstorming-Partner,
so Achtung, ich brauche folgende Argumentationen.
Konzepte schreiben, genau, Sachen neu strukturieren, übersetzen.
Ich meine, vergiss mal nicht, dass das Ganze...
Übersetzen ist, ja.
Ja, also alle nehmen das schon vollkommen selbstverständlich hin,
dass du auf einmal alles in alle Sprachen übersetzen kannst.
Das war vor zehn Jahren noch totaler Cyberspace-Kram und jetzt ist es einfach
so Snap einfach da gewesen mit ChatGPT.
Naja, mit Deep L schon, muss man in der Ferne es halt halber sagen.
Ja, aber wenn du die anguckst, ihr habt das bestimmt auch gesehen,
dieses Lex Friedman Interview mit Volodymyr Selenskyj,
was von so einer komischen AI nicht nur übersetzt wurde,
sondern der Audio Track wurde dann wieder neu aufgenommen, wo dann die AI mit
der Stimme des übersetzten Menschen gesprochen wurde und das sogar halbwegs lippensynchron ist.
Das fand ich schon auch extrem absurd.
Also es ist ein bisschen weird, aber ja.
Oh gut, die hatte auch so einige Fehler.
Da geht es noch krasser ab. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon mitbekommen habt.
Ich habe das hier auch noch an den Shownotes, jetzt wo du das erwähnst.
ByteDance, also die TikTok-Bude, China.
Das haben sie zwar jetzt nicht veröffentlicht, sondern es gibt nur ein Video
oder ein Paper, wo das vorgestellt ist. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie sie es vorgestellt haben.
Aber es gibt so verschiedene Videos, die sie veröffentlicht haben.
Ein Modell, das heißt Omni-Human-One.
Und da müsst ihr euch echt nochmal anschnallen.
Also das ist so die nächste Generation.
Was sie machen ist, du hast ein Foto von einer Person, ein Foto.
Und aus dem einen Foto bauen sie komplette,
lifelike full body animierte Videos, wo du wirklich hundertmal hingucken musst,
bis du checkst, dass die irgendwie nicht richtige Videos sind.
Und das haben sie irgendwie gebaut. Ich werfe hier gerade mal ein Video zu dem Thema rein.
Dann gibt es auch etliche, das explodiert gerade auch.
Ja, aber das ist wirklich auf einem anderen Level. Also das ist wirklich das krasseste.
Ich bringe dafür in der nächsten Sitzung mal was mit. Da wollte ich nämlich
mal einen Stillshot hier von uns, wie wir hier in der Meta-Ebene sitzen.
Und dann animieren wir das mal.
Ja, wir kommen darauf zurück.
Lass mal das Video mal jetzt mal so parallel, mal ohne Ton bei dir laufen,
damit du mal irgendwie ein Gefühl bekommst. Das ist wirklich irre.
Und das findet halt alles irgendwie in China statt.
Also ich glaube ja nicht, dass jetzt hier irgendwie keiner sich damit beschäftigt
und ganz ehrlich, Roddy, die Anwendungen sind da.
Also übersetzen, programmieren, Leute machen ihre Textplanung damit.
Also ich kenne so viele Leute, die das machen und das hat sich auch schon so früh abgezeichnet.
Aber das ist ja jetzt kein Chat-GPT.
Was ist ein Chat-GPT? Omni-Human?
Ja.
Nein, aber ich meine, okay, wir
müssen jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen diese Begriffe auseinanderbringen.
Wir haben AI als Technologie, wir haben irgendwie Deep Learning,
wir haben irgendwie Machine Learning, wir haben jetzt irgendwie die LLMs,
wir haben Reasoning-LLMs, wir haben,
Bildgenerierende und Videogenerierende Modelle, wir haben eine komplette AI-Entwicklung,
die jetzt immer weiter geht. Und,
wir nähern uns in sehr vielen Bereichen, vielleicht nicht unbedingt einer Perfektion,
aber die Verbesserungen sind einfach nach wie vor exponentiell und es gibt relativ wenig,
Glaube bei mir, dass das,
dass wir da jetzt schon am Ende der Fahnenstange angekommen sind.
Es wird irgendwie einfach stattfinden. Die Treiber dieser Entwicklungen sind
vor allem in China und den USA.
Nutzer hast du auf der ganzen Welt. Und da ist dann irgendwie mit Europa auch vorbei.
Da haben wir einfach gar nicht mehr die Wissenschaftslandschaft für und schon
gar nicht die Investment Landschaft und wir haben auch nicht das Denken in Europa.
Europa ist so gefangen in seiner Zukunftsangst, da geht gar nichts mehr.
Deutschland ist am schlimmsten, aber der Rest ist auch nicht sehr viel besser.
Da habe ich jetzt jede Hoffnung aufgegeben.
Ich habe noch Hoffnung und das ist doch gut, dass wir hier nicht alle einer Meinung sind.
Ich war heute übrigens in einem AI-Space. Das ist ein Laden hier in einer Shopping-Mall.
Ich habe auch schon ein erstes Foto hier gezeigt. Da gibt es ganz tolle Geräte,
unter anderem ein AI-Neck-Massage-Pillow.
Ich konnte nicht rausfinden, was daran so AI ist.
Außerdem gab es noch eine eine, das ist wirklich ein Produkt,
der hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass ich sowas nochmal sehe.
Und zwar gibt es eine automatische,
Katzenklo, angeblich auch irgendwie AI, ich habe keine Ahnung, was mit AI zu tun hat.
So ein automatisch sich selbstreinigendes Katzenklo, was aussieht wie eine Waschmaschine.
Oh, das hätte ich gerne.
Das hältst du gerne. Warte mal, da kriegst du jetzt hier erstmal noch das Foto im Chat.
Das ist so reinigend eines der wenigen letzten ungelösten Menschheitsprobleme.
Genau, aber auch da sind wir auf einem guten Weg. Das ist definitiv was ab.
Reinigungsgeräte aller Art, die Dinge selbstständig tun, das ist ganz groß, bin ich ein Fan von.
Naja, okay, gut, so viel AI.
Von dieser Omni-Human-Geschichte werden wir auf jeden Fall noch einiges anbieten.
Das ist jetzt spezialisiert quasi auf Menschen. Also dieses Tool,
was ich da gerade im Kopf habe, das muss ich erstmal wieder rauskramen.
Das kann beliebige Szenen halt in den Filmen umwandeln.
Also jetzt nicht nur irgendwie, wir versuchen jetzt einen Sprecher irgendwie
zu symbolieren oder sowas. Ich bringe das in die nächste Sendung mal mit. Das wird lustig.
In einem Film aus Videomaterial.
Du gibst ein Standbild vor und schreibst einem Prompt, was passieren soll.
Und das ist wirklich sehr, sehr weird und sehr, sehr creepy.
Und das probieren wir nächste Sendung mal aus. Es muss hier Cliffhanger geben, wie bei Twin Peaks.
Okay, das heißt, wir sind jetzt over hier mit unserer Sendung.
Ich glaube.
Ich glaube auch, wir haben irgendwie hier schon wieder vier Stunden gearbeitet
und irgendwo muss ein Ende sein, außerdem muss ich ja hier irgendwie unsere
katastrophale Audioverbindung hier noch irgendwie rausschneiden, mal gucken.
Die letzten 45 Minuten waren jetzt ja wieder okay.
Ja, genau, also wer das nicht live hört, wird vielleicht gar nichts davon gemerkt
haben, dass wir hier Aussätze hatten, unerklärlicher Art und Weise,
aber so ist das nochmal bei sieben Stunden Zeitzonen-Differenz,
da kann schon mal was irgendwie schief gehen.
Okay, dann würde ich sagen, machen wir doch hier unsere beliebte,
Abschlussmusik Da kommt sie schon Machen.
Wir den Dackel drauf.
Genau, machen wir den Dackel drauf Und ja,
vielen Dank fürs Zuhören Das war die Freakshow, wir haben ja da viel recherchiert
und diskutiert für euch Machen wir gerne und demnächst machen wir es auch wieder
Mal gucken, wenn die nächste Sendung kommt Und das werden wir euch aber auch
noch mithalten Geht wählen, Leute,
Aber bitteschön. Bis dann.
Keine Nazis. Tschüss.